the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
open at the sinkfield cup in St Louis
despite incredible chess over the boards
the story of the day was Magnus
carlsen's surprise withdrawal from the
event with a super powered wild card no
longer participating the road ahead
becomes much easier for players vying
for crucial tour points however you
would not have known it by the stalwart
defenses on display with all games but
one ending in solid draws Wesley so
holds a tenuous half-point lead with a
crowd of Chasers in Hot Pursuit round
five of amazing chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to day five of
The singfield Cup held at the Saint
Louis chess club this is it the day
before the rest day and the players are
ready to leave it all on the line let's
go to the studio and start today's
action with Yasser Peter and Alejandro
from the home of Chess in America
welcome to the single cup the
centerpiece of the Saint Louis chess
clubs summer of Chess and the last stop
on the 2022 grandchester
hello and welcome back I'm Peter swidler
and with me is yasa serovan the man we
all wanted to be when we grew up
you keep coming up with some different
twists Peter I admire your ability to do
that hello everyone and Welcome to our
broadcast thank you for joining us for
this round five
pardon me after the stunning decision by
Magnus yesterday to withdraw from the
tournament we kind of forgot there a
little bit that there was some really
excellent quality chess that was being
played Peter please do the honors and
tell us our current standings absolutely
after the withdrawal uh our cross table
will look uh slightly more loaded with
data as you can see there on your screen
compared to what it was prior to
magnus's withdrawal because people have
played a different number of games so
this is what this graphic stands for I
think it's somewhat self-explanatory
where season on Two and a Half out of
four which is a plus one score in chess
parlance and then of the people on two
points 250 and two are also on plus one
so in effect Wesley is tied with hers
with the Unicorn Mission Hans Neiman
whilst Fabiano Caron and Elizabeth are
tied and also linear Dominguez are all
on on 50 and then we have three players
uh below below the 50 uh water lines so
to speak well done Peter on the current
standings and our format please
it's a challenge it's a challenge I know
I know I think I did okay you did great
uh and the format now is a nine player
round robin uh a market difference for
what it was three days ago or two days
ago even right uh with 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves and 30 minutes for
the rest of the game 30 second increment
from move one draw first expressed with
forbidden and uh one point where we
don't have a point for a draw as is uh
usual in the classical events and our
schedule Peter uh the remaining schedule
for this tournament is today we have
round five uh the first sorry the last
round before before the rest day and
then we play uh to the end starting from
Thursday and finishing on Sunday
September 11th uh the playoffs for this
tournament if they are required will be
played that same evening and if the GCT
points somehow also end up getting tight
those playoffs will be postponed until
Monday uh September 12th outstanding and
as usual we're very very fortunate to
have in studio Grandmaster alar hondro
Ramirez good morning good afternoon
Alejandro good afternoon guys what a
pleasure to be here yet again in this
tournament which well it has really not
gone the way we thought because a
certain Magnus Carlsen leader at some
point is no longer playing and that
means that there are other players here
now that are looking at that first place
position let's take a look at some of
them let's start with a surprise Javier
Carona had lost a game earlier in this
tournament and it seemed that his hopes
have dwindled a little bit but he came
back yesterday with a strong win against
maxiva Sherlock and today he will be
playing Black against shakurama madirov
a player that fights with both white and
black so that's going to be an exciting
game look at his road ahead he has Jane
pomyachi the day after the rest day and
then he has white finally against Levon
aronian but we do have a leader as you
guys were mentioning that is Wesley so
he'll be playing today against Le
bonaron you will have a rest day then
play against Hans demon and then he will
get another rest day remember that he
will be playing not play round seven
because he was burning his Magnus
Carlsen then and then he will come back
repeat White against alireza farouza so
this is going to be a fascinating
tournament even without the presence of
the world champion and that lack of the
world champion has said the Twitter
sphere and the St Louis chess club
absolutely Ablaze tell us a little bit
about that we have with us woman
Grandmaster Anastasia karlovich thank
you Alejandro what a day it was for
social media I mean everybody was
talking about it since the moment that
Magnus published this tweet telling to
the whole world that he is withdrawing
from the sinkfield cup I mean you cannot
imagine what was happening lots of
retweets lots of likes under his tweet
of course lots of discussions what a
drama it was yesterday and of course for
all our followers if you are still not
following Saint Louis chess club and
grantchester accounts it's really time
to do so you will find lots of
information there so probably we can
check some of the tweets if we we can we
can see them now on the screen so first
of all it was Magnus who came out and we
can see how many retweets how many likes
he got uh it was more than 600 comments
yesterday and of course Robert chess
players came out with their predictions
with their conclusions so first timura
Java was maybe what was covered but we
know that Magnus is actually find this
real well don't worry about his health
then of course Hikaru Nakamura who
always has something to say he had no
words even after he learned the news and
we had also published some interviews
some comments of the players from
singlet Club on our accounts and of
course as we could imagine
World newspaper World lead in newspapers
Financial Times and also German
newspaper did side also published the
news about it Fabiano caruana also came
with his comment after the the round was
over because he wanted to hear more news
as well as we want to hear more news
about what happened what is in the mind
of the world champion right now so yeah
I mean we can see also Financial Times
article about Magnus who just withdrew
from the singford cup in Saint Louis I
saw today Magnus father Henrik and his
men his Peter Hadley Nielsen his second
in the lobby of the hotel they told me
that they are going to leave soon Saint
Louis and unfortunately they will not
come back to Saint Louis because
actually Magnus was not supposed to play
in the next tournament which will happen
after singfield carbon 960 he is not
going to play in any case he was not he
was not supposed to be here at this
period of time so I recommend to
everyone once again to follow our social
media to check all the interviews and
YouTube channels if you didn't do it
yesterday and of course followers team
today back to Peter and Yasser thank you
Anastasia for all the work you do I'm
sure
if you are following those accounts what
are you doing with your life exactly and
Peter lay at the table today what our
viewers can expect in terms of the
pairings uh let's take a look the
bearings for today the one at the bottom
there is kind of sad you have to say
because we would have had alireza feroza
playing Magnus Carlson today that would
have been a wonderful match to be sure
something that all of us always enjoy
watching and talking about but as things
stand we have four games to talk about
and they are Shakira is White against
Fabiano Caron up top there linear
Dominguez plays against one of our
leaders Hans Niemann Wesley so is White
against lebonaronian
is White against Yani pomishi which is
also a very very interesting matchup of
course and there we see our players
arriving for the game exactly as the
players get ready to be wandered and
checked with all the electronic gizmos
that we can possibly muster Peter round
five and for you as we get ready for
this around five this game yesterday
that Fabi played went so long I mean he
won the marathon game today is the day
before the free day in the past how did
you approach this type of game when you
knew a free day was coming up did you
give it your all
um I I think very few people in the
history of I don't know the last couple
of decades ever accused me of giving my
old but uh okay I misspoke there I
understand
but on a more serious note I've I've
often wondered and I think we even had
the discussion maybe even more than once
on air if it's it's difficult because
nobody really thought of doing it from
the beginning and now you have to kind
of track down schedules and and things
of that nature but it would be
interesting to try and collate some some
data on on like the number of decisive
games before before the rest day and
after the rest day uh and see if it
differs in any way from a random around
in the middle of the run I suspect the
difference even if exists even if it
exists will not be huge I think what
people just play the way uh they play
and the thought of
knowing that you can you can play a long
game and not be too tired on the next
day it does enter your mind a little bit
but it still doesn't make you play
entirely unobjectively right it was
something that was in my Consciousness
but I must say that with the no draw
offer of the table you can't just
suddenly stop the game and say yeah yeah
we we've played enough uh I suspect it's
kind of a moot point there you see uh
yeah and you're you're very close with
me and I have what do you have you
spoken with him about magnus's
withdrawal did it impact him I think it
impacted everybody in this tournament I
would be shocked to uh to hear you know
otherwise yeah any of the players say
yeah that's completely completely did
not affect me this is an everyday
occurrence Champion just abandoning a
tournament right one third of a weigh-in
uh no I'm pretty sure it's it's a
talking point for uh for all of these
guys but I I I did have some
conversations with Jan but I I do not
want to be you know putting words in his
mouth sure if he chooses to say
something he will say something we know
he will actually yeah in case yeah in
case of Jan in particular you know you
have you have to assume that he has
something to say we will we will hear
about it right but yeah I'm not going to
I'm not going to uh try and you know
predict what it is or you know
front run it right in any way and uh
Alejandro as the whoops the camera went
on tilt there as uh play gets underway
uh you've had 24 hours yourself to kind
of digest and think about it uh how have
you made peace with magnus's decision or
have you nah there's no making peace
with the fact that we're missing the
world champion in this tournament it is
the same field cup and today
particularly what a mouth-watering
matchup we were supposed to have you
think of alireza farooia playing Magnus
Carlsen and at this point it's a it's a
matchup you just want to see it doesn't
matter where what the time control is
you just want to see it because you love
these Gladiators fighting against each
other so certainly I'm gonna miss him
every time that I see the world champion
Play It's just amazing and to not have
him in the tournament I just can't have
any peace with that but you know the
situation is what it is there's a lot of
rumors online I've been my phone has
been just exploding for the last 24
hours and I thing it's it's set up and
the spotlight in this tournament more
than it already was and when you think
about it everybody was already watching
this and now it's like twofold exactly
exactly
um we're having just a little delay on
my board and because of that reason
Let's uh just remind everybody about the
money what are they playing for in this
uh competition Peter absolutely the
price fund for for the grandchester in
general is the it's the richest
tournament Series in the world and the
prize fund for the classical events is a
very very nice round number of 300 000
uh 350 000 right total with a with a
cool hundred thousand up top there for
the winner uh it's a nice number yeah it
was a nice number to rise on a giant
check and presented the closings exactly
if you're so inclined and logicity
points are of course very much at stake
as well and there I mean this looks like
a cynical way of looking at this but you
know my withdrawal obviously increased
the you know the expected value for a
lot of these players in terms of in
terms of the the GCT running uh in
particular and there is a very nice
additional price fund there for the GCT
and as you can see on your screen a very
very generous uh additional uh price uh
prices being awarded in this tournament
by provided uh generously by Brian
prister who is giving us a price of five
thousand dollars to award to the the
best game of the tournament right the
Brilliance if you all thank you to Brian
who repeats his generous uh prize that
he offered from the previous uh Singh
Phil cup and now again I'm still a
little bit stuck so we're gonna have to
look for at the games perhaps like the
cameras point of view uh the webcams
from the tournament Hall unless you Ali
so if you have an e-commerce for now
yeah this looks like it's like an
Italian uh yeah
and linear is a very very uh experienced
player of of these systems actually with
both colors but mainly with white right
uh he's been playing a lot of uh of the
Joker piano over the past couple of
years and has had good results with it
as well so we'll see uh we'll see how
well Hans is uh prepared for it the line
that Hans appears to have chosen is I
would say these days maybe the absolute
main line of the opening where black I
assume will know castle kingside and
then play rookie 8 Bishop B6 and the
resulting positions uh they favor white
a little bit but they're extremely solid
for black and also very very well
researched by this point which I think
is a major part of the equation here
exactly and again Hans is one of those
players with two points but has only
played three games so he as you say in
the chess Parliament parlance is also a
plus one and we'll keep
obviously our eyes peeled on this one
yeah uh and yeah that is relevant
because on our screen there we see that
they both are they both have two points
but not all two points scores are
created equal right right
not not all two points are equal
something like that
and uh we'll just see if we can switch
games to another ah this is our chakriar
versus fobby game yeah and this is a I'm
not sure about Queen E7 but I do have
memories of this line in general because
I
and those are not pleasant memories
because I uh in the uh last Vikings a
tournament I ever played which I believe
was 2018. I decided to venture into this
particular goes in against
and played it so poorly on the white
side that I could more or less resign by
move 15 I think did resigned by move 22
or thereabouts uh shattier of course is
uh very well aware of how not to play
that position
in part I guess because of that game
against me so he will have an idea Queen
E7 uh the move that uh Fabi has just
played 94 Rook C1 Community seven is new
to me but I would expect that Shakira
may have seen it may have seen it before
it's a very rare move there's a couple
of games there one game by uh even June
uh a very very strong Chinese
player but not a lot of sort of
high-level Grandmaster practice in
general is the Smith Queen E7 connected
with ideas of G5 H5 Peter well the thing
is G5 H5 is very very much at the
Forefront of what black is doing in this
line but I don't know why Queen E7 is
stronger than for instance Knight C6
which I think yeah a 96 is by far the
most fashionable move in this position
and here you get all of this absolutely
mad positions like white can go Knight
D2 yeah the witch black generally just
replies was G5 followed by F5 and we get
into those I was like really really
great maybe not F5 immediately but
Knight C3 Bishop by three and then at
five years right
and this is a very very heavily
trafficked uh theoretical line there has
been a bunch of games by Magnus uh
Magnus I think won some games but also
famously was I think even lost that game
he definitely was lost out of the
opening against Anish gear in one of the
online events I believe last year so
this is as the absolute Cutting Edge of
ragozian theory but Queen E7 is a very
very rare moves right very move Queen E7
again I'm still trying to come to terms
and understand
uh the thought processes behind this
move I kind of understand that E3 yeah I
think we go in yeah
H5 I might get into a little trouble if
I have to play H4 because absolutely
yeah and Knight takes G3 but I'm
wondering again uh that for for me I'm
seeing this position for the first time
any takers for trying to go into a
catalanish looking absolutely but black
generally doesn't have to stalk anyway
like you can maybe still do this they
definitely still do it against you three
even light is on C thick C6 I think one
way and you you I mean I I want to
preface everything I'm saying about this
position by I haven't looked at this and
this is just pure guesswork based on not
even a lot of experience uh with the
opening in general so I has to be taken
with a mountain of salt I think the
difference between Queen E7 and 96
potentially is that in some positions we
will still sort of go in with G5 and H5
and play of that nature if white still
allows it and it's favorable but we're
also preserving the option of playing a
purely Carlsbad structure developing the
pieces by playing C7 C6 and then the
knight from B8 will go to G7 and F6
so we're doing it in a more flexible
fashion like we're keeping both options
open because 96 is a very active move
it's very useful in in a lot of
positions because you're developing a
piece you're controlling the E5 Square
all good things but it also is extremely
committal in terms of how you're going
to develop your queen side because I
think in ragozins you you very very
often will not want your iPhone C6 while
the pawn is still on C7 because you want
to place your 75 agree uh OC 7 C6 so I
think it's just a move which says
show me where you are planning to go
from here and I will adjust accordingly
right which isn't like it's an
interesting and a very valid concept I
think that definitely I agreed with you
all wholeheartedly and I see this uh
constant flexibility in keeping your
options open all the time Alejandro
jumped right in what caught your eye in
this round five let's continue with the
remainder of the games we have this one
between Wesley saw and Levon aronian and
even though this is a very popular line
and it is currently very debated at the
top level I'm not always so happy to see
it Levon has been defending this type of
positions in this Catalan very very
often with this move D takes E4 the very
quick C5 and Wesley has been trying with
the white pieces and with the black
pieces to play this position where they
take on C5 and we get the symmetrical
structure and then after Knight bd2
everybody sheds this Pawn with C3 takes
on C3 and we get this very very heavily
theoretical position after Knight fd4
more people have also tried C4 I believe
this is what we saw in the game between
and alireza ferrugia in the rapid and
Blitz so Knight fd4 was played and most
people here after Knight fd4 play the
move Bishop D7 but Knight takes D4 is
also valid and here is the little twist
or difference Wesley has actually found
himself in this position with the black
side many times uh he lost against mvl
actually defeated Hari Krishna Drew
against weigi so he must have a very
good idea of the subtleties of this
position most people take with the c
Pawn just to fix the structure get some
space on the center but it does have the
drawback that it kills your rook and it
avoids the Knight being able to jump
into the center so instead of this
what's he actually tries a different
approach takes with the Rook instead of
with the pawn that keeps his Pawn
structure shattered but it's obvious
that this Rook has some activity now uh
here Levon played the move E5 I think
that Rook takes D4 is a novelty
according to my database but I'll check
if there's something more recent if I've
played Rook D1 already on the board and
those both players actually played
really quickly we actually transposed
back into a game between universe and
Monica sochko from about 10 years ago
Rook B8 was played actually a shout out
to Monica who just became European
Women's Champion oh very very great
achievement in Prague maybe a week ago
Knight A5 was played right now Bishop C5
and H3 this is the current position that
we have on the board we actually reached
this very quickly both sides with an
more than an hour 30 which is the amount
of time that they started with that
means the increment has get gotten them
this far the move H3 is the best move
according to the engine so no surprise
that both are in Preparation let's try
to break down the position a little bit
this bishop on G2 very powerful against
this Pawn on B7 and this is where most
of White's ideas come in this position
if you play B6 at any point and the move
Knight C6 is very powerful especially
because in this particular structure the
E5 Pawn will be hanging so you cannot
evict the Knight so easily if you ever
play the move Bishop B6 you similarly
have trouble with the pawn on E5 because
now I'm going to be able to Fork your
bishop and the pawn and if you ever go
Bishop C7 Bishop A3 you start seeing how
white spaces come out very very quickly
so no big surprise that Levon actually
chooses the best move according to the
engine as well plays the move H6 just to
prevent the move Bishop G5 it's a useful
Loft at in the long run and I would not
be surprised that Wesley plays quickly
the engines are torn between Knight C4
attacking the pawn on E5 or G4 with the
idea of G5 takes takes and still putting
some pressure on the king side so a
little bit of a quieter Catalan it is
without Queens but at least this one
isn't going into any kind of force
theoretical draw L of the piece is still
on the board but I have the feeling both
of the players are still within their
Theory thank you for that Alejandra as
we see Lavon at the board night on A5
it's a useful piece though because it it
stops black from playing B7 B6 it stops
black from at least comfortably
developing the bishop on C8 without
losing any materials so uh I would maybe
even argue that this is the best piece
why it has right now but it does get
driven away uh eventually I would assume
it's a bit of an awkward position for
black
um
I should quite like I'm surprised the
machine doesn't like it more because
like if I play Ruby one I would be uh
worried I don't know exactly how to meet
this right uh because uh the pawn B7 is
hanging we don't really like playing
Bishop B6 and allowing Knight C4 and uh
we're just uh
generally uh kind of stuck I assume uh
yeah H6 maybe is an indication that you
want to play 5v4 but that also doesn't
really look uh all that great so yeah I
like what Wesley is doing but levonne is
playing quickly enough to uh you know
intimate to to all of us that I've been
here he has seen this before yeah right
he has seen this before so Alejandro
while we're waiting for uh for Wesley to
continue from here uh there is a another
game which we haven't touched uh yet at
all uh with Maxine Michelle Graf playing
White against
uh uh Yandy pomnishi so well let's
finish this thought out first what does
happen against the move Rook B1 and
there's actually two solutions in this
particular position now the engine crazy
type stuff Bishop E4 just shut that on
Rook takes B7 and then Knight E4
supposedly gives you enough compensation
because you have attack on C3 and attack
on F2 and if you have to give back to
pair of Bishops or give away the
terrorist I should say then you have
more than enough according to the engine
however a more sane way to do so
although not necessary it's B6 now
because after Knight C6 thanks for
putting the Rook here apparently the
move Bishop F5 works you could win an
exchange with E4 I think but it's not
enough there's too much activity there
and if you move the Rook somewhere Now
The Rook has E8 to defend upon on E5
from this is the key of the tempo if you
just trade the Rooks in this position by
taking on B8 then after Bishop takes B1
black is according to the engines
completely fine maybe even a little bit
more because remember the structure does
favor Black and this tricks of Bishop
takes H6 can always be met comfortably
with Bishop takes A2 so let's take a
look at the mvl against nepo game to
Great Experts of the Petrov but usually
playing this with white are well both of
them mvl has been playing uh E4 all his
life and he has a lot of ideas against
the Petrov but nepo has been slaying the
Petrov with this particular variation
for years now so I'm wondering exactly
where we're going to see any deviations
now let's go exactly to what happened
Knight takes E4 and we have this
variation of D4 Bishop D3 D5 Knight
takes E5 Knight D7 and here the main
move is Knight takes D7 but people have
been trying Knight C3 pretty frequently
recently in this position and almost
everybody that I've seen including uh
Dominguez that's playing this tournament
a couple of times has taken on E5 and we
all played it against linear earlier on
in this year so this cannot come as a
surprise to Nepal but instead we have
the move Bishop D6 which is also
perfectly playable it was seen in the
game between Oparin and aronian from the
Grand Prix last year and after castle
and Castle we currently have this
position where so far following that
game rookie one is a very common move F4
is not ridiculous at all Bishop F4 is
also fine so we'll see if mvl is able to
find something against nepo's Petrov
which has served him quite well since
the end of the world championship match
thank you for that absolutely and uh
one small point there perhaps is that uh
Jan in round three uh basically I think
you can describe it this way uh
just as we suddenly yeah
bit of good news over there but we'll
see we'll see if it's actual good news
or if it's not uh young in in round
three uh it feels like he just thought
okay better off is solid but not as
spectacular as I would prefer it to be
so why not play the the neither of my my
you know Old Flame from years back right
and that was basically lost by move 15.
so today he feels that yeah I'm I'm not
perhaps that interested in excitement if
that excitement brings me this much
trouble so he is back to uh back to
playing the extremely solid opening uh
that is the Petrov right and uh the the
line that they they're entering right
now is I think very heavily uh
theoretical you're supposed to take with
the bishop white ghost Queen H5
provoking F5 because both H7 and uh nd5
will be hanging there yeah there you see
it on your screen in some positions uh
black has been known to sacrifice the
pawn on D5 but I don't think it's
everything D5 Bishop C6 kind of yes the
old the old art of Yusuf of uh games you
uh there was a bunch of
there was a bunch of uh games uh but
they were in a kind of a related but not
the same line and this line is
tremendously uh tremendously well
researched uh there is a
uh a bunch of games uh I think Jan maybe
won some nice games
uh on the white side of this over the
years but 55. I think to me the most
famous game here because I got to see
that life was young with the white
pieces defeating new Yang Yi at the 2019
Astana world team championship and that
caused such an impression on me because
young finished that game with more time
than he started it was a classical game
just destroyed the Chinese opponent and
I really I'm curious about this line
that being said the move order and I'm
don't remember very well how this
happens but in this particular move
order
the one that we used in this game did
you take with the queen
uh well I think you probably play Queen
H5 queen of three right and uh or maybe
even queen of three straight away but I
I think provoking G6 cannot really be a
big mistake it's not a big mistake but
wouldn't you rather be provoked to play
G6 than F5 well yes but the queen on D7
in front of the bishop on C8 is I think
the major like this is the difference
and uh
uh and this is why I'm bringing this up
uh and if we continue talking about this
position if black stabilizes in the
position you have on your screen right
here black generally will be completely
fine because those these types of
positions where no Knights are left on
the board it's a four Bishop middle game
uh you have to generate some sort of
activity more or less straight away and
white has two plans to choose from uh
one would be after I assume Queen E8
which is oh or bishop8 also exists but
when the queen inevitably is chased away
from the H5 Square uh you can play Queen
H4 or queen of three depending on how
things go and then try to trade the dark
squared Bishops by playing Bush before
and then perhaps uh use the the very
very weak uh Square on E5 to make uh to
make Black's life very unpleasant right
and this does give white a very very
solid stable Advantage for the rest of
the game but I think black often holds
those positions because
the structure is so closed in particular
if you for instance can get with black
you can get time enough to play C6 and
then perhaps B5 to make sure that the C3
C4 break is completely unavailable to
White right that even with the Bishops
coming off yes there will be a rook on
E5
but the structure everywhere is so solid
for black that black can more or less
play around it and then eventually start
trading the Rooks only five right going
rookie a take a five second Rook to E8
and so on and the other plan for white
if allowed would be to play C3 C4 and to
start opening things in the center as
fast as possible
and to me the second plan has always
looked uh sort of the likelier to give
you anything tangible long term but are
dissolving your double pawns as well
Peter absolutely but I don't know you
know once again everything I'm saying
here is
I suspect borderline correct but also
but also very very uh you know
descriptive right and top level chess in
particular when you talk about let's say
mvls and Jan's preparation in the Petrov
this is not descriptive check the chess
this is concrete chess with both of them
I assume actually knowing knowing
exactly what they're doing and move
orders and like subtle differences
between move orders will play I think a
major major role well one question I
might ask for you Peter is in this
position after a move like C7 C6 I agree
with you wholeheartedly C3 C4 is
desirable are you worried about this
bishop on G5 potentially yeah
potentially yes
absolutely yeah but uh I wouldn't
suggest this kind of a line you can try
but I think once again just as a
concrete game and the way you've played
this I think after H6 I very very
happily play C5 and I claim that I'm
winning or rookie won first and then C5
instead of C takes D5 ah sorry just a
second yeah so somebody go back yeah
maybe fi Bishop oops sorry Queen E8 and
I got it wrong I apologize Queen F3
yes four or F4 okay yeah probably one
first okay we have been F7 I play C5 and
I claim that I've won the game pretty
much ah it was a a rook landing on my
doorstep yeah so your point is sort of
well taken and understood you have to
watch out for that tactic yeah but black
is not developed enough I think to uh to
spend a full 10 point five or four yet
if you start with pin F7 and then I do
nothing like Queen F7 here and I yeah
just for arguments yeah I mean I've
plundered the pawn here but I understand
yeah yeah this would be you know giving
me pause with white let's put it like
this exactly Bishop could very easily
get picked up by h67 G5 very cool
Alejandro what has caught your attention
as we're going through this Petrov I
always like simple questions that have
tough answers when you make a move in
chess so here Wesley thought for a while
put the Knight back on C4 and the simple
question is how do you defend this Pawn
on E5 and the answer is not so logical
to me because I was thinking well don't
you just play rookie 8 and then I
realized wait a second that doesn't
depend upon at all I can still take here
and if you take on E5 I play Bishop F4
and look at this cure it's actually
going to cost you a full Rook not just
an exchange from here so you're not
actually getting two pieces for a rook
now you could argue that the line
continues because you could play Rook
takes E2 and Eyeball the point on F2
another way to do this the engine say
just give up the pawn bishop F5 Knight
takes E5 and then continue with
something like 94 or first Rook Fein and
then 94 just shutting the pawn
completely saying you know what we have
enough compensation with play against
the E2 Pawn later the C3 Pawn the Knight
coming to E4 now is this apparently
obvious I I wouldn't be so sure about it
because Knight D3 is a Tempo it does
cover F2 you don't want to take on D3
and allow Pawn takes D3 so I don't think
it's immediately obvious how you defend
this spawn and Knight C4 Levon finally
thinking here perhaps he didn't consider
this one in his preparation or he's
trying to remember exactly what his file
said
thank you indeed uh Alejandra I'm still
having a little trouble in one
particular game Peter what is caught
your uh I this Wesley so game Knight C4
yeah unless C4 is an interesting move
and a a move which I think
if you don't know I mean it's it's
understandable what's happening here but
still I think you you have to be aware
of this tactic existing from exactly
sort of going into the line and both of
them are playing very very quickly so
yes I'm pretty sure they both looked at
this right and if we if we discuss uh
the the variations continuing from here
that exchange sacrifice that uh
Alejandro Alejandra mentioned uh did
seem interesting uh you do most likely
after rookie 2 Bishop takes B8 you'll
quite likely will have to spend the
tempo on yeah on uh playing Bishop c86
maybe even straight away right just to
make sure we never blunder it through
DHC tactics exactly but then we have we
have a very very serious amount of
compensation against the one the white
king side I think if they have to pawn
Falls we generally are not going to be
much worse at all uh and if you play
Rook of one you can play for positional
compensation even something uh as uh
restrained as neither 64. I'm just
saying I don't want to win anything in
particular straight away I just want to
get rid of that Bishop on G2 please give
me that bishop and then we'll go from
there exactly because it's like Bishop
F3 I think looks like Rook takes F2 I'm
actually interested in Bishop 3 Because
as usual I am as wide here extremely
interested in the energy of getting one
pair of Rooks off the board absolutely
this is a this is a very well of a you
know a favorite topic of mine of just
how useful it is to get rid of that
active Rook right but I will pick up
like half the half the king side right
Knight takes F2 H3 will fall I will put
the Knight on G5 I think I have
compensation here I don't know if it's
full compensation but I definitely have
compensation here as black uh and Knight
E4 is not forced against 90. yeah
instead of 94 we can try other things as
well exactly A2 is hanging I don't know
if I can take but it's hanging right
uh and a very very interesting move has
been made by by Hans Neiman in that
gioko piano I don't think I've ever seen
that approach oh uh uh okay so uh
perhaps
uh we can do it this way uh they played
they played kind of in a very very
normal fashion up until uh move nine and
then Hans went for a setup which
I I don't I don't believe I've seen
before at all it exists in some other
positions but I haven't seen this in my
database either Bishop B3 was played in
this position Yasser I think that you're
like Bishop B3 yes okay and Hans
answered immediately with move C5
whoa whoa yeah everything I know about
Chess
in the case that this is a terrible move
right against all of your light squares
it kills the bishop on A7 but it's the
top engine move when you let it run for
a little bit really of course and
apparently just the seizing of the space
and more importantly stopping the 3D
foil stopping the entire idea of the
Italian for white which is D3 D4 and
forcing white to go for a completely
different approach
it's a very valid way of playing and
linear is currently faced with this new
idea
I'm still coming to grips with it I I
know these chagorians from the rui Lopez
but in all of those the black squared
Bishop is not sitting on the A7
sitting on f8 or E7 yes in a way I feel
like it might eventually not transpose
the move order will be completely
different the uh the position will be
new
but you do see this in the once again
I'm struggling to pick a name out of all
the names this line is called but like
the the modern archangels your die of
Mueller whatever you want to call those
right those positions where blood goes
Bishop C5 Bishop by seven against the
Spanish right with the inclusion of B7
B5 and then the bishop gets developed to
B7 that setup exists right with the pawn
on B7 and in general in Italians you're
kind of unused to the idea of playing B7
B5 voluntarily right because why give
white a Target on the queen side when
there were none exactly uh but this
setup with the bishop on B7 and the
bishop on A7 definitely exists and it's
not bad it's not bad because you are
considering the fact that in most of
these positions White's General plan
very much revolves around the swimming
control in the center with d3d4 your
Bishop pair on B7 and A7 is extremely
well equipped exactly
dealing with specifically with this yeah
exactly because D4 you know our Bishop
on A7 instantly becomes a very very
active piece and the bishopon B7 will be
providing pressure against the pawn on
e4 which will be weakened by the fact
that white played Knight of fun I think
has been played yeah allow me to play
the uh yeah let's go this way let's go
B5 here and see how it turns like b593
which would be seven right uh
I'm a bit worried I might get mated
after Knight H4 that was that is my
worry here uh thanks for uh pointing the
the the gun in which direction I think
apart from this plan not very much
really is happening for white but this
plan is very dangerous yeah just a very
straightforward queen of three followed
by Knight and five followed by something
on the king side right uh but yeah it's
a very interesting concept it's very
unusual in Italian specifically but if
you continue looking at moves further
down the road I think you start
glimpsing uh you know outlines of things
which we have seen from different tops
this feels very dangerous
sacrificed anything and maybe you're
taking too many risks Knight E7 if it
were to go to G6 maybe bishop B6 yeah
right I just hate the structure with a
passion but maybe I shouldn't as as
black yeah I I always try to avoid
allowing this doubling of the pawns on
E6 but once again if you look at this
normally our Pawn is on C7 and the Y
bonus on B4 yep and he's actually played
Bush B6 very quickly without even
Nigeria without this is what this is
what Hans means to do here
um
and
honestly I think the fact that there's a
Pawn on C5 and upon on B2 limits uh
whites options in the center and on the
queen side right tremendously well right
and and I think Bishop B6 without 96
indicates it might just go back to C6
to further reinforce the idea that you
know None Shall Pass we have full
control in the center yeah please
demonstrate what you play even it's
funny that you should say the Knight
comes back to C6 because one of the
ideas that had filtered in my mind was
idea playing A4 A5 and kind of clamping
down on the queen side and then suddenly
the move Knight C6 was a little
off-putting I mean I put my Pawn on pre
essentially with the move A4 A5 a very
different approach for sure I don't see
any real problems unless as you say
you're loathed to play this uh
structure as a black and maybe there are
issues Alejandro how about you well that
looks very well
that did not look like that five minutes
ago I I can tell you this much exactly
this is a very fobby prep when you think
about Fabiano carono with the black
pieces he loves complications he loves
trying to get his opponents in some kind
of mess from the get-go and he's not
afraid of bluffing a little bit I'm not
sure how much of this is a bluff and how
much of this is good so we're going to
go back all the way to this position my
Madara did play the move Knight D2 which
is the most natural move why because you
need to evict this Knight and because in
certain occasions this bishop needs to
retreat to G3 and this Knight can't be
targeting it anymore so 1963 was played
bx3 Bishop A3 Rook B1 these are all very
logical moves
castles was played and here after some
thought mamadier played technically a
novelty the move E3 Knight F3 and Rook
B3 had been played before but of course
this is the most natural move just
trying to develop the bishop and in game
G5 Bishop G3 F whoa so that was not it
F5 in this position and that with the
very clear indication that F4 is coming
there's only one good move in my opinion
here I mean queen B3 the engine side
doesn't lose but Bishop B5 is the only
thing I can really think of the idea is
that if white gets in the move F4 yes
there's a lot of weaknesses behind the
bishop but you're not getting past that
monster on E5 and if you ever take it
with the Knight on C6 or D7 then you're
just giving me a protected pass Pawn for
the rest of the game and that is going
to be a good strategical Advantage
unless there's something immediate it
keeps doing that F4 Knight takes E5 F
takes E5 and now if you give me a couple
of Tempe for white you play the move
Bishop D3 you could short Castle in a
good day you put the queen on H5 then
Black's position is just bad this pair
of Bishops is going nowhere this bishop
is kind of bad the bishop on E6 is going
to be locked in actually the Knight one
day if it gets to F4 is just
strategically winning but it's not you
know blight has not fully developed
black has a couple of Tempe to do
something and in this case it's boom F4
and you know that five is had this
position on the board today an hour and
34 minutes for him he has not thought
for a second mama jar of already
spending more than 20 minutes to get
here and the question is how does
Muhammad yarov proceed from here now if
you take on F4 then you don't take back
which is kind of funny the engine says
play C5 open more stuff go for the king
this guy is going still far away from
castling and it doesn't amount how many
doesn't matter how many points you have
you just try to break open the structure
more and more the ideas that you take on
the four take on D4 take with the Rook
so that the pawn on D4 will be hanging
it also allows me to play Bishop E4
checks in case the Knight leaves D2 very
cool stuff now of course nothing is
compelling my mediara to take on e4 he
could just play the move E4 this is a
nice uh tactical trick well not
necessarily a tactical trick but here if
you take on e4 you don't have the ideas
of C5 breaking open the center because
Queen B3 check targets the king and now
that you've cut the communication
between the queen and the bishop this is
no longer possible so uh you might want
to play E4 in this kind of positions to
try to open up the diagonal the engines
are saying that if they do if my Madero
does play E4 then of course G4 you
continue and yes you do follow it up
with the move F3 trying to get to that
King fascinating stuff here by Favi the
best move according to the engine just
play it cool and smooth play the move
Bishop E2 with the idea that if you take
on E3 you Retreat the Knight and then
recapture on E3 with the Knight with a
very solid position however I figure
that this is actually really hard to
play because Bishop P2 giving up the
pawn is not immediately intuitive
especially since it opens up the Rook on
the file which means that you might not
be able to Castle for a very very long
time great stuff here for Favi and his
second you know that they work very hard
and it seems like shock is being caught
in a web right now wow thank you for
that uh Alejandro this very concrete
approach but I wanted to ask you Peter
after the move E3 E4 that to my mind is
an attempt to refute whatever it is that
black thinks he's doing I'm countering
in the center
Alejandra mentioned G4 I'm the pond
grubber yeah
it's not even with the pawn grabbing we
want to generate a pathway for a king a
way for check ideas exactly yeah I mean
room if you will yeah I would be uh you
know if I had to if I had to talk about
this position this is definitely one of
those positions where I would you know
ask for my you know five minutes of
silence before I I I say anything at all
so that not to look entirely stupid
right I have no idea what this is at
first glance it looks like it shouldn't
work for black but on the other hand my
king is only one I expect it probably
does not get to Castle in this game no
I'm worried in particular against a very
very well prepared opponent it's in
shock by this point did decide on
something he played a very striking move
he played Bishop on D3 just ignoring
everything altogether saying I need to
finish development I'm giving you my E3
pawn and I assume the idea is to play
Knight of one right and recapture it
this way uh there is Queen F7 in this
position which needs to be addressed but
I guess he is he means to play Queen E2
or queen of three Queenie two I guess
well a check could land on the doorstep
and we could maybe clean up yeah I don't
know this this looks uh this looks very
very unclear and perhaps all radius that
keep going guys we're just having Queen
it Queenie two queen F7 Queen E2 Queen
F2 Check Yes and the engine says you
know what king do you want D1 yeah
because Bishop G4 is not based in some
positions in some positions Bishop G4
would be made because we have this
all-important Knighton F1 protecting the
G2 Square Bishop G4 is not made remember
what that Larson said with the Knight on
F1 I don't get mated but that was
right yeah
F takes you three blitzed out of course
uh Fabi will have looked at all of the
uh obvious captures and Bishop D3
definitely is included in the list of
moves what a person can play in this
line so every three Knight F1 on the
board this is again Queen F2 check King
D1 that is I want to say queen of seven
is not forced I would be interested in
the move C7 C5
uh I don't know if it's any good but I
would be interested 93 CD4 CD4 Bishop
before chair give the king stuck in the
center but it feels like maybe in the
end there uh in the end there the of the
line that we're discussing the king is
reasonably safe on it too maybe it's
just nothing just go King into here and
say that uh I'm okay Queen B3 coming
Rook F1 coming there's not a single
check to this King currently available
yeah but it's a little scary for white
it's just varies
at the end right yeah exactly I thought
I thought it was nothing but no sorry
CDC
and then I realized Queen F7 exists once
again
with checks from F2 and H5 on tap and
okay the one on F2 is not the check
the one left two is uh
senior check that would be hurtful
indeed and uh Rook F1 Queen I mean the
initiative is definitely this looks
horrible yes this just looks straight up
horrible okay so so yeah probably where
we're gonna go event after Knight F1 C5
looks like the most testing by far yeah
I think we're choosing between kind of
queen F7 and C5 I don't really foresee
anything else being in the running
because allowing white to take only
three unopposed just gives white uh so
much extra time so I think this is the
my current you know Far and Away top two
choices for black guys
I'll show a couple of lines from this
position please from all the way here
with the move Queen F7 at the end with
C5 and C takes D4 included we got all
the way here and I was wondering what
does white do this position yeah and I
saw the Arrow Bishop H7 is one move what
queen takes H7 and Rook takes B4 because
you get the bishop right and you don't
you cannot take with the King
uh because after Rook takes before
apparently the king is pretty safe
on D3 so I'd rather take with the queen
and then after Rook takes before play
the move B6 and somehow you're getting
checked from every angle but this is not
forced uh if you don't want to take on
H7 and you shouldn't there's a move that
actually defends
against both Queen H5 and queen F2 which
is this ridiculous looking book Queen G1
if you play check now thanks to the
queen here I have G4 and white is just
winning because this bishop is hanging
and you don't have Queen F2 obviously so
you have to move the bishop somewhere
and then you have time for Rook F1 of
course the engines think that this is
zero zero because after Rook F1 I can't
capture on F1 actually I have to you
cannot take with the Knight well you
can't take with the Knight because check
here and Rook F4 is of course equal of
course of course what on Earth are these
lines guys and well Fabi is thinking
right yeah he is finally thinking he
might be remembering his prep but he
plays C5 he played C5 he played C5 C5 is
on the board we might be going for
something like this guys yeah no
probably Fabi knows and uh I assume
Bishop D3 I mean has to be in the top I
don't know five and if you if you're
doing your due diligence properly in a
position after fe5 F4 you should be
looking at pretty much every single
developing move
[Laughter]
each and every turn I must say uh is
just ridiculous wow uh how did we get
that record Bishop C3 Bishop C3 and just
snap it off and of course Queen too just
snap it off yeah it's it's hanging can't
you see it's hanging
I'm gonna keep my mouth zipped from now
on Knight takes F1 Bishop G4 and Rook F4
is of course and the question is why are
we not losing exactly and the reason
we're not losing is Bishop takes H7
followed by King D3 oh my word to
prevent Bishop takes D4 from and our
Queen's traps Yeah Yeah from winning
everything and now it will only win
something Bishop D4 I'm pretty sure
we're not going 93 there pretty sure
we're actually taking on D4 and going
for that
uh a good General should lead us yeah
and honestly the second game I'm curious
why why black is not hours maybe black
is not worse because Bishop F5 check or
yeah okay and then after King E3 I want
to play rookie for check
I believe this is correct but I kind of
want to prevent the night I understand
the E3 Square very easily nice nah yeah
this is absolutely absolutely ridiculous
like way too much fun like they're
absolutely I mean five years probably
having fun uh as well I don't know about
Shah because as as we've established
shot does like interesting chess he's
definitely not lying when he says that
it's his prior you know primary
motivation for playing chess these days
is just to play interesting uh Fighting
Chess exactly uh but you know even if on
some level he's enjoying the Mayhem that
his position looks like on the on on a
different level it's he he is still
playing against five is prep right if
you had this position and felt like he's
on equal footing with his opponent
that's one thing right but playing that
position and not knowing when the
blitzing will stop is uh is less fun
exactly I wanted to say uh we have a
very different approach yeah I liked all
of the things that you had pointed out
in the mvl versus nepo a game of c3c4
rookie one Bishop F4 playing to control
and that game actually is very very far
progressed exactly after 4h6 uh the game
continued which before okay and here Jan
just snapped on a four and played Queen
D6 which is an approach you don't see
very often because of how Grim it looks
optically but I guess it's fine going to
six Queen takes the six Rook fb1 through
kb8
a41 yeah Rook AB8 A4 and Rook fc8 on the
board so far and this is where mvl is
thinking uh generally
like fun is unlikely to be had by anyone
here but specifically by black right
because the bishop on D3 is just so much
stronger than the bishop on D7 white
eventually could get let's say his King
over to G2 that probably results in the
pawn on C3 being well defended well
defended for the rest of the game and
then white you know frees up here for
his Rooks and tries to generate some
activity I think we are probably playing
B7 B6 here because it feels to me that
allowing a4a5 with the pawn on B7 would
be a major major exactly exactly and now
we're always ready to meet A5 with B5
that would be the point uh to to not
allow uh yeah the creation of any kind
of an isolani for for black owners I
like the what you suggested bringing the
king very much I like your suggestion
bringing the king to D2 but the speed of
which uh nepo has played kind of
indicates to me that this might still be
in his preparation well I mean they had
to look at the petrol very very
seriously and this is one of the
fashionable lines this is one of the
lines he himself used as Alejandro
described to great effect on on the
white side of it so absolutely no reason
for him not to take this seriously for
him and his team when they were
preparing for Dubai absolutely yeah I I
think you're right I think this probably
is still leftovers from
from the Dubai prep for for young
leftovers nice actually he hasn't played
Basics it surprises me he's got seven
he's going okay three king of seven yeah
very very quickly so uh
yeah I'm a bit surprised by this I would
be very very low through
uh Leave myself with this Pawn on B7
which can be pressured
and let's just uh take a a gander at
this maybe he wants king of six G5 and I
gain some space on the Queen's on King
side but I don't know what that does
even if it does happen like what what
does that do white can ignore it well
one of the things you pointed out is the
potential that the light squared Bishop
could end up being a passive Peace
by five yeah try to continue gaining
space precisely precisely so
um might be something King F7 on the
board I will keep our eye on that
because okay it's nice it's technical
but it's dry it's an end it is a very
drying game and we've got these
excitement going on between Shack and I
think shock is still thinking of the C5
sorry I kind of lost track of it how is
Lanier doing with uh
um since Bishop E6 yeah he's gone 93
Hans replied with Queen D7 so now that
linear did not take only six uh black is
with 27 maintaining it is the option of
recapturing with the queen I don't know
how happy you are about that though
because I think one of the things white
could legitimately aim for in this
position is let's say Bishop takes E6
okay and if you take with the queen okay
I will play C3 C4 and kind of shut this
bishop down in particularly if I can get
a 485 in as well but I mean I I can't
really be greedy you probably will do
something about that right but I want to
play 95 next move and I want to claim
that if if you take your position is
definitely a bit worse because it opens
up the C4 Square for my second night and
if you don't take like how easy it is to
just completely ignore that knife for
the rest of the game no no I don't like
that night sitting and our Bishop on E3
or D2 will be much more active than that
guy on A7 which is now completely locked
out of the game pretty much for the rest
of it so I get the feeling that despite
the fact that Queen D7 has been played
if white trades only six black probably
still takes with the pawn I don't I
don't like this at all I think this just
gives white uh a bit too much of a free
roll let's just play one two moves here
I you know what I wanted to play of
course is I wanted to play Knight B4
completely forgetting yeah you have to
spend a ten point something else yeah
yeah just to let's go look somewhere
yeah
okay I'll pick a square let's go A5 here
I really like having the pawn yeah lock
lock down so to speak yeah let's go
Bishop couldn't be three Queen B3 okay
and finally let's get rid of this okay
she takes C takes so I'm hoping that
somehow you're going to be agreeable and
open up this bishop for me go Bishop to
D oh but you got a C4 Foursquare don't
you yeah I just got 92.94 here I think
this is the first order of business I do
everything else later it's still not
that clear you can go at five or four
and claim that eventually there will be
a pawn
storms
a long-term uh weakness I don't I don't
like this at all uh it becomes very
double-edged I I think
in particular in terms of developing
counter play I think you take with the
pawn only six if this happens and
finally I know you're loath to do it but
in case
I had recaptured with the pawn are you
still in the c3c4 no I think I think
here I mean without the G5 Square
available to the Knight on E3 I mean
it's a safe move you can make this move
to be safe maybe but it makes I think
very very little sense strategically
because black has just everything
covered I got you uh on the other hand
you're not playing D3 D4 you're not
playing F2 F1 I don't hate this for
black I think uh this actually makes a
decent amount of sense yeah maybe before
before we can take take 96 so that our
Bishop is back to being alive that is
true and the four square is available to
our pieces I don't hide this at all for
black all right and Alejandro uh what do
you have for us in this exciting round
five well let's see how Levon solved
this issue of the Pawn on E5 and in this
case he went for the sacrificial
variation of the Pawn on the exchange
with rookie and Bishop F5 this is what
the engines like the most and now it's
up to Wesley to try to defuse this now
let's see what are some of the his
possibilities the first one I mentioned
was simply to play the move Knight D3
this attacks the bishop on C5 so I don't
have time to take on E2 now white has
two main black has domain ideas against
this one would be to counter pin the
Knight on D3 to The Rook on D1 an
interesting idea here for sure but I
think it's more natural to just Retreat
the bishop back to B6 get it away from
the attack of the knight from D3 now
you're gonna be able to take on E2 next
move and if you decide to defend the
spawn I'll continue the pressure I'll
play Rook BCA start hitting the pawn on
C3 and then really gang gap on it I'm
gonna follow this up with the move 9 E4
according to the engines there is
compensation for the pawn the other way
to do so is to start with the move G4
trying to Define where this bishop is
going to go if you take on E5 then I
don't take on F5 that would be kind of
silly because after taking and taking
I'm just at opening Avenues against my
own position but instead it's this the
old trick of Bishop F4 securing the
Rooks and since I'm still hitting the
bishop on F5 I do win the exchange as
white so G4 is certainly possible there
are possibilities here Bishop C2 you
could play Bishop E4 if you Retreat all
the way to H7 then this allows me to
play Bishop F4 now what is the
difference of course that if I play
Bishop F4 in this particular position
after Bishop F5 then you get hit with
the move G5 this is one of the many
points of the move H6 and you don't have
any squares on this diagonal and that's
how logically we get to the move G4 you
spend a Tempo or and try to regain it by
kicking out the bishop so that I can
play Bishop F4 and then Retreat to G3 if
need be when I hit with a move G5 so a
lot of things to calculate here for both
players I think they're definitely out
of theory by now Wesley down to an hour
and six considering that he got out of
the opening with something like an hour
and 34 only two or three moves ago
thank you Alejandro and as we prepare
for a break what's what's new at Q
Boutique here and today is a very
exciting uh very exciting thing that
we're promoting uh and uh it is this
very very nice little book and this is a
one-of-a-kind workbook which is meant
for anyone learning chess notation it's
developed by Dr Jeannie singfield the
co-founder of the Saint Louis chess club
and sparehead of the Boy Scouts chess
merit badge and it has everything you
needed so uh it basically teaches you
notation teaches you all the things that
will be required for you to continue
studying chess it's great for any
beginning chess player and what's even
better it's downloadable for free from
the cubicstl.com so this is a a public
service that Dr Jeannie singfield and
and the club and and cubic are doing
together so this is a very very uh nice
nice thing a little background about
this uh Jeannie got tired of sitting in
conversations with all of these chess
players uh speaking Greek of Bishop to
F6 Queen F6 she said I've got to learn
notation and the moment she learned the
notation then she exploited all the
people that come to St Louis and said
you speak Dutch translated into Dutch
did she get you to translate the Russian
no then she got Almira she exploited
everybody but it's downloadable for free
it is as you said this is this is a very
very nice picture and I'm highly
appreciate it absolutely and as we go to
rake we have a feature for you we hope
you enjoy it
[Music]
thank you
going into the final leg of the grand
chest tour how do you feel you've
performed up to this point and how do
you hope that you're going to finish oh
well I didn't play well in Romania I
scored 50 but
the quality wasn't there and the result
wasn't enough you know to Garner many
Grand Tour points as for uh the
singfield cup yeah my classical play has
been pretty poor recently so I'm hoping
to recover from that my last result
wasn't great I didn't do very well in
Instagram although I I Was preparing
quite quite well and I was
doing my best but it didn't go well the
first one was was quite decent in in um
in Romania so yeah the plan is just to
to finish well okay for me it's not big
chance to to to be in top three in this
time last year I played much better I
will just see like it's very super
tournament and I will try to play good
chess interesting chance and try to play
much better than first two tournaments I
mean Zagreb and in Bucharest I've
performed well in terms of points for
sure because I am among first three
players
having played a few events so you know I
have a good feeling that I could do well
no with that being said the way I played
was not always that convincing in Boss
Bucharest and tagweb so I worked up a
lot of points
but I feel like I will have to play
still even better you know to to take it
to Nature
yeah I performed um not very well I
think just throughout the tour but I
have a feeling I could improve my
results in the Tour by playing here I
think I have a great chance I played
well in zocgrab but in Romania I didn't
play so good so I'm looking forward to
improving my performance here
frankly I don't even know what is my
like status right now like how many
points the third points do I have I
assume not so much yeah because I did
quite poorly in Bucharest as it seems
after Madrid it was more or less for the
for the battery yet we have some nice
training so here of course it would be
not about training what about I hope it
would be about like achieving some high
results and yeah
I'll try to try to fight
as hard as they can they fill up
competition this year compared to last
year uh players have brought first you
just won a big tournament also Maxim is
playing really well
in order to fight for a standing clear
can have to win some games like plus one
plus two
probably plus three is enough to win the
same field Club but
we'll see what happens uh just like to
take it a game at a time try to come to
the games very well rested and try to
play well and see where things go
well I've had a lot of experience
against these guys and let's see rapid
and Blitz event online events so
I feel like I know these people quite
well and
I don't necessarily feel like um I'm
completely that inferior to them so I'm
just looking to to show my my best chess
and and to show that uh I can compete on
an equal level with the top players in
the world and uh
as long as I show that then I'm sure
that it won't be the you know last
single cap that I play I'm more or less
satisfied because I'm in the contention
so yeah I really would like to win it
because I never won uh just a tea tour
and I always like collecting new
victories
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome back to our continued
coverage of round five of the sinful cup
and uh plenty of excitement today in
particular we are
kind of in strong disbelief watching
watching Fabiano show some really really
uh you know high-tech prep in his game
against uh Shakira majara of this one is
somehow it's gone beyond world class as
it did I mean it really is extraordinary
it's got 90 minutes on his clock they're
on move 21 and he's been playing all the
temple Shack has been you know 40
minutes studying the position he we've
reached the position actually that we
looked at Peter some time ago yeah Queen
G1 and Bishop C3 on the board I wanted
to to say that uh perhaps you know
players in particular shock here not so
much for Brianna but Chuck definitely
right right this moment looks like he's
preparing for the
960.1 looks like it does look uh 960-ish
yeah yeah a little bit and we went Rook
F1 and we understand why because
otherwise it's very awkward to defend
the pawn dude defending the default Pawn
is very very awkward Queen takes F1
can't be the only remove Peter Well if
you have to consider Queen H5 maybe not
so much I think you've got to play G4
yes but uh H5 is just not such a great
Square
because you're going to take on I think
I'm taking you know I think I'm taking
here Rook G1 Rook G1 and I feel that
Rook G1 Rook G1 and you feel that well
black has to be careful because G5 is
hanging and the white pieces are very
very active D5 is also hanging maybe you
have time to play H7 H6 but okay this
this looks potentially quite dangerous
quite risky I I don't whiskey for the
the black side and therefore it is why
Alejandro in this position uh proffered
[Music]
white might have a draw there but
you have to fight for equality okay so
we got here and everything seems to be
rather forcing
and after uh now we have an issue yeah
absolutely and uh Alejandro please jump
in on this one because we are at our
Wit's End no not at all I mean you guys
are doing great uh Rook F1 Queen H5 is
actually inaccurate because of the
everything you were mentioning takes
takes on H5 is important takes on G1
takes on G1 you do have to play the move
H6 but it doesn't matter you go H4 and
reinforce the attack on the G5 Square
Bishop takes D4 H takes G5 you have to
get out of this somehow either after
Bishop takes E5 first check King a chain
and you do take on D5 at the end now
this might be holdable but it's very
risky mainly because you haven't
developed yet so you are faced with
sometimes some mating patterns also the
fact that this Pawn can get to H7 and
it's difficult to challenge it's not
very pleasing for the black side so
after Bishop C3 Rook F1 no the computers
are pretty adamant that you have to take
on them you have to take on F1
uh you could take on a phone with the
queen here it is possible but it's the
it's a very similar to what we just
looked at except the king side doesn't
collapse for black if you take on D5 and
take on E5 the engines are saying maybe
you should play Knight F5 because this
are checkmating ideas with 97 check or
not H6 you have to take on F5 and after
Rook takes F5 they evaluate this as
approximately equal or it will get a
pawn back very soon because of the power
of the E6 Pawn but it's opposite color
Bishops they should end in some kind of
draw some how
um so let's go for the juicy one take
with the Knight
Bishop G4 is of course forced King E3 is
of course the only move and Rook F4
shouldn't come to a surprise as anyone
since Bishop takes D4 is such a
humongous threat now there's only one
good way of Defending here nothing else
works if you allow Bishop takes the
force queuing the queen that's game over
so the only move is Bishop takes H7
check King takes H7 is The Logical move
King D3 defends let's call it that the
pawn on D4 the idea is that if you do
take on D4 you take back you take with
the queen queen take Rook takes King
takes and actually this is pretty
dangerous for black if you count the
material it's absolutely even not
against Bishop the difference this king
of D4 it's great it's a little bit of a
target with a middle game even without a
queen but when you transpose into an end
game the king is fantastic on D4 it's
blocking the pawn it's attacking the
pawn now coming to E3 much better than
the King on H7 for sure this is very
difficult to survive for black so you
don't take on D4 you instead play the
move Rook C8 first keep the king and
snerd on the D3 square and force white
to still find good moves Bishop F5 is a
bit of a threat Bishop takes D4 has been
reinforced uh Knight G3 is the only move
it's not a difficult move to find I
think because you do have to cover the
F5 square and the engines are saying
that here after the move Rook C4 again
only one move to for to still keep
equality for white
and it's Queen B1
guys good luck to shock
good luck honestly looking at everything
you've just shown us I think he goes
Rook F1 Fabi blitzes out Queen takes F1
and he just takes with the queen yes I
think he just takes practical in
Practical terms no way you're entering
any of those positions against somebody
on 130. yeah the only unfortunate thing
is that we see all of this cool prep
yeah and we might be thinking of an
absolutely drawn Bishop fan game very
very soon it is very regrettable that
the move Queen takes a fun exists
because otherwise it will be so exciting
to watch an absolute world-class player
show us how they work out all of these
details over the board against the well
prepared opponent and I think Shaq is
capable of actually navigating
navigating all of these positions quite
well but I just think he says to himself
why would I do this he didn't even think
about it he saw Queen takes F1 boom
instantly
any of this yeah
away with you yeah zero zeros of course
Bishop takes D4 on the board he has
choices here he could play H4 you just
don't take on D5 I think because the
after Bishop G4 check it's not so this
one is a bit worse this one is a bit
worse you don't want to do that just
just play Knight F5 yeah the other five
is very good and we should show The
Mating thread to where you were
describing Bishop takes E5 check on h8
King h8 Rook f8 check thanks for not
developing your pieces King G7 Rook F7
check this is why I didn't start with
King G7 now it doesn't matter if you
take my knight or you go to h8 it's the
same Checkmate Rook takes H7 just
finishes the game so important for
mahmet I think to equalize easier to
play the move Knight F5 I suspect a
couple other moves are also possible but
I think Knight F5 once you found it find
it it's it's so obvious yeah wow and
just again to buttress the obvious uh
131 yeah
54. happy and he's been blitzing
glitching sorry uh I think Bobby will
make Zero moves today Zero moves I think
the entire game will be on fire you will
have played the move Bishop takes E I
mean pardon me Knight F5 Bishop takes F5
I think
G5 King h8 I think this is what and you
just Blitz all of this stuff out because
I don't think this even looks like black
is better if you don't immediately
attack the E5 but you can play h7h6
instead of instead of rookie eight but I
don't think it looks like you're better
no like Bishop B5 V6 is seven you can I
mean yes uh I started to get a little
bit worried that I mean there is there
is Rook F6 there I'm we're actually not
using this but it looks very very level
and uh by the way once again not just
world-class uh preparation this is
something that is just extraordinary
what was your best experience in terms
of a prep that just went unbelievably
well
um I won a game against my my friends
Sasha grishock in the Mexico City uh
World Championship you know seven and
the last round we both had a ably
horrendous tournament
but then uh my at the time second
Alexander mothadov worked something out
in a very topical line of the naidorf
and I think I started playing roundabout
move 28. everything was going swimmingly
and until that moment in particular
considering the stakes and the
importance of the stage I mean neither
of us were in running but it's still a
world championship tour exactly so uh I
think that's the one
as well and for you Alejandro you're
like ultimate most wonderful prep that
just went swimming I played this game in
the Olympiad against uh I think it's a
Grandmaster now but I think he was an
international Ambassador back then from
the Faroe Islands uh helgi siska and I
got a lot of prep in like I found this
really nice idea in the king's Indian
fiance variation I sacrificed a pawn and
my position was just winning from the
opening I converted very nicely but two
months later I was playing another
International master who hadn't seen
that game and I beat him exactly the
same way and I was very proud of that
one because I won two games in two
months without making a single move
that's that's pretty darn good yeah two
for one or as well yeah and the thing is
this used to be quite I mean I wouldn't
say uh a frequent occurrence but it
definitely used to be something that
happened in the pre-internet era where I
you know I I'm sure all of us have heard
stories of people are sort of hoarding
their opening ideas exactly asking for
like bulletins not to publish their
games so that opponents couldn't do any
research right there's a couple of names
that immediately spring to mind from my
childhood there was an international
master in then learning graduate wasn't
even Saint Petersburg yet uh who was a
an avid philidor player and like the the
Sharp Field door with not the bishop
seven castles but the G6 Bishop G7 type
Philadelphia maybe you're just losing by
force we're dead early but nobody knows
how yeah right and and he would just ask
ask for for like the tournament books to
exclude his games because he he felt his
livelihood depended on it but these days
everything is online on the same day so
exactly normally it doesn't work that
way I I do recall of course uh Gary
Kasparov against vashi and nand that was
the open Spanish where Gary sacrificed a
rook went bang bang bang bang bang and
only stopped at like move 30 or
something when he was completely winning
I think in Gary's Life there's there
will be many of those I think he was
experiencing very much a
front-runner for for this uh extremely
sort of mathematical extremely
uh searching for the ultimate answer not
like not satisfied with unclear with
compensation
he took it to the next level for for me
personally it was one of those moments
where you know you are in your career
you you're playing black and you need a
draw I was playing a match against
mecking I was leading by one point with
one game to play and it was black and I
found a line in the BOGO Indian that I
analyzed to like move 25.
even and it went right down the Primrose
path and I got my draw and I got my
match Victory but those are so rare and
welcome when you do get them uh Wesley
so our tournament leader with four games
in his pocket uh is nursing a an extra
Panic against Lavon but obviously Levon
has great compensation I was a little
bit surprised by the moves for five
before I I was watching Alejandra
explain the intricacies of this position
and I think we got to Rook d8 King F1
and Alejandro was playing 94 or Bishop
B6 first and then 94. and those ideas I
felt were very very well Justified
I understand
like generally speaking uh trading away
the Catalan Bishop in the Catalan is
pretty much always a good idea but we
are upon down here and Bishop E4 feels
you know somewhat
uh vague it gives light a hugely
important Tempo to do something useful
in particular my eye was drawn to the
movies before I uh toyed around with
this Mission a little bit uh while while
we were coming back from from the break
which before might not be the engine's
best suggestion but I thought it's very
logical I'm connecting my Rooks uh the
responsive five is now hanging finally
attacking
perhaps this bishop can go to E5 in some
positions perhaps having gotten it sort
of uh beyond the pawn chain I can play
after the trade at some point e to E3
and just solidify everything but even
here yeah the machine says take Stakes
Bishop B6 or the immediate Bishop B6 and
it's not that bad because I think E3
pretty much always runs into some G5
issues maybe 95 first and then G5 well
the bishop might get trapped exactly
yeah so yeah perhaps this is why the
engine is not that in love with the idea
of putting it on F4 because it doesn't
stay there very uh securely against
against the counter play the black house
right
okay black steel definitely has
compensation he has Rooks on two open
files there's a weakness on C3 to play
exactly decent coordination of the
pieces but it's a pawn I don't think Lev
has entirely equalized all right we'll
keep an eye on this one uh
Alejandro please back over to you how is
Hans demon in and linear getting along
according to the engines they don't like
the way that Hans has handled this
position specifically this move that he
played here after Rook 88 I love
Lanier's move here A5 it keeps your
options open on both flanks but the idea
is that now you cannot play B5 at any
point this is a nice little control over
the B6 square and when does he do it
after the move Rook 88 why is this
important because had you done this move
here for example
black could consider simply retreating
the queen back from D7 I know I just put
it on D7 right but I can now put it on
d8 again because you've put a weakness
on A5 that I can Target and Peter's idea
of Knight C6 now even gain strength of
course you don't have to play Queen
Diego immediately but I'm showing the
ideas behind a Black's position but now
that you've put the Rook on d8 if I play
the put the pawn on A5 it's much more
difficult to get to it because there is
no Queen d8 now Hans says well how about
I put my Bishop on B8 transfer it to C7
and therefore I this Pawn on uh A5 you
might also think at some point if I get
the D5 break that this bishop is
defending the pawn on E5 now after
Bishop A4 which is a very good move
Queen C8 Lanier understood this position
perfectly he killed this bishop on B8 he
said you want to get D5 in haha you know
you're not C4 on the board and I think
this is a very very powerful time to do
this if you play the move Knight C6
trying to get to D4 there's no good
answer to Knight D5 so you can't really
do this at all Bishop takes Pawn takes
97 is just a very bad position because
of the break B4 you wish you had your
Bishop on A7 and you wish your queen was
not on C8 but because of the specifics
of the position B4 comes like a very
strong break Rook C1 to follow and
Black's position actually just collapses
instead after C4 he played the move
Knight G6 and I think that Lanier is
still going to be interested in
establishing a knight on D5 the engines
are saying that you could start with the
move Knight H2 just to solidify this
part of the board but I don't see
anything wrong just go Knight D5 in this
position you have very strong threats
you can't move the Knight to F4 which is
the desirable move in this position and
ignoring this Knight on D5 I don't know
how long you can do that for especially
because right now Knight takes F6 is
obviously a threat if you take with the
Knight Pawn takes D5 Bishop D7 you again
play this idea of before it doesn't
collapse Black's position the way it did
when white also had the pair of Bishops
and this Knight on F6 was on the way of
the eventual F5 break but it still seems
to me that this is pretty fast this
bishop is going to come to E3 this Rook
is going to come to C1 and you're
targeting this point on C5 while the
Bishop is dormant on the B8 Square it
actually will probably have to spend
another Tempo to get to A7 95 already on
the board I like linear's position the
engine is giving him a slight Edge not a
huge Edge just a slight Edge but I like
how Lanier has handled this position
more than Hans thank you very much for
that uh Alejandro Peter I know it's just
like garbage but uh couldn't help but be
attracted to the move Bishop H I keep on
calculating this every single position
you know it's it's a kind of a twofold
thing first off uh because there is a
queen on C8 and the bishop on this
diagonal right your eye is drawn to it
but secondly I think I'm doing it
because I really dislike the exposition
right and I'm searching for a tactical
solution because I feel that if we do
nothing for another five moves there
might not be any solutions left right I
don't think it works though because like
GH Queen takes H3 I think the simplest
is rookie three exactly rookie three
followed by 91 if you play Knight F4 and
I think I've entirely stabilized like
there are no more threads through cool
come to G3 and then I will start it's
very hard for me to talk about my
wonderful attack when I'm looking at
this bishop what you said about Fisher
random Jazz everything begins like how
did you get your Bishop to be a dude not
good not good knight E5 looks like
Lanier isn't in Pole Position there once
again I just have to go back to the
shack yeah I think we can maybe even put
the cameras on onto that board because I
think you go Rook H5 here Force black to
take with the rook and that end game is
just very very safe we do have this
position and again
126. so it's possible to talk about Fabi
having slowed down
making only 27 moves in three minutes or
so Rook H5 as you were about to say Rook
takes E5 and somehow they will figure
out yeah thanks takes H3 yeah the the
point about this position is I think I
can even blunder on H2 and probably not
lose there's no reason for me to do that
but I'm pretty sure that like if I put
my king on G3 in the bishopon B3 right
and just uh chill right for the rest of
the game that probably is a draw but we
also have an extra Pawn on the king side
to fall back on should be extremely
extremely say for white absolutely and
Wesley
wasn't so attracted to your Bishop F4
Ida played Bishop to B2 yeah
I mean I'm keeping my extra Pawn maybe
on a good day I'll just slowly slowly
slowly try to unwind as you said lavon's
still trying still having to equalize
the game not there yet but he's got
great comp I mean yeah still no question
well particularly optically you can see
why why black has compensation this
night only for in particular if there
was a Pawn on H2
I think White's position would look a
lot better because you would be able to
at least dream of playing f2f3 somewhere
the way the way it is the Knight only
four dominates the the board so far very
very uh convincingly and it's currently
very difficult to smoke out
um so let's say yeah I play Bishop B6
you I guess you play rookie C1 or C3 C4
I don't know if we're trying to start my
my question for
for black here is how do we play Bishop
f8 uh he's gone all the way back okay
this is interesting because uh
um yeah I thought it was well placed on
V6 funnily enough I did too I mean the
this is a bit surprising to me I have to
say I I'm not horribly against it but it
is a bit looking for some relocation
maybe maybe
interesting
um that came rather quickly still Wesley
uh is actually significantly behind on
time not that that's so meaningful the
position again very technical but okay
levana's been playing this incredibly uh
quickly and finally let's go I mean
sorry we've kind of lost uh touch with
the game between mvl and uh and uh when
we left it sorry we were around these
parts uh yeah and here I want to bring
us back like we can get to the final
position what I want to attract the
attention of our viewers to is something
that Alejandro said at the at the top of
the show that he still remembers that
game nipponishi won in this line against
Irani all the way back I think in 2011
in which he ended the game with more
time than he began with yeah and he is
sort of demonstrating the same thing
from the other side today not quite but
close very very cool and he yeah he
seems to be holding quite comfortably
but for now Peter this is Robert other
unique situation we have a special guest
in studio as Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
is about to be interviewed uh by Lavon
not the interviewee by Lavon by uh
Alejandro sorry Alejandro Maurice
welcome to Studio I was watch I would
watch so much out of that interview it
was if it was livonian Levon conducting
the interview I hope you watched this
one too Peter welcome Maurice we haven't
had you here in the studio for a while
YouTube asks every single broadcast
where is Maurice and well maybe you can
shed some light yeah sometimes I get
lost as to where I am too because I'm
traveling so much uh having a good time
as you know I took a year off from
commentary everybody asked me do you
want to do commentary you and say no
because I just needed this year to
recharge refresh do some writing uh do a
chessable course that's out now as well
so just sort of like a sabbatical if you
will but like I come back the first day
I come back and his craziness here in St
Louis so it feels like I never left that
was what was what happened it seems that
you got here to St Louis and Magnus said
uh-uh and left
well you know Magnus and I have had
run-ins in the past so but I'm not
taking blame for this one it looks like
it looks like Hans is doing more than
enough by himself we definitely had a
lot of drama you've been calling a lot
of sing feels but this one this one
feels very unique go back you try to
remember any singfield cup of course the
first one when Magnus declined the
dragon's LaVon in that big one that he
won of course Bobby winning seven in a
row that was interesting a little bit of
a comeback story with Wesley beginning
last one year winning the next year but
absolutely oh I dig Lorraine also uh the
the one he defeated Magnus that was
pretty dramatic beating Magnus in a tie
break when Magnus hadn't lost one in
like 10 years all that was cool nothing
matches this like not even close uh
maybe 57 or I would say would be the one
but this is just this is must see TV you
gotta eat your popcorn now and just
start popping oh man that's been great
the internet has just been buzzing about
this tournament everybody with their own
speculations what do you think is going
on
no idea I mean I got no I really have no
Intel here I think that it's clear
something's up with Hans and Magnus you
know something's there the way Hans has
spoken about him that last quote was was
vintage I'm glad I beat him before he
left I mean that's that's going to last
forever I'm curious to know magnus's
reaction to that as well we know there's
some history with Hans in the past with
some some issues that that are pretty
well documented about him possibly
cheating and and so and him taking
punishment for that as well will will he
admit to that will that come out as a
statement or or what I don't know but I
think that uh it's it's frothy whatever
it is it's like real housewives of of St
Louis well maybe it's real house
husbands or whatever but it's just it's
incredible what's going on it has
absolutely been fantastic but tell us
about your year tell us about some of
the projects that you've been involved
in Maurice I know that everybody misses
you so why how do they missing you what
have you been doing instead well like I
said I did a chessable course my first
ever yasser's done like seven or eight
so he's a vet but I did one called the
secrets of Chess geometry it just came
out uh just in late August it's blowing
up I'm totally thrilled with it it's
just ideas that I've collected over the
last 20 years and decided to now finally
start publishing when I was doing real
work like you are it was just too much
there was just not enough time to get
projects done so that's what I'm really
proud of and as I said it's out now I'm
actually also writing a children's book
nice and uh my publisher is doing it's
actually been Illustrated for five to
seven euros I'm not doing the
illustration I'm not that talented but I
did tell the story it's about my life
little pieces of my life so that'll be
coming out sometime next year I'm doing
other another book as well on chess as
it relates to business I've been doing a
lot of corporate speaking Google Amazon
Pinterest Century 21 IBM some no-name
companies and uh that's been amazing as
well so I've been keeping busy not
really it seems that you have your hands
are full uh tell us for the fans when
are you coming back
you know I don't know the answer to that
question so I can't tell the fans that I
promised myself that I will not answer
that question until January 1st 2023 I
won't even inspect the question until
January 1st 2023. so until then I'll
keep doing what I'm doing try to do a
couple more testable courses uh
hopefully finish this book that's been
taken a while to write the one on chess
in business and uh and see what else
comes up I mean there's some other cool
TV projects that I can't speak on right
now but some Hollywood stuff people
think I've moved to California and I
haven't but because I've been out there
and I've been meeting some some pretty
cool stars like you know Jamie Foxx for
one and we'll see if that pans out but
it's it's just been an interesting time
it doesn't seem like your life is
terrible right now it's not bad it's not
bad no complaints I still miss you guys
though no question about that no we miss
you here as well y'all sir jump in here
in the conversation I mean you've been
working with Maurice for how long oh my
gosh yes and I go back to the mid 90s
somewhere around 25 years ago uh yeah
we've known each other a while because
Kasparov Adnan for one as well 95. but I
thought it was pretty cool Maurice that
you were the tourist in Madrid I'd still
like to get some more insights of what
you found about the candidates
tournament that you liked and uh it was
it was history
yeah it was fun being in the candies it
you know what's in general it's been fun
being a chess fan I always talked about
myself as a super fan I actually got a
job where I get to watch the best
players in the world duke it out I had a
front row seat and to be a fan uh like a
true fan not working at all not worrying
about being stuck in the studio sorry
guys but being able to just roam around
meet people hang out talk leave when you
want come back when you want it's just
been it's been fun I'm like a true fan
of the game now and I sit at home a lot
creating chess puzzles one of my big
Hobbies now you know I try to torture I
send you a few puzzles Alejandro uh you
know just to torture the strong players
with this side of myself and I never
thought this would be a sign I'm like
spending three or four hours a day
creating chess puzzles and I'm gonna
tell you guys for those that are not
familiar these puzzles are hard
hard I'm aware yeah we set them up for
the US Olympic team and they spent an
hour trying to solve one of them it was
five it was Levon all of the girls were
there trying to solve it it was hard
guys they eventually got it but it took
some time that warms my heart a hundred
percent that's what you want to hear I
love making really strong players suffer
over my puzzles I did with mvl I did
with Ali Raza called my puzzle over
27.50 for sure so that you know I can't
play like these guys so it's great to
make them suffer over the puzzle
Creations so that's been a real joy for
me and that's the side that's just been
coming out over this last period of time
that creative side that shows that I'm
still passionate about Chess I may not
be playing I may not be doing commentary
but I'm always going to be part of this
game oh I have to agree completely that
sometimes it's nice to look at chess
from a different perspective as we have
a result mvl has drawn against uh Nepal
we didn't see a lot of that end game but
nepo seems to have shown exactly how the
defend it will go over that in a second
but as I was saying sometimes looking at
just from a different perspective is
really fun people have asked me do you
prefer coaching or do you prefer playing
at the Olympia and my answer is always I
prefer going as a tourist it is
definitely the most fun tournament to
follow being in the midst of it so I'm
totally jealous you are over there in
Madrid Maurice well I'm glad you're in
St Louis how long are you staying only
uh just today is another full day and
then I'm off to Dallas to do a corporate
talk so it's just just to be around
everybody the gang see Joy Bray and Rex
and Tony and everybody it's been great
and I'm and I'm here just at this point
in time which is excellent that I showed
up on the right day and when I leave
trust me I'll be following you guys Well
you certainly know how to pick them
thank you Maurice for joining us here in
the studio we'll update some of the
games guys back to you hold on hold on
Maurice uh do a last question the
Columbo last question the youths man
tell tell me your reaction to the youths
Ali Reza what he did in the St Louis
rapid and bullets was amazing and Hans
Neiman is amazing they're 19 years old
uh Maurice
yeah add gookish uh aragaisy all the
Indian kids it's what's happening right
now is incredible I think chess is
seeing the generations start one rise
another realize that they're coming
they're coming it's like a wave a tidal
wave of young players and that's what we
want to see the change of the generation
and we we've seen it happen time and
time again we've seen when when Magnus
made his rise Fabi made his rise and the
ones we thought were entrenched at the
top had to seed ground as well so that's
exactly what's happening in the next
five years of Chess are going to be
absolutely amazing and it's a great time
to be a fan absolutely agree this is a
change of the Guard
the changing of the generations Marie's
always good to see you wonderful and
good luck with your chessable courses
that they're out now the one has already
been released and as Marie saying is
working on others so uh get yours a
Wilder are hot thank you again Maurice
thanks guys always fantastic to to see
Maurice I was that was absolutely my
highlight of the day yesterday
while everything else was going on
suddenly the door opens and Maurice
Waltz is in and uh it just yeah warms
the cockles of my heart to see him every
time and uh let's just uh one of the
best positive people I know absolutely
let's just jump back into this uh nepo
mvl because uh we did leave it uh in a
position that we thought there was
something going on and suddenly it was
uh oh yeah I think he answered me down
I'm pretty sure Jan just knew that this
is passive but it holds uh that you you
can't actually just play in this fashion
and in particular like this decision of
HG HD king of two and then you just take
on F4 it looks ugly as hell but uh it
just holds because you you white will
have to dedicate some some pieces to uh
you know trying to recovers recoup these
these losses and in the meantime you get
to play Bishop C6 you get to trade some
pieces and one final finesse there at
the end Rook H1 takes takes yeah I was
just about to say just in time black is
in just in time to get rid of one Rook
yeah and in this position uh Rook F7 is
a major major threat and there is also a
beat of a threat of 586
as well yeah so if you didn't have
exactly what Yan showed here you may be
arguably in some trouble but the Rook
just does not have enough squares and
you can always yeah you can always chase
it with the King and it cannot attack
any of uh any of the pawns seriously so
it really looks like this kind of a
defensive perimeter has been not just
sort of established while Jan Was
preparing but they they tested against
the most natural plants from the white
side in uh in uh preparing for the Dubai
match and they figured out that
it looks kind of worrisome it looks
definitely somewhat unfun but it holds
very very solidly so if you're okay with
making a solid draw against a very
strong player you probably will and this
is what he demonstrated dagnabbit
Alejandro the Petra
lives again well nobody's dancing also
between Fabiano caruana and Shakira
mamadiarov they have traded off to this
position and that is the last Pawn about
to be taken
and that's it guys that's two draws in a
row here in round number five yeah and
in a way they are sort of the kind of
the opposite side not the opposite size
of the same coin but both of these games
are the product of extremely extremely
high level preparation but one is a kind
of a concept of how to hold and the
other one is just a very very uh kind of
impressive bit of move by move sharp
tactical concrete preparation are shown
there by uh by Fabiano and very good
reaction to it by uh shaft as well world
class and with these uh two results
let's just take a quick uh update of
where we stand and we're in the middle
of this uh around five two draws in the
history books uh Peter yeah uh so far uh
so far both games today have been drawn
the remaining two positions are very
different though uh Wesley is a bit
better uh but I suspect livon probably
holds that game and then there is this a
very promising position I think for a
linear against hunts in the last game to
talk about wonderful and we do have nepo
in studio with Alejandro let's go pick
nepo's mind about this petrol Esa today
Alejandro and welcome to the studio it
seemed that your position had some
danger but you held it what seemed very
easily
uh well perhaps uh I think I you know
played this game you know far from
Excellence uh like no no not anything
close but as far as I know this line is
I mean supposed to be slightly better
but in fact it's more or less a fortress
uh it might be okay I mixed up for
something but this probably won't you
know the fact I play badly it doesn't
change the you know the revelation of
the whole line yeah so even I with my
like quite poor play managed to to call
the draw yeah but when do you say quite
poor play are there any moves that you
saw were inaccurate well first of all
I'm supposed to play a four if I'm
giving a chance I think yeah for example
in this position for example here yeah I
mean okay here perhaps again we should
just six but okay Bishop G6 is not ever
ever an idea so let's go with one more
yeah maybe here or four I mean so I I it
was like very weird because I felt like
all right before is like a key move
forward and he was not my F4 and I
wasn't playing F4 and then he played the
four either for 12. what's going on okay
so I like okay I felt like a G5 is uh
should somehow be like a fortress uh but
I thought maybe after G5 he could play
G3 and maybe uh yeah like Rook B3 is
quite smart yeah I'll say Rook Q7 here
G3 with the idea so if I uh like play in
a simple way like Chase takes and let's
say Bishop C6 sorry uh yeah let's say
King F2 and here uh we will you know
whichever look I put on G7 white is in
time to play Bishop E2 and Bishop F3 let
me just give it a for example yeah so
Bishop B2 he plays uh let's see yeah I
mean it's it might actually become
unclear Bishop a friend here Rook G3 yes
uh but uh yeah first of all room takes
B7 deserves some attention here and
secondly uh he could also try maybe
something like Rook H1 and then try to
improve somehow yeah because this is
like I don't know to me it didn't look
like absolutely clear like okay perhaps
it's also like some sort of a fortress
yeah right but uh yeah probably I would
not I wouldn't be in a hurry with
capturing on F4 but there was some small
problem here
so effort let's say if I started with
Bishop C6 so the idea is uh after King
F2 I would probably start with Rook E7
or Rook E8 so in general I think
exchanging a pair of hooks is quite
favorable for me right uh and let's say
if he plays Bishop B5 I'm always good
for if like Rook uh b38 so it's never an
idea for him yeah so because like yeah
I mean invading the the B file and here
uh let's say the difference if if I
would exchange only four he would have
this Rook G1 and H5 idea which was quite
quite unpleasant I think if he's sorry I
mean let's say if we include gfgf and
here he might play let's say Roo G1 it
says here text takes Bishop
c67 urugu G1 and then H5 H5 and have
with the witness from G6 I I couldn't I
couldn't really evaluate like should uh
you know what should I do because I felt
like maybe I mean once once white played
before I understood okay four was quite
a quite a nice move actually but and
normally you want to do this you want to
play this move to grab some space right
yeah but uh yeah you know but since you
were solid enough anyway yeah I think so
so I I wasn't sure like okay in the line
I thought maybe he should take on G5 I'm
thinking give two and try to play like
this but um as for me I
I I don't think it's really that much
white here yes so it's you know always
you know material is quite limited and
you know his ideas are quite limited
also so maybe I should also I could also
like stay still and like see what what
you know what fight is going to do
without even G5 but I thought like all
right it's uh more or less a draw and in
the end it was like funny that King G6
move uh not actually attacking The Rook
yeah so that's actually okay okay so for
example if he plays King F3 yes I mean
okay of course they can take on H7 take
English king G5 yes there's also sort of
yeah like and then okay play B6 so let's
say if it will be something like a six
plate probably it would be lost for a
while for black but then okay now I have
b600 I'm good right and but instead of
this I could also go for something like
Bishop B5 to you know to exchange
yeah to exchange not not truths uh there
would be seven Bishop I mean okay just
total elimination for for both sides
yeah thinking obviously draw yes yeah so
well the okay the petrol flake is very
solid opening so even like with my
uh surely not masterful touches yeah
it's still still survives here did you
get a little burn from playing the
nighter and you decided out let's come
back to the Petrov uh no I just wanted
to yeah I just prepared against a
specific line and I was like very
excited and then uh yeah
I felt like I should need to I mean I I
should work a little bit more Nitro
because I basically I didn't touch it
for working let's say one or two years
uh this was a little bit over optimistic
yeah we have to ask you we haven't had a
chance to talk to you about this Magnus
leaving tell us your thoughts
no it's I think it's quite bad for the
tournament first of all and uh I think
no one is helping building Magnus that
you know that happened uh but uh well as
I said yesterday probably he has his own
reasons so
I can't say if I like completely share
his opinion but uh yeah I'd say it's
I mean uh you can never be like 100 100
right or 100 percent wrong so you kind
of be like completely sure uh until uh
like something uh
I mean until you have some direct
evidence let's say yeah yeah but uh
that's somehow the problem yeah when
when they speak about okay some some
sort of like bad things happening in
chess like fixing or whatever like or
cheating or something else I mean there
is always a problem okay you can um
without some enough evidence uh I can
come and say okay it was a good day for
me okay I was I was lucky it it reminds
me as some uh billionaire played against
uh vision and uh online and he crushed
him with black like after playing
whatever like D4 E5 and okay it was
lucky day for me I used to play chess
you know when I was when I was a kid
yeah like this yeah so
yeah you know Frankly Speaking uh it's
uh it's a very big threat it's a very
big threat for chess and uh hopefully
you know everything will be all right
and you know uh Hans will prove himself
you know Innocent but uh yeah for now
it's clearly you know
I think the internet right now is very
hyped here also like like more or less
50 50 situation and okay I'm getting my
popcorn well you are in the midst of it
right now actually because well Magnus
uh not playing the rest of the term
means that you somehow have eliminated a
loss uh does that give you better hopes
for winning the tournament yeah you know
it's probably the first time in my
career when I have to make you know made
a draw and uh by by this draw I made it
to the plaza so as it was yesterday so
like we draw we watch and okay that's
how you get into the plus course
suddenly
no but I'm not thinking about uh
about places uh of course like
the gaming as Magnus was like very you
know very disappointing so getting like
nice position out of the opening and
then losing like this
uh so it's uh I mean it's the same
feeling uh and it doesn't really matter
if like the game counts for the overall
standings or not uh going back to this
issue that we have in chess you've
mentioned that fixing cheating all these
things have been a problem in the past
do you think that they're ramping up do
you think that we need to take better
measures against it
uh well uh when we speak let's say okay
after the pandemic okay uh the internet
uh just boom uh surely uh okay this
problem was you know
it became very serious and a lot of
people were you know really vocal about
it uh but uh I don't think uh it's
anything like realistic to prevent
someone from like you know clever
cheating again
and as well as you know the the fixing
which okay occurs I hope quite quite
rarely but you know yeah sometimes
people want to get some Norms you know
to share some prizes and so on so
unfortunately this also happens probably
not on the top level yeah
yeah so I think like uh it's always you
know like
uh two sides and uh you know uh it's you
know basically it's like in the war yeah
you know you the better weapon you have
okay and uh your opponents also you know
have to you know
and take some measures how to how to
counter it yes so
I mean if if there is like a way to
avoid it like for 100 okay probably like
stop any transmission of any games here
and like play uh you know next in a in a
locked room yeah but uh I I'm not seeing
this happening uh do you feel a little
bit difficult or different I should say
not difficult different for the players
playing Hans now that all of this drama
has happened and the internet is saying
all these things
but you better ask players I think yeah
so as for me I think I'm paired with
funds in the in the last round so I
think I hope to have lost their own
situation will clarify yeah we'll hope
so uh yeah thank you for joining us here
solid draw today in the plus score
janapalyachi thank you very much John uh
good luck with the rest of your games
and uh we do have two results but I'm
thinking three results we're about to
have a third result we have Wesley so
and levona Romanian have just
I think that goes to three versus two I
just want to say you sort of bring us
back to the start of the show where yeah
uh where we did I think specify that if
Yan wanted to say something he will say
something and he did and I think I I
think we got we got Vindicated exactly
from that point but we have more
interviews uh so in a moment we will
have uh Alejandra with Maxima Shirley
grav all right
and uh nvl is in fact is ready over to
you aleandro here with Maxim you had a
solid draw against nepo did you feel
that you missed something or did you
feel it was more or less according to
plan probably I didn't miss much uh it's
just that
when I looked at this end game a little
bit I thought I had some changes so
you know
I felt like it's the best I could obtain
but
I don't know I think it shouldn't have
been that comfortable for you and so
probably I had some better option I just
didn't see it yeah Jan also came here
and showed us that the Fortress was just
very difficult to penetrate even with a
best play so I'll ask you Alice we do
have this result we're expecting Wesley
so did draw against Levon I don't know
I'm sure we'll have them soon we gotta
ask you about the drama we know that you
made a comment online yesterday on one
of the twitch streams at least I saw it
on Reddit was that was that you or was
that fake news
uh did I actually make a comment I mean
I made a comment on some French yes our
Channel yeah but this was this morning
oh sorry yeah
um uh so anyway yeah there's like a few
things I think
I mean as always with this
um uh with these dramas uh it's very
difficult to handle well but I think
this has been handled very poorly
because it's become basically a Witch
Hunt and like
the effect it can have an ants is
actually quite devastating so you know
this felt bad then uh to whether or not
he has cheated honestly I don't know I
don't have you know for now I don't have
enough information like if it were up to
the information I have until now I would
say no cheating
but then of course like Magnus is also
not known for going on with chance and
stuff like that so you know maybe as
solid arguments but like I would like to
to see them
and yeah if I have to end on a more
positive note I think you know these
things have been ramping in the Chess
World for for the past few years
um as you well know and like it was
Orlando behind the scenes in general but
uh you know like it's and it's hard to
avoid suspicion on one player or the
other and um
if it can you know if this going
straight out in the open uh can help
figuring out you know ways to like make
cheating much more uncomfortable like
for instance I assume that uh delay in
the podcast will be a common place stuff
like that I mean it can and for the best
um but for no yeah like again I really
don't like how things uh happen
yesterday like I so after I came back
from my game and I saw basically
everyone
uh going straight after her hands and
like again like I don't have enough
information maybe in cheated of course
if that's the case it should basically
uh be banned but uh almost for like for
life but you know like I would like
first to to see some proof or at least
some circumstantial evidence that you
know exist in some way but is definitely
not enough to to conflict to to a
certain like or even like
a proverb or cheating like for now it
doesn't look probable considering the
amount of information I have you've
played Hans plenty on casual bits I saw
you play in Dubai I see that you've
played him in here and there does it
surprise you at all that he has the
strength yeah exactly yeah I didn't come
to this but yeah I played him in a
casual match in Paris and like okay if
he cheats there like that you know
I did win the match actually but it was
playing very well like definitely over
2700 of course blades and classical is
not the same and of course is that this
tremendous progress but he's also been
working on chess non-stop for for two
years so like
you cannot like Banner player for for
improving I I feel like otherwise you
know we have to ban every young player
who has been improving like
foreign
like his list never ends and you know
I've been at this place of course when I
was younger so of course computers were
not
uh yet uh you know part of the issue
so of course but I can imagine and back
in the days if we had computers and you
know Magnus would have been cheating
everybody would have been cheating so
again like for now I don't have enough
information to to say like
but I would say still to the fact that
Magnus seems convinced is a bit worrying
but you know without more information I
I won't go on the weekend based based on
that well Maxi thank you for your candid
thoughts on this we wish you the best
for the rest of the tournament thank you
indeed thank you very much Maxine candid
thoughts and uh I must say I agree with
them uh
show me some evidence in particular in
particular the thing that rang very true
for me and and something I've been
saying myself for for for a bit is that
uh this this seems very very unfortunate
right now but if it leads to some kind
of clearing of the air hopefully like a
an open discussion of this topic which
as Maxim said has been going on you know
in private chats behind the scenes
behind the scenes for the past I don't
know a year and a half it's it's been a
topic Non-Stop and it's never really
gotten out of that very very you know uh
closed club uh if it leads to an honest
discussion and perhaps leads to improve
protocols uh going forward that at least
would be a positive because yeah what is
going on right now is
no no not very enjoyable yeah uh Peter
let me interact you just say that we do
have a special guest with Alejandro in
studio the man who was on the receiving
end of some incredible prep over to you
Alejandro Shaq welcome to the studio my
first question how much time did you
spend considering taking with the knight
in this position okay I mean he played
very fast until this moment after Queen
F1 of course uh I understand this uh
is maybe his draw maybe is a better way
I need to play I mean a knight F1 why if
connect one I see after Knight F5 it's
better to play
without Pawn than
the extra Queen yes
yeah if you open it now everything is
better to just to change and play end
game without Pawn I mean I I was upset
with sure Knight F1 is also I mean it's
okay but I it was not not today I mean
maybe next day maybe not today today I
just think it's Queen F1 and take 95.
because after Queen E7 it was a new move
for me yeah after this moment I started
to play myself and I was too much time
and really I think I great variable and
and the very important moment when I
played
this move yeah you first take here you
can play is continue I think every yeah
yeah Knight F1 yeah here is he plays C5
after C5 I was a little bit in a shock
because I really 93 take Queen F7 I I
don't know after queen of Queen F7 is
looks very easy losing and after
knighting fun I want to play a C5 I want
to play Queen H5 yeah because first 10
or 15 minutes I calculate this move
because I was very happy with this move
take take D4
and uh
sorry Bishop B4 yep kingy two yeah I
calculate I was very happy because it's
looking for looking for Knight E3 maybe
I mean but yeah I bet after I I find
Bishop C3 move inside of Rook F4 I think
inside of which and after this move I
think this looks like very bad and maybe
the losing position for what and I just
take 93 yeah and after 93 I calculate
okay maybe I can play of the queen of
seven yeah Bishop F5 is very strange
move Bishop F5 that was already
originally yeah Bishop B5 Bishop B5 Rook
B4
I think okay is minimum I can play this
position but this looks very bad Bishop
B4 yeah it's I think it's a very bad
position yeah but I am very happy to uh
I can calculate and find the queen G1
movie definitely can count like when did
you find it yeah okay I think he played
very fast it means I played good
very first it means you play very good
his main lines is uh for this reason I I
was some moves but I don't know which
one and uh when okay he played Queen F7
again very fast and I think it's okay I
need to find this move or queen G1 is
finally this move after Queen G1 I start
to think okay white is better but again
I is Queen a fun idea I miss but okay
after Queen G1 okay Bishop C3 look at
fun Queen he finds the amazing yeah
yeah of course I I calculate of course
because uh uh but what to do if no truck
F1 is just take D4 I have no move and uh
it's Queenie fun and everything is draw
I mean it was very good from preparation
is from Fabiano and the very good
defense from Mommy dear
we have to agree this was a brilliant
played game considering he didn't know
the engine evaluations Chuck I have to
ask you what were your thoughts
yesterday as your opponent's clock
started ticking down
okay uh of course it is a little bit sad
uh Magnus not continue to play
tournament this little bit set for for
beautiful Saint Louis beautiful St Louis
chess club everything because every year
everyone happy to play here and we all
hope it Magnus will play of course all
tournaments but
this is not easy moment
say something about Magnus
uh
but you know why he's not go uh I don't
know
why he's not continuing tournament he
has not made on the official declaration
no yeah okay if you know you can ask me
I will answer something if not I don't
know
of all right guys you want to join in on
the conversation uh no just I I love the
uh I love the line great preparation
great defense by uh
is doing our job for us I just feel like
kind of observed because yeah that was a
perfect summary we don't have anything
to add here I guess uh good luck uh
enjoy your free day Shaq I will see you
the day thereafter nicely put really
nice yeah perfect perfect statement of
fact there by by Shakira absolutely so
with uh one game yeah we are now what uh
an hour into another two hours into the
into the round and we've only got one
game left and this is this game between
uh Lanier Dominguez and uh Hans Neiman
I've been trying to calculate this end
game it's an incredibly concrete end
game I feel because uh White will be
structurally much much better if the
exactly before it gets recaptured in the
Visa sevens the B7 weakness will be very
very exploitable so I've been looking at
Bishop takes E3 fdx3 F5 trying to play a
5 F4 and get squares for this guy for
this Knight and and maybe actually after
a five you're supposed to take on F5 and
not even allow F4 because allowing that
Knight to land on F4 is a huge big deal
for black yeah
you're in doubling my pawns by the way
so I'm grateful for it and then we're
taking on before we're going rookie B1
the Knight comes to D2 and then perhaps
to E4 or C4 uh uh no this is a dream
this is an absolute absolute dream dream
and game for uh linear for sure
absolutely no I I he he's already
captured on E3 huh yeah it's uh it's
interesting because there was also a
kind of a really really risky option
here of playing Bishop C5 I was also
trying to calculate that was right but I
get the feeling this loses I don't think
this works yeah because you just don't
play neither four quickly enough but in
the meantime we have more uh more
interviews so let's go go to the studio
and to to Alejandro who's with Wesley so
Wesley saw that just comes off a draw
against leonardonia and Wesley you seem
to have good prep that your opponent
played one more move than you did no I
mean I wanted to turn but live one
apparently and life also in this
position with the white pieces and he
knows that they're very well so I he
played this Catalan with C5
a few times I played regularly and you
play this regularly as well yeah I
played against England it's a very solid
line and last night I was looking at
several lines I could try uh but uh
basically black knows the theory which I
assume Lebon mostly knows then he
equalizes pretty much I was looking for
an interesting way that's why I came up
with Rubik's D4 on move 13. yes which
are the main line I mean
it doesn't look very nice objectively
because the queen side pawns they are
weak but I assume that one would be well
prepared against he takes D4 I played C4
on move 12 against him in Roman no where
is it in Poland in Poland yes yeah but
uh didn't get much so
the point of this line I guess is to
provoke black to play E4 on move 14 or
E5 rookie one by rogate is very accurate
I think it's the best move and LeBron
Blitz it out because he even Blitz it up
to H6 but once you play Knight C4 he
seemed a little bit stuck what was going
on through both of your minds yeah
because the main line is 38 first on
mode 16. ah advocate in this position
yeah and then after G4 H6 and then Rook
B1 uh this move order yeah actually
LeBron told me that he prepared this
line after the game but he makes it up
so that his preparation was Rook B1 B6
96 through B7 95 rupee 7.
9V through 94 and claim black equalizes
so it's fascinating yeah the problem
with this end game yeah that you either
go for the main lines or right you try
something new but then black has
multiple ways to turn and hold a very
decent position but I thought I won a
pawn here I thought I had some chances
when I played Bishop F5 yes yeah I
thought I was a pawn up but it's I spend
a lot of time I couldn't find way to
make progress like I was gonna play G4
first
instead of what sorry if Knight D3 ah G4
right away yes Bishop C2 Bishop C2 Rook
D2 and then he can play Bishop H7 let's
see Knight D3 Bishop B6
Bishop B2 Knight E4 yeah and black
probably just no problems at all so a
lot of activity for blocking
compensation for the pawn yeah yeah no
problems so in the game I thought I was
consolidating I was happy after King F1
yes
but like a several chances basically if
I get Bishop B through rook ac1 and then
C4 then I have very good chances to win
but LeBron played Bishop E4 and then I
couldn't
okay finally because it's threatening to
take on G2 and rookie2 and I don't want
to take on e4 and activate this Knight
but I didn't really see any option like
I could play Bishop F3 here yes
and then he can probably take take and
then I don't know just Rook create or
something again with compensation yeah
if my feet one was only on B3 then I
would be winning yeah well that's a big
impact
yeah but the problem like outside of
these lines the fitter Pawn is always
weak in many lines so so you decided to
give the pawn back and after that it
just seemed like you didn't have many
chances yeah after Basics I wasn't
planning to play C5 but I had I looked
at my clock and I was down 50 minutes
50. yeah I had 30 minutes and he had
almost an hour 20.
yeah I think he barely left any of his
time today like I was uh
yeah Black Ops main moves like this
example four figure play Rook C8 also or
Rook E6 right I thought Rook E6 also
makes sense but maybe Lebon didn't want
to calculate Knight F4 right and then
but anyway after day six I was gonna
play something else at first but then I
like E3 but then I look at my time and
attack time too yes time to bailout yeah
time to bail out basically I I didn't
find my comfortable day because every
time player Rook ac1 here through k6
attack my a pawn
so uh
yeah I'm not really sure sometimes you
just don't get chances yeah you know
like yeah you want to get chances okay I
can't stop Beyond I manage to win an
equal position
well you seem to outplay him from very
nicely in that one yeah I think yeah
but it was equal in the opening so
that's true yeah Wesley we got to ask
you uh the drama surrounding the
tournament what are your feelings now
that Magnus is not in it yeah did he
give an official reason no no yeah yeah
if everyone's been silent I I guess uh
yeah the day we had a lot of
um
solid draws as well I'm sure everyone's
distracted like it was hard for me to
sleep last night because of the six
events are here yeah because of the
Dharma and whether the whether whatever
is happening is true or not
um I remember six years ago 2016
all the top players were just preparing
on classical chess and classical chess
and all that but now we have online we
have rapid Blitz and now we have all
this drama so it just makes it a bit
difficult to concentrate
um
and also I play hand Seaman on round six
so uh
I don't know but with the increase
with the advancement of technology these
days it's hard to predict already what's
uh what's possible or what's not
I know online there's a lot of shooting
involved but over the board of course
it's much harder but I'm not exactly
tech savvy and and all that I mean I can
think a few ways to do it but not the
most advanced person so I guess only
time will tell what was happening the
drama has affected your sleep and now
you're playing Huns
yeah I mean I was watching today and I
mean he probably get uh he probably get
so mad and beat me on their own fixed
but we'll see what happens
um but again only only time will tell
you know he'll play in the U.S
Championship as well and uh we still
have no idea what's happening or what's
going on but I'm just saying the world
does definitely changed compared to six
years ago you know everything's more
advanced these days but I'm trying I'm
just trying to play some good chess you
know I'm trying to
improve trying to focus on my classical
chess uh the last few months have been I
haven't really done anything special so
I'm just trying to I just gotta focus on
my own game I guess but uh yeah it's um
it's interesting I think before
tournament everyone expected Magnus to
cruise through this tournament
um but now that he's gone the term is
wide open oh yeah I know he was my pick
too in the term right now it's gone I
mean I'm not very happy about that yeah
I mean it's a hundred points higher than
everybody
Wesley thank you for your time we know
that you will need plenty of prep for
the rest of the tournament yeah it's
also nice that I get two rest days now
that is also very true are you gonna be
having more whites or blocks no I'll
have five blacks five blocks and three
whites well it helps that you're the
leader of the tournament right now I'm
white against Magnus only I could
substitute it that is a Pity well Wesley
thanks for joining us here in the studio
and we'll go back to the only game
remaining thank you uh Alejandro in fact
there is one game remaining and a very
exciting game I like Lanier's position
very very much but we're going to take a
quick break and we're gonna see you on
the other side of the break thank you
stay tuned
[Music]
St Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of St Louis SLU
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception SLU
obtained second best university of the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good St Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
[Music]
when you visit St Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead Boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know I can't play this
right St Lou is always exploring
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cup with only one game remaining and
that one is our highest hope for today
for a decisive result with three draws
so far absolutely and Peter I gotta tell
you my feeling is we're going to see a
decisive result in this game I love as
do you everything about White's position
break it down absolutely first first I
think we can reintroduce the uh the day
so far of course with the games that
already finished as you can see on your
screen uh
they're all they were I think all
interested in interesting in their own
way I think by far the peak has to be
the majority of karwana game which
features some really really high-tech
prep right by Fabi and as Shaq himself
remarkably uh said just just a moment
ago on our broadcast and a good defense
by momijero yeah yeah great preparation
by father he could defense by mamidara
very very nice but yeah three draws so
far and uh the last game running is the
game between linear Dominguez having a
very very uh nice uh advantage on the
white side of a joker piano against uh
Hans Neiman Hans has just played in this
position King G8 f8 his plan as I
understand it is to wait for white fake
on before with the sea Rook I would
assume all right and then we go Knight
C8 Knight A7 Knight B5 or at least we
hope to go 98 98 97 95 and if it reaches
B5 you can start feeling perhaps less
this respondent about whatever you will
have broken the connections along the
b-file blocking the threat if you will
and very very importantly if we play
Rook B6 here yeah there is an idea
though maybe it's not that relevant
because 98 perhaps just pushes the route
back and then we can re-establish Knight
B5 setup right I wanted to say if you do
play Knight B5 afterwards oh yes we can
take on B5 and on D6 but very very
importantly for that position black has
Rook F6 there
meaning that we will have to trade a
pair of Rogues and if we have to trade
the pair of Rooks this is not as
hopeless as maybe some other positions
would be it's still very very dangerous
because right the Knight comes to C4 and
everything like if if you imagine this
Mission the white goes 1939 C4 secures
everything brings the king over to E3
and then plays D3 D4 it was it to
connect yeah those two those two
passwords probably win but as you said
the Knight C8 might just process
backwards uh so but this entire line
makes me wonder if perhaps we can uh
maybe finesse it a little bit somehow to
not allow Knight C8 to even happen
exactly that's uh that's the big
question I mean we want to recover the
pawn but do we want to allow Knight C8
now the move King f8 Intimates to my
mind that
Hans is ready to play King E8 take that
king walk so that he can play uh the
desired Knight C8 uh again Peter uh if
we do it the other way we just what's up
my problem with this move is I don't
quite understand like we've stopped
Knight C8 black apart from this King
march towards the G8 Square does not
really have anything going for them but
uh how are we improving from here right
I thought it was going to be based on
d3d4 here now or uh with the prep let me
just make a preparatory move like
something like this like this like this
and if I ever land a knight on E6 this
and I'm golden this makes a ton of sense
right I was kind of lost to trade any of
that structure because black has a very
very sub kind of a passive passive
structure all of these spawns really
feel like weaknesses exactly as you know
it's a solid yeah including the E5 Pawn
on it because I think you know we in
every single position here we run a
decent chance of just winning the D6
Pawn over outright exactly forget to
attack it properly which means that we
get to win the E5 Pawn out right as well
but maybe you arrive maybe you are you
you do have to switch to a you know a
slightly more wrist trained way of
converging this by with T3 by playing
neither 3g4 and asking like are you
going to allow my knight 36 are you
going to allow GTX E5 providing me with
a protected passer on D5 as well as an
open Target to the E5 Pawn let's get
Alejandro in on this and uh let me just
ask straight up a big Advantage white
but what's the numerical number let me
guess 1.3
uh remove the one and remove the decimal
three all the way up to three plus three
a full extra piece you're gonna count it
that way yeah sir that's how bad the
position here is for black I'm playing
around for a little bit the engine wants
to take with the B Rook as you mentioned
you don't want to allow this Knight to
C8 and after King A8 they actually
Retreat this Rook like King Dana said
you want to play Knight seat you don't
get to do that and how do you improve
after G5 they when you can start playing
the introduction wants to make some
moves on the king side I just made G5
because it's a move gotta do something
sure and the idea is to play Rook F4 to
C2 and then prepare Knight C4 and
tactically you're not gonna be able to
play Knight C8 because of Knight takes
C5 and you're not going to be able to
challenge with Rook C7 because of Knight
takes D6 and if you allow my knight to
get to B6 well that's just game over
right I trapped it exactly so this is
the slow but crushing maneuver that
white can do in this position it's not
the only way to get a decisive Advantage
but to me this seems pretty clean guys
that sure does I love I I love the fact
that we're just absolutely putting the
stopper on a knight c8p on any kind of
counter play stopping both Knight C8 and
Rook D7 C7 as well so again that was
Rook takes yeah and then we drop it back
and double on the C file that's that's
sweet uh no an ICA for you and then
after Alejandra just picking a move yeah
uh a dropping back the Knight is ready
to swing to the square B6 and that could
even come with mating checkmating uh
Concepts as well let's see what uh
so he's still doing very well but that
does allow Knight C8 which I think that
was the one thing is an improvement
because at least you can sort of
understand what you're playing for with
black now exactly you've got to go stick
your knight on B5 and block the the
Rooks attack of the B7 Pawn
hmm how how
well I mean this spoiled a little bit at
the advantage but did it spoil it
in a big way or just a minor way uh
aliandra about 33 of the advantages gone
if you're in a very very numerical about
it it's now down to plus two but still
plus two uh King fa rustic takes before
I expect Knights here it is the only
move to not have a plus three evaluation
right but the problem is this move
Knight F3 okay you're just not getting
to a A7 B5 you go Knight A7 I go D4
immediately you don't have enough
Firepower to defend on E5 here in this
position
uh especially considering there's also
ideas of Knight H4 Knight F5 if you
decide to put a rook on E7 right let's
say that you go here and I go Knight H4
well that's the game that's it G6 96 or
Knight F5 will win something so you kind
of have to play after D4 Pawn text
Knight takes allow this Knight to E6 it
also remember it prevents this Knight to
coming coming from B5 for the time being
so you have to go something like King G8
96 congratulations you got your knight
to here but after Rook C1 I will just
Crush you the Knight only six is way too
powerful
marvelous marvelous it just really uh
clarifies everything I love the Knight
of 3D for break Peter yeah you were you
were the first one to point it out and
it does seem to be in particularly for
allowing Knight C8 uh you do need to
generate uh additional activity because
your fantastic structural advantage on
the queen side might not be enough with
the with the blocker arriving on B5 but
it doesn't arrive there fast enough
exactly you always feel like uh you're
risking definitely a parts of your
advantage here because you as mentioned
you've traded some of your some of your
beautiful structure uh some bones came
off the board but the Knight only six uh
versus yeah puts puts the lie to the
next sentence I was about to try try
mentioning that you know you've also
weakened your E4 pawn and perhaps
presented a target for black to play
against not only 6 says no no targets
for you how are you going to attack this
yeah this is just completely Untouchable
and uh yeah this looks horrible I'm a
bit surprised just just how horrible the
machine thinks it is considering it's
still equal material ending with three
pieces left but me too but I do suspect
when Lanier played the move Rook C for
takes B4 he has anticipated the knights
and you have to assume that's it right
and it's calculated that his Advantage
will still be well overwhelming is this
looks really really really good
yeah still a bit surprised because I
think uh you know perhaps maybe this
idea of spending too Tempe to just
double on the C file uh when we don't
actually have a Target on the C file
just yet until you make more moves in
preparation was appeared a bit too slow
for linear right because I think the the
temptation to just rule out all counter
play entirely must have been quite
strong because absolutely as a player
you know playing the strongest side in
positions like this your dream which you
generally don't get to realize against
strong players but it's still the dream
right yes is to actually never have to
calculate ever again in this game you
just you just make solid moves you
prevent as much come to play as possible
your position looks like it should be
winning so you just hope that eventually
all your pieces get to their Prime
squares
and then things collapse exactly and and
rugby takes before followed by doubling
on the C file did feel like it was
coming pretty close to this ideal ideal
description of how you would like to
convert exactly but as I mentioned uh
sort of in real life again strong
players who know how to defend very very
rarely do you actually get to experience
this kind of bliss of never having to
calculate a single variation from a
winning position I love that expression
play on one goal uh but but then again
what linear we we
guess has calculated Rook takes B for
Knight C8 Knight F3
Knight A7 D4 E5 is collapsing do not
attempt to defend the E5 Pawn trade
trade Knight comes to E6 and the the the
scale if you will between the Knight
powerfully placed on E6 and versus B5 is
just overwhelming that and I just
completely dominates two Rooks right
like those Rooks just will not have any
squares for the rest of the game pretty
exactly if you if you could maybe get
time enough to play Rook F6 from df7
then you will have some squares to look
forward to but I guess even that will
not be enough and also I don't think
you're getting there because Rook C1
among other things yeah is creating a
thread of Rook CA check and like the
check which wins material and shockingly
I'm not sure you have a decision no no
it looks it looks it sounds ridiculous
but even if let's say you start with
King H7 I play Rook C8
I think you've lost an exchange here
there it goes yeah there it goes um I
recall uh in his really Immortal
brilliancy the Moscow uh world
championship match where uh Gary put a
knight Black Knight on D3 and just kind
of like was this amazing octopus that
just captured all of these squares the
Knight on E6 is doing uh a terrific
terrific job this is
overwhelming it is it is a very very uh
strong Advantage for white yeah and
shockingly with all the interviews that
we've been having And discussing
magnus's withdrawal uh sure puts a
question too to what the the previous
day's proceedings doesn't it Knight F3
as we thought was was going to happen it
did like if you think with the sea Rook
I think this is how you follow up
nothing else really made much I'm sorry
Peter that the position that we've been
looking at just simply unplayable I I
but this hasn't stopped before his issue
right well
no it doesn't of course but
okay I can still I mean maybe Knight H4
wins even faster but I can also play
g484.94 you haven't actually attacked
them that is true that is true I mean I
was trying obviously to prevent this but
you're not actually preventing them not
preventing anything uh
it looks terrible uh Alejandro uh has
the engine reevaluated that uh two two
Pawn advantage to anything even greater
nope it still thinks two pawns but that
black has to be careful not to collapse
and it wants to start with the move King
E8 so that on D4 I've moved the king
away from the f8 square and now I can
play Rook D E7 so that when Knight H4
comes it doesn't actually hit that many
things for example if I play Knight H4
in this particular position I the angels
are saying you can move the Rook to C7
yes allowing takes on D5 is not very
pretty you could take on D4 as well and
well fasten has played the move Knight
A7 instead already I expect Lanier to
blitzed out D4
this is linear I'm not sure Blitz is the
right word I apologize so D4 you don't
have a choice you absolutely have to
take in this position unlike the
positions with and before D4 already
played yeah
I stand corrected uh if you play uh Rook
D7 in this position then as I mentioned
Knight H4 just wins because there's two
different attacks in Knight G6 it just
hits too many things so he has to take
he's already done so I you take with the
Knight all the time uh I don't think
that really matters which way you go
yeah the interesting point is if if
Black Goes Knight B5 instead of King G8
I wonder if in that position you still
go Knight yeah exactly right we're just
thinking we we we're walking past that
night we just yeah you don't
we just ignore it all together yeah
this is the same position and if King is
seven we I guess we still occupy the C
file and we're still kind of winning
right it doesn't matter I think you
occupy the C file the engine actually
wants to play Rook one B2 I think
what's wrong with this
a king F6 and King E5 and why was Rook
dito stopping that because
because engine be faster uh apparently
what Rook check Rook of two nights of
fate or something yeah right here
Knight G6 made the Rooks also hanging oh
that it's a beauty it's hard to see
though uh it takes the fortnite takes D4
on the board not on the board actually
he's thinking of three takes D4 but I
expect him to take yeah he will he will
take yeah I mean I mean there is a 45
right now maybe he's considering playing
E4 E5 e45 is okay but the engine doesn't
like it as much because you can give
back the exchange either way yeah I was
wondering about that yeah we'll not give
back the exchange but give the exchange
with something like Rook F3 the E5 also
works pontex Pawn takes and then if you
oh no not one takes that's kind of silly
Knight B5 and since your knight is
strong your pot on D4 is defended it's
not giving white a huge Advantage uh
quick question The Rook takes F3 E6
uh just move the Rook it's the same
position right it's the same position
pretty much yeah yeah I got it yeah okay
um let's just take a break and say that
uh Anastasia caught up with Fabiano uh
for a short interview and let's cut and
see what Bobby said
Fabiana you just made the draw in the
game with the air but I first of all I
was wondering how much time did you
spend to check in social media yesterday
after that game you know and after mad
who's withdrew from the tournament
actually I I spent quite a lot of time
because it is a very interesting thing I
mean
we haven't had any like really major
scandals in the Chess World and this is
the first one in quite a while
I mean it's
maybe like the biggest chess Scandal
since uh The Chronic Hall of match of
2006 so it's been a while
um so yeah I was really reaching quite a
bit of what people are saying
it's this sweet like you wore so it
is oh but this was just a joke because
uh you know Magnus had his podcast with
one episode called the Magnus effect and
uh I was one like I thought that this
podcast was basically just
to announce
um like or to talk about his uh why he's
not defending his title in the world
championship and so now he has something
else that is quite it's quite juicy to
talk about uh so I was wondering okay
just just a bit of a play on words and a
bit of a joke yeah absolutely and um
what kind of effect because on your
situation in the tournament and
grantchester right now suddenly you
check the standings and probably uh
found yourself sharing the second place
before this game no but I'm not really
sure I mean like hands as possible
because uh
like his winning his Magnus doesn't
count and it only shows that like we're
tied because he got let's say a zero for
that game right because the game wasn't
played and I'll get a zero in the last
round when I was supposed to play Magnus
so uh so I'm still half a point uh
behind behind him behind Wesley and
behind Ian who okay Jan is clearly the
biggest beneficiary in the terms of the
tournament for this because uh he lost
the game and this game is as an old so
he went from 50 to possible on this
actually
um for me it doesn't change much I mean
and if anything it's not not really good
for my tournament because it was you
know I already had an extra black in the
tournament
and now I have two extra blocks because
my last round white against Magnus is
erased
um but I I don't like look at it as you
know personally as a negative or
positive it's uh
uh I mean for the Chess World it's a
negative of course but
for my tournament just doesn't change so
much yeah what about today's game how
did it go for you
oh well the game was very interesting
um
but I guess it's not a surprise to say
that this is kind of a forced line it's
drawn it's not a new idea level played
this queen E7 very rare move
and it clearly took shopping here by
surprise he played a very dubious Bishop
to D3
well I shouldn't say dubious it's a fine
move I mean at least to a draw but
basically why is why does walking a
tightrope after that destroy you have to
find his Queen G1 and all this stuff uh
but then he calculated it brilliantly he
found all the correct moves and it was
it was a draw
um
so yeah I was surprised why his decision
that's super risky to play Bishop D3
enemy white could also be a losing you
know his King is on E2 and he's not even
on material but uh but the way we played
was all very correct and the four-strom
yeah I saw you were talking after the
game did he explain some of his
decisions
well no he just
um asked me more or less if the game was
correct because it's clear that he was
uh played on his own and I I came with
preparation
um so he just asked me and I told him
that Queen G1 and everything that he
found was correct and he said that this
queen G1 idea was uh took him some while
to proceed because uh
it's it's a bit strange the queen
usually doesn't defend the king via G1
uh so he said that
um that it took him some while to see
that detail that he's okay here
and uh
how did it feel actually to play today
and to play at home without my moves
without the lyrics who was supposed to
play against him today
well I mean it was more yesterday when
it came as a surprise today it was uh
you know we already knew what was what
was happening but yesterday I kind of
heard that some something would happen
before the game like I I just heard some
rumor that there would be some sort of
you know some development and and I
didn't really think so much of it and
then
and then it happened I mean yeah I saw
that Magnuson shop but he forfeited the
game
and uh but today already we you know
we're used to the situation
and uh
yeah I mean we'll see what happens of
course because uh
it's
quite
quite a big thing to withdraw from the
tournament I don't know if Magnus has
done it before
during the tournament I'm sure he's you
know withdrawn before his ornaments but
during the tournament it's quite a big
development exactly thank you so much
and we are waiting for more news
hopefully okay
[Music]
thank you Anastasia and just an example
leader of the type of content that
people can enjoy on our social media
channel so be sure to subscribe in the
meanwhile we have one exciting game
remaining of the four or three have
already been drawn as we've said and we
see this move G7 G6 and everything about
this position is so dominating for white
Peter it looks it looks horrendous for
for black and Rooks better minor pieces
better Pawn structure what is not to
like but how do you put it to rest I've
been I've been looking at this and yeah
it's just so sad to even like consider
those things but it appears that Hans
for now is trying to defend it by not
even playing Knight B5 because if you do
play Knight B5 it opens up uh this idea
of the The Rook landing on C8 right so
let's say we go 96 check here Black Goes
King G8 we go Rook C1 right or look C4 I
don't know if it makes a difference I
guess Rook C1 is slightly more okay more
precise and then we just don't do
anything with black I don't know Rook F7
knocking H7 or some kind of to allow the
room yeah and it's uh somewhat
surprisingly okay Lanier went a kind of
a different way altogether with the move
of Rook one B3 which I suspect spoils
nothing whatsoever because black really
cannot uh generate any counter play it's
a bit of a surprising move I guess
hinting at Rook G3 perhaps a little bit
yeah trying to trying to provoke it
further further weaknesses on the king's
side it would be nice of course to get
the F5 Square as well as the uh yeah
absolutely yeah in your mid B be as
greedy as possible here exactly with
your advantages but uh the larger point
I think is that
whatever we do with white uh black
really has no counter play at all
unlikely to have any counter play in any
kind of foreseeable future the big
question we have here if we're playing
this mission is wide is how do we uh
create that final threat that cannot be
parried right and I'm still a bit
struggling with it but you know
experience tells you that you know
eventually something comes up and
another thing I I wonder if Rook B3
perhaps although I would be really
really unhappy if I had to do it if I
even if I had to consider it maybe it's
an indication that he wants to go Rook
F3 and then King King F2 King exactly I
I would have guessed exactly the same
Peter that you know you we've maximize
the Rooks we've maximized our night
almost we could put it on E6 our bond
structure is great when no reasons for
us to play H4 H5 or something like that
but King F2 I would very much like to
have the King on E3 but I really hate
the idea of trading any of those
horrible Rooks on the seventh one of
mine I think both of our Rooks are just
so much stronger so much more active
than the roads on G7 and F7 that I think
in my mind it trumps the idea of getting
the king over to E3 I would really not
like that very much I think when the
position remains very good if we do that
yeah but I would prefer not to exactly
um Alejandro is very clean way of just
doing everything we want and having our
cake and eat it too let's put it like
that the difficulty of analyzing this
particular position behind me with an
engine is that it thinks every move wins
so it doesn't really see a difference
between like Rook B3 Rook B2 Knight E6
H4 it doesn't care it thinks that the
advantage is so overwhelming and so long
term that you can move anything and it
still preserves more or less a
three-point Advantage so I try to play
around with it trying to break the
defenses of black it's not so easy but
black runs out of moves faster than he
would like the move King G7 was played I
have the feeling that he's trying to
meet this check with King F6 hinting at
the fact that you might go on to E5 we
know already that he can't because if
you play Rook F3 check King E5 it gets
met with a knight f8 so that would
simply force uh him back to E7 and the
engines again they want to play
something like Rook G3 or Rook C3 but
they also like King F2 they don't think
that it spoils anything at all that you
can trade a pair of Rooks and that your
position is Justice winning as with them
on the board so King G7 Rook F3 is 596
is fine Rook G3 is a move uh the problem
for black mainly is that if this Rook
does get to C8 it came over because when
The Rook gets to C8 imagine that the
knights on B5 or something like this
then this Knight on E6 will always be
threatening Knight d8 and it's just
impossible to meet so at some point an
idea Rook B8 will collect the B7 pawn
and then everything starts collapsing so
King G7 Lanier has a choice of moves 96
is of course the engine stop move
because it has been the top move for a
while you might as well give a check
while you're doing so but everything
else everything wins
and there we have it everything
everything wins a nice dominating
performance by Lanier Lanier just to
refresh everybody he's drawn all of his
games is that right I think so yes he
was he wasn't in Desperate trouble
against Fabiano but he was also winning
against Napo yeah he was there so well
okay A little bit of a roller coaster
ride but this would certainly uh
warm him up to at the event uh King G7 I
love this Knight f8 I just got to show
that again yeah because it's a very very
cute kind of uh you know at first blush
you see this King on E5 and you think oh
finally you have some active play all
you need to do trade Rooks please put
the Knight on B5 I'm back in the game
but the moment you see night night uh
attacking The Rook with a check so that
Rook takes F3 Knight takes D7
just wins a full rope it just wins a
full rook and if you uh do something
else like moving The Rook you just get
checkmated which is it is a very very
nice construction and exactly so we're
expecting 96. yeah it's also perhaps
it's uh worth mentioning that uh it's
move 35 so they have plenty of time I
think linear has just under 20 minutes
and Hans has 27 which for Lanier is a
fantastic luxury Untold reach exactly by
linear standards wow this is a player
we're used to seeing playing on
increment by move 30. at least yeah
probably even earlier than that but
today he had a luxury of a very very
safe position with a lot of pieces
traded off by move 20 so
um yeah he's taking it a bit easier on
the clock today and again I really I
think he's showing uh the class uh play
that he's really noted for is to keep
kept real control foreign
he really is I think uh concentrated
perhaps on the idea of introducing a
another winning Square for the night
with H5 and Knight F5 somewhere exactly
well we've been told by Alejandro that
pretty much nothing and she spoils the
advantage so this is this is still fine
I think it's a
um
a little bit too unnecessary is what I
would like to call it but on the other
hand for uh for Hans here he is now
faced with a kind of an uncomfortable
decision if you allow H5 in the night
lens on F5 your your problem is probably
compound because you you have a very
unsafe king and the pressure against the
D6 Pawn improves and so on if you play
h6h5 yourself yeah after Knight D6 check
there is now an additional G5 Square
available to this Knight it might be a
problem in some variations you
definitely don't want to walk into a
fork if you go King uh H6 as you say
that's just an extra Square yeah in some
positions it might become relevant that
white has 9g5 even though I currently am
sort of struggling to name exactly which
position this will be with the King on
H6 in particular like how do we exploit
the fact that Knight G5 exists well
nothing has been spoiled it's a
completely dominant position because
that pieces don't move exactly this
Knight on A7 cannot allow The Rook uh to
to land on the C8 Square as Alejandra
and perhaps this is the point where we
can go Rook C4 completely uh kill off
all the counter play and then actually
go Rook F3 king of two King E3 and start
trading exactly with the King also on H6
completely out of play and probably
impossible to return and to play frankly
from that structure right
um so yeah linear uh I think
generally speaking I would trust linear
with my life in this type of obsession
with white like I would uh he's not the
only player in the world who I would
really really uh feel that you know he
it's in safe hands but he's definitely
on the list he is a very very solid
positional player he knows how to uh how
to improve advantages you like how to
how to play methodically and and
properly in positions with that such a
large Edge
strengthening the position Alejandro is
a linear he almost feels like a
python-like grip going on here it's a
nightmare to play this with the black
side every move that you make might lose
something the engine's saying that it's
time to take a deep breath and go
forward go King F6 and hope you don't
get mated because now that 96 you get to
E5 before the Rooks on F3 so there's no
Knight f8 the idea specifically is that
on Rook G3 you have Rook F6 barely
holding on but holding on if you play
Rook F3 you cannot take well you can't
take but then you have to play G5 I'm
creating this weakness because F4 when
it kicks out your king it's too powerful
so these are very counter-intuitive
things in my opinion uh but what else
can you do H5 as you mentioned it just
loses you go check King H6 Rook C4 I
like that a lot and then Rook F3 the
engine saying it's an extra Rook
basically for white plus five in this
position it looks like an extra room
frankly that's that is very true and the
King just gets mated so often right
right so you don't have a good choice
here after H4 King F6 is the engine's
top move second best move is King eight
this is just depressing guys yeah it's
just the president position it is not
great I I wonder one thing I wanted to
uh to inquire but I think I have my
answer after king of six uh can I go
Rook F3 Check Yes King E5 Rook F7 Rook
of seven Knight F3
but this actually doesn't feel right
because I thought maybe I can play uh uh
E5 like E5 or Rook B6 and then E5 but it
doesn't win nearly as convincingly as I
thought yeah no not as convincing yeah
and Hans has played Knight B5 uh this
idea I mentioned earlier yeah uh saying
can you can we please at the cost of an
up absolutely healthy Pawn can we at
least please trade away that that
horrendous night I have on A7 I would
assume a linear says uh things but no
thanks but we'll see let's see you have
to assume that right I mean if the king
didn't get to E5
maybe maybe maybe but still I would
still hate it even then I think we we
don't trade like the the one on E6 is
just so much stronger than the one on B5
yes we we never really entertained that
uh that notion no 96 is definitely the
best move in this position like buy it
by a long shot it says that if you do
take on B5 you get this yummy extra Pawn
I mean not even Yasser takes that phone
Knight takes B5 the advantage drops all
the way to plus one I'm not surprised
because if you can see this far that
this king gets to F6 I think you stop
right and you're like many times I don't
win this actually I don't even know if
it's
yeah I would start I would start taking
joy as a favorite over the win right I
was too yeah yeah so I think you play 96
because you don't have a choice
King F6 is might be played but then you
realize Rook F3 is possible we already
know that King E5 fails tonight f8 that
has not changed so the King has to go
back you play Rook C4 and again because
the incursion on C8 is so strong it
doesn't matter if I trade Rooks or not
you have to go Knight A7 right and then
we just kind of get that position we
analyzed already yeah and and The Rook
on D7 you know might never make a move
in that game again so it's extremely
extremely depressing and yeah I mean
Knight takes B5 will absolutely shock me
here I I don't know
if I can recover from the thing yeah
yeah this would be I mean again the
contrast of the two knights uh there's
nothing to weigh up the scale is is
falling overwhelmingly in White's favor
here and
our King is ready to make just a
triumphant entrance as well as the Rook
no no no no no uh that would be terrible
uh just looking at the
I'm just looking at Hans is he just kind
of glancing off into the World there
what's he doing
well it's a it's a you know the posture
of a man who knows his position is bad
but who is still you know he is trying
to keep himself I think one of the
biggest challenges when you play a
position like this is to continue
reminding yourself that the game isn't
over yet you should be con like you
should continue because uh something
that I think people who haven't really
been in that situation very often kind
of underestimate is a psychological
pressure of playing a very very poor
position for hours on end exactly and
you're sitting there and you're staring
at this horrible yeah horrible
collection collection of disjointed
pieces and you you're asking yourself
like why why is this my position why am
I here what have I done yeah and
being able to deal with this and being
able to preserve objectivity and to
preserve you know the the your ability
to to look for best chances to continue
fighting is invaluable and I think all
the best defenders just have this extra
layer of patience
to just sit there and sort of take the
punishment and continue move after move
after move to look for for best
decisions right knowing that against
best Play It's All futile right this is
the feeling that gets you that you you
you're playing against a strong player
you know that you're basically waiting
for a mistake whatever you do from here
against best play will be uh uh you know
in the end will be completely for naught
right uh but you you you mustn't give up
you must you must preserve your
concentration you must look for for
small chances it's not easy uh
but it's uh it's something that you you
need to learn to do
as my friend Jeremy Silman says chess is
hard and then you die something like
that uh Knight E6 check
um
a bit surprising because again I would
never go into that rook and pawn ending
the chances of a draw are just too high
yeah they Skyrocket compared to okay
compared to these positions yeah and uh
okay nothing nothing more to say 96
check
you know we've all had our share of that
positions and you're always looking uh
just to put up the best resistance you
can find some tricks in the position
you know yesterday we had this terrible
position for MBL and he found some
stalemate ideas and he came really close
he almost he almost saved me he almost
saved me he almost saved it by
preserving that that sort of uh you know
layer of
come come sort of acceptance that the
position is bad but there are still good
moves to be found there is still chances
to be sought out and right uh you know
he came like at some point he stopped
and he came up with this concept that I
just must
liquidate into two versus zero on one
side Queen and even even if we start
from a position which is mathematically
lost it still represents my best chance
and he just sort of laser focused and
went for it right and yes he was lost at
the beginning but he continued looking
for best child best choices and
eventually the game did come back to
drawing margins it's just difficult to
play and mistakes are I think almost
inevitable in those types of Queen
endings but yeah it's a good example of
uh hello
I was about to say hello
oh what
Knight takes B5 what are you serious
hello hello
wow okay that's stunning
now I mean uh uh Hans must be soaring at
this very very good news uh Peter I I I
don't really I don't really understand
this I'm a pond grubber but Knight E6
was just so overwhelmingly strong
wow wow I I think this is just yeah very
very difficult well maybe he goes Rook
F3 now maybe that's his point but I
still don't like it this is bizarre guys
this is bizarre Knight E6 what are we
witnessing here
yeah I don't know maybe he didn't see
neither fate
but even like I don't I don't know I'm
I'm kind of struggling uh struggling to
find uh justification for this trade it
just makes no sense to uh ourselves and
I I you know I've I've given the hard
vouch here for for linear's position
understanding I'm not life I'm not going
to withdraw it I still I still feel that
linear is an extremely extremely sound
positional player I just don't we have
really three on the board after Knight
takes because I think that's what he
played yeah yeah I mean otherwise that
at least explains something capturing on
B5 would have allowed black to
immediately bring his King to the E5
Square even this though Alejandro how
badly did that impact the engine's uh
evaluation or why does better by point
four point four so it went down by three
yeah that is a bit of a shocker frankly
the the only way I can explain it is
that he uh just he missed Knight f8 did
not see that neither fight just wins the
the entire house and he thought okay 96
the king will come to E5 it's difficult
to attack it and let's make our life
slightly easier but yeah it just loses
on the spot tonight of eight as we
continue pointing out just there is a
point though if you don't see Knight f8
I mean you're still like king of two I
think I'm still better honestly I think
I think even if I go King Juan F2 in
this position I think I'm still better
oh no there's no question you're better
I'm just wondering if uh you start to
panic and think that I'm allowing play
or something maybe yeah I don't know
it's uh but if it's a strange thing I'm
just saying if you don't see Knight f8
of course guys uh Knight f8 would have
won the game instead we do have a rook
fe7 is a very logical reply to Rook of
three there to uh you know not make it
easy for y to take on B5 it makes
perfect sense why just obviously white
would very much like no no he played
Rook F7 first oh sorry
uh from this position ab5 Rook F3 Rook
Fe so look F7 makes perfect sense we're
dying though the white rocks to the
protection of the evil Pawn linear
played King of two and Rook C7 just look
at this position suddenly the Rooks have
there The Rook on C7 will now be on I
don't know C2 or C3 or somewhere and I
mean white is still obviously you know
there's zero risk involved but why have
we done this why is y better
no I'm not better I'm saying white will
not under normal circumstances will not
lose this position that's my that's my
claim it's a shock yeah but I I don't
really understand this I I think this is
uh very very odd
and if you if you were so worried about
the king landing on E5 you could have
played 96 sort of Ages ago and it
wouldn't even go into G7 exactly there
was no G6 in the position so at the time
that you could have played 96 Jack yeah
I I don't quite uh yeah I don't quite
understand this
hahaha
time to one thing about the same field
yeah I mean it just has it all guys I
mean wow what sorry time to trot out the
old foul excuses yeah he's you know he's
hypnotizing me and you know like the old
Dal benko stories exactly yeah I can't I
can't play against Misha he works he
wears those dark glasses and I I get I
get hypnotized
I don't know it's uh it's just so very
unusual from a player specifically like
Lanier who you know he's been beating me
like a drum in quiet positional games
for the last 20 years I've been on the
receiving end of it enough to to be
understand to to be kind of shocked at
this
I think my first introduction to linear
was I think it was the
terrain Olympian maybe 06 which is I
mean not 20 years ago but you know close
enough and he was very young and I was a
kind of an established figure not you
know
and uh I played some kind of a Spanish
against him and didn't entirely equalize
and then I found some manure which I
thought improved my position enough to
be able to offer a draw right because I
try not to offer enjoy positions which I
know are bad right but I thought okay
maybe this is slightly worse but it's
not very much I have like some raging
advantage and it's a team event he'd be
like maybe right he spent about zero
seconds of refusing dismissive yeah just
like No And and just swept me off the
board and like I remember that you know
it sticks in your memory like when when
somebody just sort of shows you where
your place is and right and and backs it
up with with play so yeah for me this is
very very kind of difficult to to
process right uh Alejandra jumped in
when did you first uh meet Lanier and
recognize that he was the greatest
balances Jose capablanca from Cuba it
was at the capablanca memorial it wasn't
the devil yeah that was the first time I
ever met him he was playing the elite
section I was playing the one under the
premiere section it's where I got my
first Grand Master Norm in 2003 and the
first time I played him I believe was at
the Continental of the same year we were
both leading the tournament something
like four and a half out of five maybe
five and a half out of six and I got to
play Black against and we played a
fascinating fashionicuff I had a
decisive Advantage but then he outplayed
me and he ended up winning that game
um so I've always known he's very strong
he's a couple a few years older than me
so we always looked up to him as uh
probably the most promising figure uh
him and bruzon to come out of Latin
America for a very long time perhaps
since Granda so we're all very well
Familiar of who Dominguez was
and uh don't you feel in similarly uh
stunned by this decision to go into this
four Rook ending when I have no words no
words right no words it's like not
capturing a piece or something
it just feels so bizarre it's just so
weird I mean tonight on E6 for the night
on B5 really right and not only that but
there works I don't get it guys yeah I
just don't get it and I don't I don't
know if this is like being tired from
too many events in a row maybe this is
what's starting to affect players
because linear has been on a tour right
right he has been in a tour for a while
he went to India he came here played the
St Louis rapid and Blitz blade which
went atrociously for him and he's coming
to this tournament he's had some up and
downs he didn't see Bishop takes d66
against nepo a little uncharacteristic
or he saw it but Mis evaluated it pretty
badly
um he held on to Favi but he was lost at
some point I don't know perhaps Lanier
needs a little bit of a break because
this is very uncharacteristic absolutely
and just looking at the engine
suggestion behind you uh after the move
King E3 Rook C2 I mean what uh what a
difference a few moves makes because a
moment ago Black's Rooks were absolutely
stuck in mud they were going nowhere and
suddenly this Rook coming to C2
activates itself hits the G2 Pawn asks
quite some questions
and I think
Hans is in a great shape to save what
was
lost position yeah
it's strange and uh
one thing I will I will say you know
perhaps I'm talking entirely out of
do it say it but uh you know uh perhaps
the uh
the situation around the tournament is
actually affecting players more than we
know right is what I'm going to say
perhaps uh you know shocking as it may
sound uh Lanier just feels you know the
simpler the position the better
that would be like still I don't really
I I don't really feel like this would be
you know part of the part of the
conversation here but I'm struggling to
figure out how a player as strong as he
is uh would arrive at the decision he
arrived at with like what he had like 17
minutes at the time right not not on 30
seconds like on 17 minutes for like four
moves
um yeah I I don't know uh actually it
was kind of funny because I was I I I
was trying to think of a great Scandal
that happened in the world of Chess and
I was coming up with a blank for a while
there until I was watching that Bobby
special with Anastasia where Fabi said
in a toilet gate I remember toilet games
that was great uh Vladimir cranbic
versus not not the word not the word I
would describe it but uh but you
remember that again a cheating
allegation and a World Chess
Championship with absolutely nothing uh
to back it up and prepare for some very
very angry tweets yeah exactly exactly
and uh what was your perspective on uh
when you heard all of this uh I I still
I still get Flack even now from my
position on this topic which someone
surprises me it's been what uh 2006. so
it's been 16 years but uh yeah if uh
it's it's sort of interesting because uh
the moment the story hit we were all
home uh watching from home I wasn't part
of the of the team I mean I've been
close to Vladimir for a number of years
but I wasn't part of that team
for understandable reasons
I mean no no play montages the people
not wanting to hire me as a second okay
I understand them entirely but anyway I
wasn't I wasn't part of the team there
and then the story hit and we
sort of all of our own accord where you
like assembled a bunch of people like
Olga my wife and me and ILY a little bit
of a friend of both like our friend and
of Vladimir's Vladimir's friend as much
uh as as much as ours maybe more than
ours
we just bought tickets and all flew to a
list just to like really uh cool just to
kind of be next to Vlad as it's going on
and perhaps you know it will be on a
very very you know small percentage
point maybe it will improve his mood to
know that his friends are behind him
right and this immediately Drew
accusation of
like I think the the direct quote from
the book is that the Russian Chess
Federation ordered the forces to
immediately go to immobilize it oh my
gosh I mean I mean like his friend
showing up it was interesting to me
because yeah
I didn't know it was it was a sort of a
kind of a genuine like one of those
episodes of like you genuinely feel bad
for somebody you care about because
right I felt that you have a lot to be
excused accused of cheating was a bit a
bit too much right uh and I thought you
know maybe just maybe it will be good
good for him to know that you know he is
yes he still has support and yeah the
reaction from the other side was that
we're obviously doing this because we
ordered to do this I mean if that's if
that's your if that's how you view human
relationships okay I mean that's not for
me to judge I was a bit surprised wow
wow I didn't know that part of the story
uh but uh again that was the one where
in the world championship match there
were suggestions that uh Vladimir
kramnik the reigning Champion was going
into the bathroom to somehow consult
some electronics that might be hidden
there nothing of course was ever found
and he ended up winning a very dramatic
uh tiebreaker yeah that was an election
that was uh that was great stuff
um any developments going on uh
Alejandra can you share what we think
Lanier and Hans where they may be headed
in this ending yeah absolutely I think
Hans is considering where to activate
his Rook he has two big choices Rook C2
trying to get to this Pawn here on G2
but it's also in some way a waiting move
because if you take on B5 in this
position yes I could take on G2 they can
just say it's okay but you could also
just go back to C4 and the point is that
there's no really comfortable way of
defending this Pawn if you ever play the
move Rook F4 and I hit you with Rook a
horror G5 or whatever you just Rooks are
just stuck right they're just not gonna
make a move in the rest of the game so
um that's not really a winning attempt I
like Rook C2 a similar idea is to play
Rook C1 all the way down to C1 the point
is that if you take on B5 of course Rook
C4 works but a more human approach just
go a check here and on King D3 takes
Rook one takes E4 it looks like you have
this trick of Rook takes B7 but this
actually ends up being a draw because
after check you actually have to block
your Rook from uh the third Rank and I
guess it didn't matter because you go
behind the pawn anyway so this is a just
a dead dead draw Roxy one works Rook C2
plate also works I think this is just
gonna head for the draw in not that much
amount of time because black is pretty
active here absolutely Rook uh C2 on the
board and we're going to take a short
break and we're going to see on the
other side thank you for staying with us
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame
Cutting Edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art Innovative programming
explores the intersection of Chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to our continued coverage
of round five of the single cup with
only one game running and that game had
a stunning turnaround just just before
the uh the first time control it's and
we might have our first round of this
event which will feature no decisive
games with the position being what it is
right now we've had three out of the the
four games drawn already and this is the
game that's currently going on between
Lanier and Hans Neiman this last move
Rook F2 I'm expecting the simple Rook C1
Peter just uh getting ready go ahead
take my Pawn please Rook E1 check on
Black's agenda this feels totally
totally totally dry well it's it's
specifically drawn because of that line
that Alejandro's shown and I was
actually wondering about this entire
thing because I couldn't quite equalize
it as comfortably for black but this
idea that after rugby five you can go I
mean Rook C4 probably also draws but you
can go rookie one rookie four allow Rook
takes B7
I mean not African u3 I mean uh sorry
the line Bird yeah we'll keep on
checking D3 King David three sorry
now the line that Alejandro showed
earlier Rook one E4 yep and it looks for
a second like root 87 is winning but
it's not because we take on B7 we give a
checkup before and we're just in time to
attack the pawn on A5 from uh the A4
square and win it and then there's
really nothing left to play for exactly
uh that line I think provides such an
you know tremendous additional layer of
security because if if you didn't have
that with black then maybe you after
Rook takes B5 you play Rook C4 while it
goes Rook F4 yes I understand all the
arguments about the white Rooks having
no squares but you're still down upon in
The Rook endings so you're you're not a
hundred percent sure you're not losing
here exactly uh but you can just make a
pretty much a straight straightforward
Force draw with Rook C1 and then rookie
one check if allowed and the stunner for
us in case you're joining us late of
course is this decision this absolutely
mystifying decision to trade at nights
bilinear when the move Knight E6 check
was so obviously dominating uh Black's
position the night on E6 versus the
Knight on B5 is no contest we were
looking at a variation with King H7
something along those lines it just
looks horrendous just yeah that was
terrible the engine went from like a
plus three advantage to virtually no
Advantage after Knight takes B5 and this
is where we find ourselves and as you
were saying this could very well be the
first round where we don't experience at
least one decisive game yeah they have
plenty of time they've just made time
control very very recently I think uh
I'm actually not sure I thought the
clocks were showing time before anyone
ran out of the first time controlled but
uh that still feels right to me to be
honest I think they were both playing
quickly enough that these are let's
check yeah that's about right yeah yeah
I think I think I'm right on this yeah
yeah
so that was my move
uh so yeah there's there's plenty plenty
of time for both of them to uh to play
this end game but the end game no longer
is all that exciting right uh compared
to just how much advantage
uh linear had earlier I'm also wondering
if maybe Rook C3 check followed by King
D4 Rook A3 is not an even more
straightforward immediate draw
because I want to take on A5 if you give
it to give me the A5 Pawn like why am I
ever worse exactly and if you play Ruby
five I go rookie Rook A4 check right and
then after King G3 I don't even have to
take one E4 I can play Rook A3 check I
think
and just make a draw this way that's the
most clear so maybe this is also just a
very uh a very safe way of making the
draw as well seems like black might even
have like a wealth of wealth of choices
here to
to to
hold the reasonably comfortably um I
don't agree I don't disagree with Peter
I think there are a lot of ways that uh
he can defend Alejandro a wealth of
choices but that's not not that one yeah
if you give a checking before and go
Rook A3 you can still play other moves
like Rook C1 yeah I was wondering if
actually was working yeah this is pretty
strong because you take take you don't
want to get stuck defending the B7
problem with both of your Rooks but if
you go into the same game and you allow
it doesn't matter if you give me a check
I'll cover them before I'll eventually
play Rook B6
and then e45. this is very ugly yeah you
might you might very very easily lose
this with black yeah yeah as I was
giving the speech I realized we're going
to existed and I was kind of Desperately
hoping it's still not changing the
variation somehow but uh
got caught exposed there yes a little
bit a little bit yeah
a little bit but there's so many other
moves right it's more logical in my
opinion even check here and then Rook C1
to me which is what we also thought was
a nice way I think this is the nicest
way because you'll be able to get Rookie
one and take try to take on e4 with
Chuck we already know that Rook F4 is
not really a good at winning attempt
so we're just waiting for Hans to figure
out which one of those which one he
likes the most yeah I think I think From
This Moment onwards yeah he should be uh
he should be okay you know to such an
extent that I'm wondering is white even
winning if we go Rook I mean nobody ever
does that but my question is
has the position deteriorated for white
to such an extent that I can go Rook F2
King F2 put my king on E5 no and King E3
King E5 Rook B5 Rook C7
no no it has not deteriorated that much
and maybe this one I also don't lose but
obviously there's absolutely no way to
check like I mean there's no reason to
check is what I mean like it is like
absolutely no call for black to subject
themselves to this and also the answer
might be no no I mean you're giving uh
White that opportunity like you you
never do that yeah Rook C1 played in the
meantime by uh by Hans let's jump back
to the game Rook C1
that's a good one yeah
that's one of the good ones one of the
good ones absolutely yeah it feels like
uh the advantages is pretty much
entirely gone I just don't don't see how
we get anywhere from here I mean an
attempt would be a move like Rook F2 E2
Rook F2 to E2 yeah trying to perhaps
take on B5 and then be able to play King
D3 after Rook C4 but let's say even if
that happens let's say we play King of
six here right okay Rook takes B5 okay
Rook C4
King G3 and we put the Rook on A4
okay I mean the difference in Rook
activity here is such that I I I have a
feeling this we're not winning I
even this one oh man yeah I think I
think there shouldn't be enough honestly
like before his weekly five is weak the
king is about to land only five and then
Ruby D4 check ideas will even become the
uh part of the equation yeah
at some point black will start playing
for a win there
okay E5 Rook takes E5 Rook F2 Rook like
a five yeah I mean probably still a draw
but you're definitely deciding to prefer
black there yeah I was hoping to take on
B7 with a check yeah nope yeah what's
happening yeah it feels like uh it feels
like it should be very very manageable
for black in most of these cases so
are you feeling like me that uh the rest
day tomorrow very very much needed I'm
getting numbed from the whole Magna
story yeah I want to put that to bed the
rest I I still haven't internally uh
properly processed yeah I think so yeah
and uh it's it's it's pretty much the
same for me I feel that
um
it's it's become
you know the single cup has always been
this sort of Festival of joy to such a
life because we like it's it's uh you
know top players playing very very good
chess in in in in friendly friendly
atmosphere there's always this feeling
that everybody is constantly in good
mood regardless of how the tournament is
going because the club provides you know
such a uh welcoming atmosphere and
what we're seeing right now is a very
very unusual for uh for the tournament
and completely different feeling and
vibration if you will and uh it's it's
sad it's it shouldn't be like this it
shouldn't be like this and uh the Hope
has to be that uh somehow it gets back
on track but yeah
um the rest is very welcome but I I
don't know if I believe that we will be
entirely in the clear but right by
September 7th uh Alejandro I thought
your interview with with Maurice was
wonderful where again he reminded us of
so many joyous moments from the
Singapore club we might taking us back
to the very first one where Magnus
famously declined the draw in the last
round against Levon a draw would have
clinched first and he refused and it was
like this electricity that went through
the studio when that occurred then the
7-0 streak and all of these celebrations
and this is a completely different uh
feeling I'm having as we're going into
the rest day oh absolutely I mean what
we were talking about back then was just
the chess and I had the pleasure of
being in every single slingfield cup
that's happened so far I've been
pressing for them I remember when Fabio
170 I was doing the sideline commentary
not the broadcast but I was doing the
in-person commentary for fans that
wanted to come in and talk to
Grandmasters while following uh the
games with Ben Feingold over at Kings
Island at the World Chess Hall of Fame
and that was like Joy right you know
you're seeing history in the making in
the right way when you think about it
this is history in the making Magnus
Carlsen quitting a chess tournament
packing his bags and going home that's
history in the making but is it the
history that we want to be witnessing
I'm not so sure I still am in a little
bit of shell shock of what's happening
right of uh what the internet is saying
about everything that's surrounding the
tournament more than the tournament
itself is sometimes felt that you know
the chassis on the on the backdrop of
everything that's surrounding it and
that's never as a commentator where you
want to be one of the joyful moments
that I love sharing was after the streak
7-0 uh the closing ceremony blah blah
blah there was a press conference with
all the players with Mike Klein asked
the players could you sum up uh
Fabiano's result in a single word
and down the line it went magnificent
amazing uh
fantastic and so on it came to Magnus
and Magnus said depressing
this was a great response I mean it
stole the show with one single word
depressing and good times and that's
what we've been experiencing for all the
uh editions of the sink fill cup but now
it's just something changed it's not
it's not fun it's it's it's obviously
not the same and you know the and I very
much sort of echo the the sentiments of
a number of people who have interviewed
on this topic of that right some kind of
uh cleaning of areas necessary but what
is happening right now is we're not
getting like perhaps it's the start of
the conversation but right now we're
nowhere near
achieving that goal exactly back to the
game I'm just going to refresh for a
moment I don't suspect too much has
taken place and in fact it hasn't and
yeah King G3 which doesn't really change
very much
once again I guess the trick is if you
play it okay one Rook fp2 perhaps
creates a bit of a bit of pressure it's
stronger with the King on D4 but for the
kingdom D3 as well it's probably pretty
strong one moreover uh take pardon me if
I play Rook A1 yeah Rook have B2 I think
is the issue here otherwise the side
checks otherwise that's way too strong
but preparing to meet them by
interposing on the v-file and then
taking on B5 this could be a problem for
black potentially in in some positions
even here I'm not so sure it's that
horrible but because I have I have
sources of checks from from both both
the side and from behind from like
starting with D1 check but I I have a
feeling Rook A1 is not clean something
else must be cleaner
I look pretty good to me Peter I don't
know Rook C1 uh King D3 on the board uh
I could yeah we could start with I think
linear wants to go Rook D2 and then
we're facing the same question again let
me just look yvoni exactly maybe just
put the Rook on Ivan and say do your
worst yeah again because of that
variation that uh Alejandro had pointed
here it might not work though because we
have Rook D4 after the check we may have
actually played ourselves into some
trouble no no we have a Perpetual
immediately right yeah exactly you don't
have the Rook D4
that will cost The Rook of course so and
you can I mean we keep on leaving the
bottle yeah yeah yeah yeah you you you
you can't leave The Rook on pre you
can't you have to stay connected and
then rookie through rookie 4 is just to
try out hold on yes exactly so it's
still just a drop so draws with checks
that's
that's usually a very very good sign for
the defender when you can roll the game
with a series of checks
jump in Alejandro uh
nothing uh no tricks that Lanier can
pull out of his hat on this one huh not
really I mean the material is very
reduced white structure is not even
particularly good right you have a
backboard Pawn on e4 so you're not
achieving very much the best you can do
is try to take on B5 for free but as
long as Hans is clever about his Rook
positioning that's impossible it's just
impossible to do 51 check is fine where
K1 is fine
saw a lot of moves that are fine
yeah I think the question by this point
began becomes uh what would be the way
here for black
to spoil to spoil things gradually
obviously there are some very very bad
moves immediately here which we can name
like I don't know suddenly pushing the
Rook on C1 on some kind of a passive
square like Rook one C5 here is a kind
of a maybe it doesn't lose yet but it's
kind of an unthinkable move because why
would you do that okay exactly rook fb2
and your position suddenly has become
quite risky exactly but without making a
one move blunder like which of hans's
choices actually generate like half a
chance for white I think it is Rook A1
because after Rook a one Rook fb2
if you follow through with your idea of
taking on A5 then maybe you are worse
then you're walking down yeah a
difficult path suddenly maybe this is
the one where you you suddenly there are
some chances at least exactly even
though like even this position might not
be that horrible because I think what I
do here with black is I don't trade
Rooks so I go like Rook A4
you have to play Rook before I give a
check from my three King D4 King D4 okay
it'll be three I wanted to go back to A4
but yeah like I think this is this is
the way black might blames himself into
trouble because otherwise it feels like
as long as the Rook stays active and as
long as we don't get distracted by the
idea of winning the A5 Pawn which really
is not that crucial in the grand scheme
of things uh we should be completely
fine here is black exactly and just to
reiterate the one position that we
really do want to avoid is black is
something of the this nature where they
use this king before yeah yeah the king
gets the D4 but more importantly The
Rook gets to B6 and E4 E5 becomes uh a
killer blow in fact yeah those those are
potentially just straight up lost
exactly exactly so I could very easily
imagine them just being straight up lost
right so avoid that keep the four Rooks
on the board and Hans should be gold uh
Rook D1 check rookie one Rook e one oh
look
perfectly playable here
time the factor not not yet no they've
just passed the uh the time control so I
think I saw on the on the large screen
yeah they're 95 minutes yeah 35 against
28 so they both just got their second
allotment of uh off time so there's
plenty and plenty of playing in in the
game in terms of time remaining maybe
not in the position of black plays
precisely but the other is still a ways
to go
uh one of the things in the world of
Chess that we always talk about are
trainers people who work with the
players sometimes that that's
information I know in the world
championship match oftentimes you try to
keep your tree the names of the trainers
uh like if I if I take you uh suddenly
everybody's looking at yaz's grunfeld as
a potential in particular trainers to
the players of this event uh let's see
if I can like Fabi I think is uh here
with Christian as far as we we can't
established right uh and uh the rest
nepo uh are things working with nipple
well young you know everybody else feels
like they're working with Skype right
there and you know I I don't think we
should be providing the you know the
specifics about exactly you know who's
on the other the other end
but uh in terms of people present here I
think apart from Christian
uh and uh well we saw Peter Heine really
yeah okay
yeah that would be that would be the
second person I would name you know
right maybe the first if Magnus was
still in the tournament but uh yeah that
is
Peter Hyland is now here for baseball
basically yes
but what do we know about say Wesley and
Lavon and MBL and for that matter uh
farouja 19 year old uh who is he working
with this far if you know I don't I
don't really know I mean I I assume he
has a decent decent sort of uh support
cast in France now he he has and I think
he's on very very good terms with a lot
of uh a lot of the French chess scene
and there's been some rumors about who
he may have potentially worked for for
the candidates like there was a uh the
the the the the one that felt the most
uh interesting was that apparently he
worked with Vladimir a little bit pride
of candidates which is interesting in
itself but it which is particularly
interesting considering some of the
things Vladimir said about the
candidates
uh terrible worst tournament ever held
under the under the blue sun and you're
very very well connected with the Chess
World Alejandro
um expose the secrets of the players who
are their trainers or not
look at the handshake I don't know I
don't know I don't know oh no no it's
particularly about furuja I have no idea
they've kept that pretty much Under
Wraps I've heard of the kramnik thing I
think there has been like it's fairly in
the open I think kind of I think
Vladimir kind of mentioned something
yeah but that's that's pretty much it
yeah
wow
okay uh somehow I mean I don't think we
really uh back and say when Anatoly
karpov was playing all of these matches
with Gary Kasparov I think it was very
clear that he had his
yeah
yeah while while Geller was still uh
right active yeah there was a kind of a
core team around uh around Anatoly and
also a court team around Gary yeah it's
easier to hide your seconds when you
have the internet though yeah
they stay at home yeah revenue is not
actually traveling with you it becomes a
bit easier yeah to to be secretive about
this if you decide to be secretive about
it exactly as people I think generally
do these days not everybody though I
remember we had this conversation with
Fabi if we were gonna like keep who's
working for the team secret and he just
won
we went to the beach and he like posted
an Instagram picture with all of us I
was like well that's at the end of that
secret yeah
although obviously there have been
nicely done Bobby
I think I think some of those kind of
grand reveals were was the word
accidental right I think Miki was
revealed kind of by accident in one of
the pictures so it's it's not always on
purpose but with Fabi I think at least
in part it is on purpose you know
who has been one of the most surprising
uh trainers the playing working again
for a rival that you've uh you were
stung by or if it happened
I'm kind of struggling to to name
anything and to me like this idea in
particular with everything that went on
afterwards the idea that Vladimir worked
worked uh with with kind of striking to
me because I I didn't think
Vladimir would be in the coaching
business just yet but right I mean this
is not entirely coaching because you
know the rest of being as good as as he
is uh I'm sure there's also it's
interesting also for for Vladimir
because it's a kind of an exciting new
Talent on the scene and you get to right
you get to kind of pick his brain and
see how how things work and you know
what makes him tick and so on uh but
yeah if you got an opportunity Peter for
example just gives you a call out of the
blue and says Please Mr Peter's Fiddler
would you ever be interested in working
with me
I feel that you know I've been I've been
scarred by my own mishaps as a second
and as a coach so much that I think the
problem will be would be on my side like
I would feel that I I'm I would be
hesitant because I wouldn't know if I
can provide enough value I'd be
extremely interested but I would be
extremely worried that you know they're
doing this of some kind of misplaced
sense of like outdated respect which
which is no longer really very valid but
in general yeah I mean this new
generation of of kids is it must be very
very exciting to to be around and uh
should be a lot of fun it's just that
yeah I've uh I I I I don't know if if
I'm the person they should be contacting
contact and also judging by a lack of
contact they probably have come to the
same time same conclusion and how about
you Alejandro as a chess coach you're
working each and every day with these uh
youths the Young Generation you're
enjoying your work
I'm enjoying my work a lot and it's fun
to see how these youth think and how
they use the engines and how they just
expect different things than we used to
back when we worked
um a kind of full-time on chess and it's
fascinating to see them they're very
hungry people so it's always good to be
around them if you feel encouraged to
play sometimes and yes a lot of my
students have enjoyed great success I
mean especially on the Olympiad when
Nicolas theodoro was fighting for the
medals he actually got silver medal in
that one so yeah it's it's pretty great
and I think having the opportunity to
see how the Young Generation thinks
about different positions is a very
rewarding part of the job nice and since
we are sort of waiting for a move here
in Texas
one of the most enjoyable things I've
done in that respect was for that for
that Mexico City uh World Championship
in 07 the situation was uh in at those
times as I mentioned like I've won a
game in the tournament basically due to
the amount of Stellar work Alexander
motive subject for
for me for me yeah but he was playing I
believe in the higher League maybe not
the Super Final I think specifically the
higher leak is a qualifier for the Super
Final uh and he asked for permission to
arrive a bit late because there was a
very very important tournament
potentially qualifying him for for the
national championship and I said sure
because like of course of course he also
is a very active chess player we you
know he I didn't really feel like he was
my employee he was a he was a lifelong
friend and if he wanted to play a
tournament of course he's going to play
the tournament right but uh you know the
world championship it's a very long
event uh we were allowed to come way in
advance because I think the organizers
and we were all very grateful to do them
for that they recognized that most of
the participants are going to be coming
from Europe right and there is going to
be a lot of you know jet lag
acclimatization issues so they gave us I
think maybe a week in advance uh uh to
to come with you know the hotel provided
and everything
but it will be a bit lonely there right
on your own like seven days before the
tournament starts and I think Alexander
came after round three so that was
almost two weeks all told before I would
have my uh my second with me right and I
thought okay what can I do about this
and then I thought
you know my best childhood friend we've
never actually traveled together
anywhere and I I I called him and I said
do you want to go to Mexico
and he said sure he's so sure and uh so
we traveled together and like all the
all the the participants you know arrive
and then you you go for breakfast
and I'm with this guy who has no one has
ever seen before right in the mystery
apart from Sasha grayish you know who
has been to my kids birthdays and so on
so he knew but nobody else knew right
and there is this like habab you know
like there's this
it was very enjoyable yeah for the first
two days like people I think eventually
realize what's going on but for the
first couple of days it was excellent
right because like I I enjoyed this area
of Mystique you know because I found
some some secret weapons to bring them
with the most important tournament in uh
yeah we visited the pyramids we did a
lot of touristy stuff it was excellent
it was really really enjoyable I like it
talk about throwing your Rivals off uh
their stride still no uh move uh nope
after King D3 Hans going in the tank and
well we we're been looking at it we
don't see the tricks Rook D1 Rook E1
Rook A1 all seem to be perfectly fine
um
Peter just as we who kind of like
talking I don't see I haven't uh yeah
there's there's really yeah the reason
we're talking about kind of non-chess
related stuff there is that we're just
waiting for Hans to pick one of the we
assume at least three perfectly playable
moves and perhaps even more exactly and
until he does it's difficult to say new
things about this position if black
plays precisely if black doesn't you
know gravitate towards some passive
positions he should make a draw uh
reasonably easily I would assume right
just because you mentioned Mexico there
was San Luis Argentina
how many candidates like well hold on
San Luis was a world champion and so was
and so I think a city was the world
championship the Madrid tournament that
we just had was a candidate how many
World Championships
tournaments did you play I played two I
think I played San Luis and I played
Mexico City and I played three
candidates so five in total
um
and finally Rook D1 check yeah it is it
is on the board the Assumption has to be
that you're blinking you through with
the intention of playing Rook D2 and
then we will see where the route goes I
assume he won but probably A1 is still
fine
King E3 here looking through takes D5 we
are stopped unhappy yes sorry uh Rook D2
you were saying I think rooked it too
yeah I think this was this must have
been the invention at least but yeah now
we choose another square like either A1
or E1 whichever one you prefer yeah I
like this one this one is it certainly
feels the most forcing and yeah probably
is yeah and sort of pass the the
question over to linear like how are you
willing to proceed here exactly at some
point you've got to do something I mean
uh G5 something if the Rook if the Rook
leaves file even king of 65 in some
positions becomes part of the part of
the conversation for black so absolutely
absolutely
uh through these five World Championship
candidates uh did you change trainers
often or did you rather yeah gravitate
to the same team sorry no I'm in 405 and
07 I was working very actively with a
with uh Alexander motelov and uh and
then he kind of got poached
I I I did not yeah yeah it wasn't very
enjoyable because I I we we're we're
also born on the same day so there was a
lot of you know like a kind of every
year one of us every year one of us
calls the other and says you know we're
happy birthday happy birthday to you
yeah reverse charges of course
yeah but but then he he got co-opted
first I think into the uh the kramnik
team and then into coaching the Russian
national team which he continues doing
until uh until today uh and then for the
kind of that's uh from 13 to the 16
onwards uh uh it was I mean Maxima
matlakov was featured in all three and
uh in Nikita golf helped me for the
first two and four for 2016. Yam was
actually part of the
part of the Brigade there really yeah
yeah
involved a lot of hearthstone yeah that
that involved that involved a lot of
Hearts
how does one prepare for candidates a
lot of hearthstone that's what it takes
Rook E1 on the board absolutely the
prescribed way to prepare for
the most important tournament in your
year did I see that in the background in
your background that the computer now
recommends G2 G4 Alejandro it's all
zeros but it's still all zero all zeros
yeah okay nothing changes perhaps it's
actually time to pull the plug here just
to go Ruby five Rook B7 and accept that
perpetual
right Rook B5 I'm assigning a non-zero
probability of this happening
you can also just play rookie too right
you don't have to be that fancy yeah
okay sure yeah you can you can also just
repeat without that's a good point
exactly
what makes a good trainer a good second
a good coach
um I think uh for me a very important
part of the equation there is having a
rap war with uh with the person you're
working with on a purely human level I
think you know considering the amount of
time you're going to be spending
together exactly in another company
you've got to get along yeah if if
there's no if there's no human contact
if it's just purely a purely a chess
thing at some point it just starts uh
becoming a dragon it very much impacts
the work product so to speak so you know
having having a circle of friends who
who are also willing to to look at chess
with you is very useful uh but uh for
for me I mean
that really is sort of the first and the
foremost in my mind but uh uh
I don't really
like I sort of know how to work uh but I
don't do any of my best work alone it
feels that like for me as a player I
kind of lacked structure something that
for instance like if you look at uh and
I have had the privilege of watching it
from very very close quarters like if
you watch Vladimir kramnik work on chess
he provides his own structure he knows
exactly what he what he needs to do he
he knows his his goals he knows he uh
there's long-term planning as in terms
of like which openings he needs to look
for and uh and the way he wants to look
at them and uh that was maybe the early
kind of a guiding line and I still have
some habits from from working with and
for Vladimir in terms of like how you
how you look at chess positions how you
approach sort of creating the file very
very sort of specific things which are
still are very much you know fresh in my
mind in terms of that but
for myself uh I've always liked lacked
that that kind of structure and in
particular for the kind of the starting
from 2013 I think for me working with
Nikita golf was uh invaluable because uh
he was very good specifically at that
apart from being a very strong chess
player who generates ideas and uh is
extremely useful as a chess player for
me specifically he was
sort of in charge of you know creating
creating a battle plan creating a a
concept of what we're going to be doing
because in particular for 2013 it was
massively required due to the fact that
I've been the one E4 player in my entire
life right and that candidates was like
every single person could play either
the Petra for the Berlin
and uh and and we very early on we came
to this realization that we either have
to spend like our entire time trying to
find like two ideas which might be good
for two games against the against the
Petrov and the Berlin or we have to sort
of revamp the approach from uh from the
ground up one yeah and and uh the three
of us where I was working with Nikita
and Maxima lakov for that we basically
made me into a semi-competent 1d4 player
uh over the course over the course of
the next I don't know four years it
obviously required some shortcuts like
you you can't really cover that amount
of information properly so like some
ideas were extremely extremely
short-lived but for that kind of this
tournament I was definitely I feel one
of the better players better prepared
players in the tournament
which is generally just so far away from
this from from the truth like when I
play normally like in a field which
includes like Vladimir and Levon and and
the young Magnus and the rest of that
field like there is no way I'm anywhere
near that conversation right but for
London uh I think
I had almost no opening problems in in
any of the games I I showed some
important Novelties I won some games out
of the opening pretty much and uh so for
me yeah it's uh first and foremost I
need to be on good terms with people I
work with
um and then uh
once again from from purely from my
perspective with the you know the uh
the leaks that I have sort of Life leaks
yeah I I I I very much need somebody to
provide that structure to uh to be there
to kind of uh uh make me uh
understand what needs to be achieved in
like
show a path forward one of the things
once I was really really shocked by an
interview that or uh Boris basky gave
Boris said to the interviewer when asked
what his problems were and did he did
that he said I'm very lazy yes I'm a
very lazy player and I didn't work hard
and I was thinking to myself wait a
minute this guy was world champion how
can he how could he possibly say that uh
do you count yourself as one of those
lazy players absolutely or hard workers
no no I mean I've come to the sort of
realization that you know I can't really
sell this idea that I'm a sort of an
entirely lazy player like my career
probably and we should probably be
showing yeah it looks like the game is
about to end so yeah they're repeating
they are repeating uh but yeah I mean
obviously I have done some work over
over the years otherwise I probably
would not have had the sort of the
longevity in the game that exactly that
I had but once again I've seen people
work I I've been a part of of Jim
cramlington for a while I've had some
session works with sessions with Vichy
over the years long ago but I did I did
once or twice
to do some work with vision I've seen
how you know the proper Giants of the
game work how they approach that yeah
compared to them I don't work at all
right it's just I I was uh shocked when
I worked with Victor coach doy his work
capacity was like
several factors above anything I ever
experienced I just I didn't even know
what it was like to work and that was an
eye Awakening experience for me but I've
also been shocked by Gary Kasparov
because I thought this was somebody who
was an extraordinarily great natural
talent but the reality was he worked
incredibly hard on this game of course
yeah and he had a great uh backup team
as well expecting a repetition
Alejandro I'm kind of hoping for it
so we were so we don't go on and on huh
all right this game needs to end at some
point and the pro the thing is Lanier
already destroyed all of his Advantage
right if we were talking about a
position in which linear has chances
then yeah let's go let's let's fight it
out but the reason that we're talking
about so many different random things is
that there's no progress to be made here
I mean you can try this you can try that
but it all ends up in the same drawn
situations not particularly dangerous
for Huns so I'm okay with a draw at this
point let's go and uh we get on to the
rest day exactly and with this draw it
would mean that going into the rest day
just a few players have a plus one score
and they would be led by a Wesley so
because he has played more games than
absolutely it will it will remain a
three-way tie at the first just as it
was prior to the start of this
tournament
Wesley Wesley uh uh the person sort of
just off your screen there uh Hans
Neiman and Yani pomnishi who is also on
plus one with his loss very painful loss
in round one to Magnus Carlson now I'm
not being annulled yeah yeah
yep
and finally sorry for pressing you on
such matters but uh Jan he's getting
ready for world championship match
coming up 19. uh pardon me 2023.
um hard worker
I think it's become a very very hard
work yeah see I think there's you can
it's you
I think you can pretty much find the
moment where he chose sort of you know
choose life I chose something else yeah
he he chose life so to speak and uh uh I
think results more or less immediately
started showing him because we for for
years and years we knew just how gifted
he is there was never I think any doubt
in anyone's mind that this is an
incredible Talent generational yeah and
an incredible talent but he had so many
interests outside of Chess you know
but not but not just Hearthstone and uh
looks like Lanier chose Rook F2 oh yeah
we keep going guys
so I don't know what that does but he he
did not repeat here and uh
is still a twofold now that we we've
we've also had this position uh on move
42.
so it will be once again a bit of a
repetition just not exactly the same one
uh
and then Jan at some point thought okay
well I I appear to be quite good at
chess why not give it a proper try you
know why not actually dedicate more of
myself to to this game as I am sort of
unique uniquely suitable for gifting and
and uh his results immediately showed up
because uh when you couple the amount of
natural gift that he has with with work
there's absolutely no surprise that the
results improve and uh yeah I think
these days he works very very very uh
diligently he also has very good support
stuff he is now working with Nikita vich
golf uh who I mean I've praised poached
no no that wasn't that wasn't uh the the
the poaching that was just a kind of a
gradual thing where I was with with
mother of that it really did happen like
you know you know one moment I had one
moment I had a coach and the next moment
I didn't yeah it was
uh so yeah yeah I think is doing quite
well in terms of both his approach to uh
to the game and the support that he has
in terms of
uh friends and helpers
did the Breakthrough that Ding lyrics
surprise you in any way uh the comeback
I want to say the second half comeback
by ding Lorraine I found astonishing
your thoughts
it was very important I just wanted to I
I realized that you know I somehow like
I singled out Nikita and did not mention
peterleko which feels uh probably
incorrect shame on you yeah absolutely I
want to correct that mistake because
like if if you talk about people who
know uh an unbelievable amount about
Chess in general and chess theory in
particular like peterleka is just a it's
unbelievable the amount of of knowledge
he has and also his desire to continue
looking at things he is uh has lost
seemingly none of his enthusiasm for the
game now that he is sort of more in on
the coaching side of it yeah coaching
side as well yeah but yeah as for as for
Dean Lauren I think it was what was the
most impressive about it is that I think
a lot of people would have just kind of
given up right the the first time yes
the first half is so dispiriting right
and the situation in the tournament so
completely unpromising by this point
that a lot of people would have just
kind of dropped their hands and really
stopped stopped really caring but he
continued showing up and he continued
trying to win games and of course you
know things had to go his way for for
the result to be what it ended up being
but uh as I said I mean like so so many
people in his spot was just have
mentally gone home right
uh and we have seen this over the course
of Canada's tournaments people just kind
of completely checking out and saying
okay when is this over like right right
right
return tickets Please
please all right Rook D1 we it's not
been a three move repetition though no
but yeah too far apology right so but D2
would be instantly right yeah you can
claim uh King E3 loses a pawn and if you
put your King on C file uh King c367
check looks kind of weird why are we
doing this to ourselves right and King
situ Rook A1 also looks weird because uh
uh apart from A5 hanging there's also
okay to check threats exactly so by this
point we are basically not making a draw
just not to make a draw and seemingly
like actively making our position worse
I don't know what what would possess
linearly linear to do that yeah yeah
uh sorry uh Alejandra I wanted to ask
you the same question I asked Peter what
makes for a good trainer you've you've
played that role yourself
I have to agree with Peter that uh above
everything else is a how do you mesh
with the person that you're working with
I have had
instances where people have told me of
trainers they've had that were great
over the board they came up with a lot
of interesting ideas but you just
couldn't have dinner with them
and they kind of can ruin your
tournament when you're thinking about
how much time you're going to be
spending with this person it could just
destroy your your mood right and that's
an important part of the game as well
it's not just the opening ideas and the
Novelties and all this stuff so you
always see a lot of people hiring people
they like you see Grand Masters hiring
people they like not just that they're
good but that they bring something to
the table outside of Chas
for the moment we're still waiting on
linear I feel he's a little frustrated I
don't think you play Rook F2 unless
you're really frustrated with what's
happened in the position and I can
totally understand it he feels that he
had this game in the back and then
suddenly what is this easily drawn
rookan game where I'm not even pressing
exactly exactly
um one story I'd like to share which is
actually uh to my mind it an incredibly
beautiful story was it of I can say uh
competition I just don't remember the
year and Gary Kasparov was playing with
a couple of key Rivals including
Vladimir kramnik and vasil ivanchak
and the round was over and Gary uh came
to me and said uh uh can we have a
conversation could you meet me here did
we do and I said sure sure let me get my
code and Gary wanted to to leave the
playing Hall before he got accosted with
all of these autographs and it was one
of those nights in vikon Xavier that was
incredibly cold and it was snowing and
there were ice and snow on the road
there's very the visibility was low but
I saw these two figures walking in front
of me and I hurried to catch up with
them because I recognized Gary's coat
and as I approached uh very very muffled
quiet voices in Russian
and I just kind of came glided to the
two of them and it was Gary talking with
uh Yvonne Chuck
and vasil had lost a very
crucial game to Vladimir that and and
they were talking with one another
as we uh you do have Rook D2 and we do
have a three move repetition and we will
have a draw signed shortly and Gary
found the move that Basile was missing
he had disadvantage and he let it slip
and literally we arrived in the hotel
and Yvonne Chuck was healed
like this incredibly painful loss was
now exercised away and
Gary did that for arrival and I thought
it was an incredibly incredibly sweet
just something about that just really
was emotional yeah but they they both
are absolutely in love with the game so
for them I think it was very like
rivalry doesn't come into it there's an
interesting chess position to discuss in
truth to begotten it precisely and this
just trumps everything else and yeah I I
very can very very easily picture all of
that yeah I wasn't there but yeah it
wasn't it was a great moment a draw
Alejandro who would have suspected
not us not us it's been a while uh but
uh four draws sums up to today's round
Alejandro
yeah we got there very different ways
right uh we had this kind of Fortress
position between mvl and Jan we had this
gaming which Wesley was pressing a
little bit we had the insanity of the
prep of Favi and ramadarov defending
like a boss and then we had this game
which is a bit of a roller coaster
because it just felt that Lanier was
cruising cruising cruising cruising then
made an inexplicable decision right and
it all just kind of
fell off the rails into some kind of
easy draw right very surprising I think
to everyone how this game went it felt
that okay Hans got outplayed it happens
but that linear wasn't able to finish
this one off for me is the shock of the
round yeah I think I think that's that
very much does sum it sum it up that
preparation I have to say that far be
pulled on the board and in his interview
with Anastasia he kind of low-keyed it
like Queen E7 I was following a game of
Lavon and I kind of knew what was going
on and
but that wasn't that was unbelievable
yeah no this is uh that was this is what
you get from uh from 5B I mean he's not
the only one right now in the world who
can do this but he's definitely uh one
of the sort of the first names of your
tongue when you when you talk about uh
really really sort of uh high level
for those of you are joining this uh
late this was the position move 21 and
Fabi had more time on his clock than he
started the game right we have our
standings after four intriguing draws
Peter let's take a look and this is now
with with some players having having
played five games and some having played
four right uh Wesley there at the top on
three out of five and then Yanni
pomnishing Hans Neiman as we mentioned
they are on two and a half points but
out of four games not out of five
percent so they're also in effect tied
for for First with Wesley and then there
is a number of people on 50 Fabiano uh
alirez and feroza is on 50 percent
that is actually a linear is also I'm
doing a half out of five uh so it's a
it's a tie for fourth through sixth and
then uh three players are uh below 50
and those are somewhat surprisingly mvl
has been playing really well this year
right live on our onion and shark Mommy
and again tomorrow is a free day so
don't join us tomorrow but be sure to
join us for round six as uh well wait a
minute that's like five games
put that game on uh hold there for just
a second there you go
hi uh for Lanier
uh Peter the honors
yeah and as you can see in the pairings
we have alireza playing White against
the somewhat struggling
hunts is White against Wesley so they
want to really is White against
and there is also a very very
interesting game there between uh yeah
absolutely absolutely again free day
tomorrow as the players uh hey may hey
guys it's an empty Hall why don't we
just sit down and have a good uh but I
don't understand why we don't have
somebody
going there and telling that they need
to jump to the interview
[Laughter]
I don't know sometimes there's just a
chess game and you've got to find the
truth
Peter
I I understand both of those uh both of
those sentences yeah they're full of
words I have seen before let's put it on
yeah exactly when you've uh in your
career obviously you've played some
great games some fantastic you've had
some just amazing post games oh yeah uh
sessions who in particular just stood
out for you that you just said oh my God
um it's it's hard to choose because I
mean the culture of postmortems is kind
of slowly slowly disappearing I think
largely because there is this feeling of
futility because you will spend like two
and a half hours discussing things with
your opponent and then eventually you
will get up you will get your code you
will get well you will get your phone
from the locker you will switch it on
and it will tell you half of what you
just saw yeah and the phone will explain
to you exactly in which way you're an
absolute idiot which is not which is not
really something that many of us
particularly look forward to relish yeah
but yeah there's been some some really
fantastic postmortems like the one that
you know the the recording of it exists
which is why it's maybe the one that
came came to mind first I I played this
really kind of a weird
uh funky game against Magnus and vike in
2018 and then and then we actually went
and sat down and analyzed it for like an
hour and uh
bits of bits and pieces of this exist on
on YouTube and we're recorded yeah
these days basically I think
post-mortems happen when the game is so
out of the ordinary that you should want
to enjoy relieving it and like at least
scratching at the surface a bit and they
are fewer and far between sadly but in
in Years Gone by like I remember I'm
sure you have very very similar
experiences like you play a game against
Alexander bilevsky yeah and then the
postmortem is longer than the game
because because he just doesn't let go
like he wants to know exactly he wants
to know and in those years your phone
would not tell you right why you were an
idiot so you actually like derived some
information like you you you got some
version of the truth through looking at
the position anyway I remember I I won a
very interesting game against him in
some
uh grunfeld in I think Madrid 96 it was
possibly
and then literally I think the
postmodern was longer than the game I
think we did we definitely sat there for
three hours maybe maybe not four but
three hours for sure because the
position was so interesting and so and
so exciting and also uh Alexander
ganderkovic he he likes looking at chess
absolutely and there you see the
security measures uh in effect as the
players get scanned coming and going as
we see and uh our colleague Anastasia
getting in the first questions before
ourselves
don't know if that is actually happening
I think she is I think before he got one
okay I missed something okay like uh she
had a little recording going on there
and uh this free day uh very very much
needed I think yeah for not just
ourselves but for the players to reset
everything about the grand chess tour
and now like you say more points in the
ecosystem absolutely yeah
and uh prep too how deep is the prep uh
in terms they're they're going to be
playing tomorrow oh an apartment they're
going to have a free day tomorrow how
much of tomorrow is going to be devoted
to preparing for around six seven eight
people I can I can answer for like what
what would be my preferred way of
spending the rest day that would be more
or less no chess in it I think as little
yeah you need to in particular if you
have the support staff to you know
provide you with some idea of what to do
in round six I would prefer to have it
as chess free as possible I think this
tournament is uh difficult enough
without you uh overloading your brain
with with additional info and the
freshness for for the game after the the
rest they've always felt much much more
important to me than you know an
additional I don't know three hours
which in my case you will never guess
what the first move will be anyway it's
like what's the point but I'm sure it
differs from person to person like that
would be just my preferred one Alejandro
what's your system position as to for
example Fabiano how much time do you
think he's going to vote of the rest day
tomorrow for his preparations for the
remaining four rounds if I will devote
some time to analyze at least something
for the next game the one coming up
especially since it's a big one he'll be
playing Black against young always need
to be very well prepared for those that
being said the morning is probably going
to be tennis then it'll probably be like
some long launch I mean there's going to
be a prep but it's not going to be the
eight hours of work people sometimes
expect these players to do in the rest
day that's definitely not going to
happen right I like the I like the
tennis if you joined yeah my year is
definitely Perfect
The Mention Of Fitness yeah you brought
your sneakers I did not actually bring
any proper Footwear but it's not going
to stop me if they stop him from beating
us I've heard you're a demon on the
course well I'm not true no no 100 mile
per hour serves I served one ace it will
be the proudest moment of my year I'm
pretty sure like as long as I remember
it happened
but now you've reminded me so I'm back
to you know yeah oh oh Ace all puffed up
and and did it like swerve off just it
hit and Grace no it was just a good
serve which I think basically was mainly
through the element of surprise because
I think that'll do I think I think
Christian just thought what was that why
is this coming at some kind of speed you
know instead of just being a lob you
know like right
exactly aleandra how's your game how's
your tennis game it's funny because we
have we went with a bunch of people over
like seven or eight of us it was alireza
and viel Christian Favi Peter Levon was
there and I would say like nobody was
too far below or too far above average
between us you know for Chinese players
were like here way here below the camera
but between us you know we're like a
competitive bunch of people so it's
actually a fun game right yeah it was it
was a good mix in in terms of uh skills
yeah very very very very very nice as we
uh we are actually uh getting ready for
Hans to join Alejandro but as we saw uh
it got delayed by the postmortem as well
as passing through the security check
and uh we'll see how I'm coming
absolutely
uh
yeah so you don't realize I was on
camera there for a second
just taking a break yeah
just
resting my eyes
but it's all uh what what it's all about
there
but uh let's talk a little bit about the
upcoming events again tomorrow's free
then we have our four uh games in a row
then we get ultimate moves uh the trash
talking uh just what the world needs
right Festival uh that is unique to uh
St Louis that will be coming up along
with the Fisher random Peter and then a
bit of a break and in early October the
US Open and the US Women's uh women's
chess championships are coming to St
Louis starting from October the 3rd so
very very exciting uh summer leading
into the fall of Chess and it has been a
very long year in terms of events here
in St Louis is quite a number of
Classics also getting played these
normal episodes uh very nice that the
club hosts these many events and a lot
of players are getting their Norms from
the tournaments here in St Louis again
let's just review for our audience uh
the GCT standings uh let's uh let's take
a look at this uh Maxime led to the
beginning prior to the beginning of the
single card but he's not doing so well
so far in this tournament he hasn't he's
opening up the door yeah meaning that
everybody else has definitely has a look
in and Wesley looking pretty good yeah
Wesley uh one plus one the only person
with a realistic chance of winning the
GCC tour who is currently in plus
because he is tied for for First with
Jan who on 16 points doesn't really have
much of a shot but to help Ali Raza is
at 50 I believe so yeah people people
are on 50 some of the people who are
very interested but yeah uh Wesley
currently uh looking pretty good but
everything I think the way the standings
are right now everything is absolutely
wide open
and at last we have Hans and Neiman in
studio with Alejandro over to you
Alejandro thank you guys and we do have
Hans Neiman Hans seemed like a tough
position you came up with this
interesting idea we hadn't seen before
with C5 tell us a little bit about that
yeah well uh first of all this bishop B3
move uh it's slightly uh it's not the
main line the main line is actually not
of one yeah and I had some ideas there
which I thought would be a nice surprise
and uh so that was my main point
um
but Bishop B3 is sort of the uh stopping
Knight G6 because then there's D4
so the point of behind Knight to E7 is
that you can't play D4 because of Knight
C6 and this is a common idea this is
also an idea there was a game actually
let's say the pawn is on A2 the pawn is
on A7 and the bishop is on B6 yes this
idea is a position there was a game um I
think uh alexenko Carolina from the
candidates 2021 so this idea of going
back and forth is a nice little trick
especially because he played Knight D2
first yes this is like a You could argue
it's a slightly inaccurate order
um
because you sort of aren't able to
punish 97 directly like let's say you
played until 92 Rook E1
castles H3 uh let's say 97 now then uh D
D4 and you can sort of punish it
directly
um so the main idea was just to sort of
avoid this immediate D4 Break
um which is by getting sort of a
semi-close position that I had more
knowledge about so okay we can go back
to C5 yes
so yeah I didn't check it too much it
was sort of a spur of the moment I was
not too sure about what opening to play
uh
I could have been better prepared in
this specific game of course um but
obviously Knight of one I don't remember
you know of course what I remember is
that actually A5 is most precise move
here in the specific yeah yeah that's
what I remembered and then uh you play
Bishop to E6 and then I and then this
sort of weird move Knight to C4
um when I saw this I was like this is a
bit weird I don't think the engine will
give this
I don't remember I think maybe Rick C8
is a move um but this looked pretty fine
to me it's like a weird Marshall yeah
and um I guess you could sort of have uh
187 isn't that bad an emotional because
you're sort of always stopping the D4
break which is the main positional break
in these positions is usually D4 and
it's never really working here so I
thought that it was possible for him to
sort of lack a direct plan which he kind
of did he went he brought the Knight 2
to E3 which I don't think from what I
remember Knight to G3 and then sort of
ideas with Knight H2 Knight G4 and
Knight H1 and if I was the most precise
so I didn't think this was so critical
but um I think my main mistake was
actually after the move uh was Bishop B8
um yes so if instead of Bishop A7 so
after he plays him with A5 I should of
course understand uh that the idea is to
play uh Bishop A4 and C4 this is sort of
the only way that he can time the
closing of the position uh to where I
don't get direct counter play so in
anticipation of this bishop A4 C4 idea I
should of course play Knight to G6
um and and Bishop B8 is even stupider um
in a specific position because as we saw
in the game the B4 brick the bishop is
on B8 yeah and uh it's basically wasting
two tempos so let's G6 here yeah and I'm
again preparing D5 Bishop A4 Queen C8 C4
uh White could be even lost after Knight
to F4 attacking D3 uh oh because the
queen is not on C8 here so I just missed
yeah so Queen to C8 yes C4 and out of
four and uh here with Bishop H3 is
coming
um and uh maybe even if it's pretty sure
isn't coming
I don't really see how I'm worse here
um even I can play G5 to consolidate
this uh I think I had a game against
Fabi and like uh some some online
tournaments a rapid test championship
and he had he has very similar structure
just reminds of that but of course I
should play Knight G6 right preparing uh
this this entire sequence so um this was
just Bishop B was was quite stupid
um because I just underestimated this
and underestimated his move Knight to D5
which was extremely strong
um I think it's the only move
to sort of maintain control because
and then here he has sort of a long-term
positional Edge but why is that Bishop
on B8 like what is it doing there
hitting the D6 E5 diagonal like it's
completely counterintuitive I just
underestimated so it was I was
thankfully during the game but I did not
understand the seriousness of my mistake
probably because the vision still wasn't
that bad but I still felt some pressure
later on I think there was the next
critical moment was um when he played
Knight takes B5
oh all the way down there yeah yeah
because again you can go through it
quickly but but before this
um how did you feel about this position
I thought if you put 96 I was slightly
worried right so 96 King F6 Rook G3 and
uh I'm sort of G3 yeah Rook F3 yeah Rick
F3 and I'm Rook G3 right or what do you
mean uh after King seven you mean no no
no but why not King E5 Are Not Afraid ah
okay okay yeah and unfortunately this is
kind of icic so that that oh so you can
get it with the tempo okay yeah I was
afraid of some some stuff like this uh
um uh yeah so this that is a nice trick
so uh yeah King seven Network G3 yes
then then uh then Rook G3 then maybe
have Rook F6 though so that's
okay it's not clear but you have Rook C4
I guess then The Rook is coming yeah
this is not looking great maybe I can go
Knight A7 but it's just so ugly right
it's not clear where the Breakthrough is
I don't think it's objectively lost yet
but it's certainly considering where we
started uh this is he's definitely
gotten everything he could he could hope
for but um
yeah perhaps I did not uh see that's not
a fake trick immediately but um I
definitely could feel some danger
because the nmb5 is just sort of
just it's just there but it's
was obviously to stunt the the the E
file but once he was able to open up the
position
uh open up uh you know the the
with d with the D4 break I misunderstood
I missed sorry misevaluated uh the
strength of this movement and how uh
poorly are by not we've been misplaced
yeah the Andrews actually do say the
objective of you were lost uh 96. 96
well about a plus four plus four yeah
yeah that's so you must have felt great
relief to see Nike techno of course yeah
yeah I thought that it was just an easy
draw after this
um
uh so yeah Knight takes pontex and you
are not worried after this no no I don't
think that let's say King Rick takes B5
um yeah if you play Rook F3 which maybe
made your life a little easier a little
bit easier but still after Rook uh Rook
of three King King F6
um I mean sorry Rick takes B5 King F6
King F2 King E3 and uh and King E5 and
King three and here um I was looking
okay I could play Ricky 79 but he
suggested that he's the most concrete is
just to play Rook to F4 and uh and then
just take an H4 and once the H Pawn is
sort of Taken I just don't think uh that
you you can sort of break right because
anytime you take this Pawn the E the e d
Pawn sort of collapse and then the a
pawners not really enough to to to
convert so this was definitely a
decent defense but yeah I could I really
could feel that the 96 was
was coming but thankfully I was not if I
if I realized how bad it was I might
have hesitated leading to uh so
sometimes ignorance is truly Bliss when
it comes to evaluating positions you
know like for example aronium in our
game he was just chilling you know he
was like he was like some of these top
guys are just chilling and I'm like
looking at them like they're crazy but
it's just sort of when you're when
you're relaxed I guess you can defend
better but sometimes if sometimes if you
realize you're losing it makes things
worse you know right and well you didn't
collapse and actually got back fully
into the game made an important draw
here were the black pieces you're
feeling about the game in general
I think the preparation
um first of all it's decent it's decent
the black games against these top guys
are ridiculous you know because they're
just lenia is just such a an esteemed
theoretician
so that was slightly intimidating
um so the opening uh perhaps I think
that I'm slightly disappointed that I
should have been a bit more familiar
with this position but I think in
general he just played quite well and uh
um I think I kept my calm uh because
because if I'm lost over 96 then I was
it was very bad long before that there
wasn't really much I could maybe there's
something I could do but very very
unpleasant for most of the game
Hans we got to speak about the elephant
in the room you've asked to have some
words
yeah so so
um there's been a lot of things that
have been you know the Social Media
stuff and I just have a lot of things to
say and uh
uh you know I've thought a lot about
what what I want to say and how I'm
going to say it and I think I can just
you know maybe I'll forget something but
let's you know let's just discuss a few
things so first of all my accent you
know like I'm sorry this is just the
first it's just like this is just the
most funny thing because if you want me
to speak like an American right now I
don't I can't even tell but for the last
two years I have lived in a suitcase
traveling around Europe playing chess
non-stop I spend so much time working on
chess that I simply don't go outside and
socialize with people who speak fluent
English
like this is just this is just one thing
I want to talk about I'm just before I
say anything like I have spent the last
two years
not spending any time in America and
even when I'm in America I don't go
outside other when I pick up my food I'm
just too busy with chess
so all these things saying that like I'm
faking an accent and that like I'm
putting on some facade that is like the
most ridiculous thing I've ever said and
and if anyone is using my my newfound uh
accent to make any conclusions about
anything chess related is like
absolutely insane because like I've lit
I don't spend any time in America I only
speak to chess players who have bad
English so you maybe think maybe it's
product of my environment okay maybe
that was a bit too okay and then okay
first of all the Magnus opening okay now
uh let's get to get to that so people
were saying that uh there was no idea
why I checked this well first of all you
know people are absolute idiots because
the explanation I'm gonna give is going
to make you all look all the top gems
look like total idiots so
the position first of all they said
there was Zero game there was a game
check the database there's this thing in
chess called transpositions okay now
when he played the move A3 of course I'm
expecting to move Knight to three now
let's say in the Catalan no let's let's
show it because this is just this is
just embarrassing
um this is absolutely embarrassing and
I'm sorry if I'm coming off hostile it's
just a passionate thing for me
um so let's go let's go to the so after
Bishop so let's say the Catalan let's
say the Catalan with the Knight of three
month old yeah so let's say you plan out
of three okay D5 G3 Bishop B4 check wait
there's a move of Knight C3 here and
then after castles there's a move Bishop
G2 and after DC4 A3 Bishop C3 bc3 C5 we
here we have we in chess we call it
transposition now
let's say theoretically Magnus is
playing I've been playing quite a lot of
Catalan recently
so perhaps I'm looking at the Catalan
and I'm thinking how is Magnus gonna
surprise me in the Catalan there's this
weird move Knight C3 I remember some
instances where he's going for these
very structures so this is a perfectly
reasonable thing and during the moment I
did not think about it because it was
such a small part of my preparation but
simply the pattern I recognized and and
also I spent 15 minutes after the move
A3 the reason I spent 15 minutes after
the move A3 I don't know if the time
stamps are there uh they are actually
yeah so so how much there was one moment
I spent yeah that's okay anyways I was
thinking more from an hour 30. in
general I've spent 50 minutes now after
the move A3 you know take and now I play
DC4
at this point since it's not a direct
transition I should obviously take some
time to make sure that the position is
going to be transposed properly here's a
move Queen A4
I don't know this is a move that I was
concerned with the game but now there's
Bishop D7
I thought in the game Queen takes E4
Bishop C6 Knight F3 and then I thought
Knight to D7 he plays castles I thought
Bishop to D5 and then I play C5
and then I thought this was my plan so I
understood at least not in most precise
way but I understood that there was
going to be the Knight of three thus
leading to her transposition so this is
why I took some time people are saying
that that I'm taking time and then I'm
making up that I meant like I checked it
because it's a transposition I I'm
spending extra time to make sure that
the transmission is correct because it's
a world champion and he's just sprung a
very dangerous trap now if I don't know
this it can be very dangerous but
the fact that it's not a miracle it's
actually me being extremely tedious and
going through every single possible
transposition or or a sort of line that
he could play in the catalog that's the
first thing okay I need to there's just
so many uh so many things that uh so I
think those are the main things and then
okay of course and then the fact that my
analysis is is not at the level of a top
player
for am I getting against fruja you need
to understand that when I play the move
Queen to G3
I did not elaborate this during the game
this is a purely psychological move
if if clearly people don't know anything
about farooja his style how to beat him
the way to beat him is to attack him he
really really hates being attacked and
the main ways he lose loses is by being
attacked now we had a game in Miami
where I got an attack
and and he completely collapsed and I
studied previous games knowing it's like
so when I see the position and I say
queen G3 I think to myself okay I highly
doubt based on my intuitive feeling that
I'm losing here I don't feel the need
to calculate every single variation
because I'm confident that there's no
way first he's going to take and if he
takes he's going to be shared shitless
okay okay so that's that's this game now
after after the games first of all
you're extremely tired and and uh it's
extremely difficult
sometimes to recollect uh the the things
that you're talking about the moves the
variations you know it's not like I'm
coming in here full of energy right and
especially in the analysis uh okay you
can debate full of energy but like it's
not sometimes you just you just forget
things so so the notion that I simply
can't speak about Chess and a high level
is completely ridiculous
um I'm a very intuitive player I made a
gut call to play Queen G3 and it paid
off and and and uh even if you look at
the pattern my games you know it's uh
I'm not
I'm clearly missing many many chances
and it's extremely human chest no no
okay so this is I think is that
everything about the interviews have I
covered everything that's up to you no
no I I have there because there's been
interviews have been a key Point
um so that's just something I wanted to
cover that people are ridiculous okay
like my accent is I it's I don't even I
can't even realize because I'm numb to
it I'm numb to it but this is not this
is not a facade I'm sorry I just don't
socialize much because I work so hard at
chess like I I'm literally sorry I like
have I delete all social media I sit
inside I study chess and I leave to pick
up my delivery food twice a day that is
my life I enjoy it okay and if my
English is not as native as it is
uh sometimes I'm sorry but when I speak
to let's say an American friend it comes
right back right it's something
subconscious
so maybe now it's coming back anyways so
in terms of interviews that's fine right
so so now I noticed throughout social
media
um a lot of people uh who who I once had
respect for who who um who who I once
sort of uh looked up to a lot of My
Heroes Have Decided to hop on this
bandwagon now there have been a lot of
speculation and there's a lot of things
set and I and and and I think I'm the
only one who knows the truth so
so there's a few things that they need
to come to light
so first of all there's the the
situation with chess.com now people have
uh there have said that my chest.com was
was banned twice okay so this is what
happened when I was 12 years old
I was uh with a friend and I was playing
title Tuesday
and uh I was playing and you came over
on the iPad with an engine and I was 12
years old and he said you know uh he
started giving me the moves I was a
child I had no idea what happened now
this happened once in an online
tournament
I was just a child and
nothing happened then now four years
later when I was 16 years old during my
streaming career
in an absolutely ridiculous mistake and
on Raider games after that I had another
when I was 12 I've never ever in my life
cheated in an over-the-board game in an
online tournament if they were in
unrated games and I'm admitting this and
and I'm saying my truth because I do not
want any misrepresentation I am proud of
myself that I learned from that mistake
and now have given everything to chess I
have sacrificed everything for chess and
I do everything I can to approve so I'm
gonna get sorry basically
so
and some I wanted to gain some rating
you know I just wanted to get higher
rates we could play Stronger players so
I cheated in random games on trust.com
now I was confronted I confessed and
this is the single biggest mistake of my
life and I'm completely ashamed and I'm
telling the world because
I do not want any misrepresentation and
I do not want rumors I have never
cheated in an over the board game
other when I was 12 years old I have
never ever ever and I would never do
that that is the worst thing I could
ever do cheat in a tournament with prize
money now I made that mistake and this
is something I thought something I was
doing consistently never when I was
streaming did I cheat never did I
misrepresent my strength so I made this
mistake I was confronted by trust.com I
had fully admitted and I stopped playing
interest.com now what I want people to
know about this is that
I'm deeply deeply sorry for my mistake
and I know that my actions have
consequences and I suffer those
consequences during that time I
completely step stepped away from a very
lucrative streaming career I stopped
playing in all events and I lost a lot
of close friendships and relationships
that meant a lot to me so I assure you
maybe I did not suffer but I'm putting
myself in the public now I could be
ruining reputation for my life but I
want to tell the truth now this happened
I'm deeply deeply ashamed of it but keep
in mind I was 16 years old I never
wanted to hurt anyone these random games
I would never could even fathom doing it
in a real game
now
unfortunately now there has been a
targeted attack and uh some recent
events have made it really really
difficult for me to not stop speaking
after the game against Magnus obviously
Magnus puts his tweet clearly
some attenuations and then everyone
starts to pile I get an email from
chess.com saying that they've privately
removed access to my trust.com account
and that they have
Uninvited me from the global Chess
Championship now three days ago I met
with someone very high up in chess.com
at the stingfield cup had amazing
amazing words but because of this gaming
it's Magnus because of what he said they
have decided to completely remove me for
their website now this if this is big
and now this is after I have already
fully admitted and they have the best
cheat detection in the world they know
that I'm not a cheater and that I have
given I give everything interesting I
work so hard and I I chess is my entire
life okay now if they're going to try to
think that I'm going to be silent about
what has happened it is completely
ridiculous I met with Danny wrench at
Miami and I would and and I genuine was
the person who confronted me and I was
deeply deeply indebted to him for
handling the the the band privately and
giving me the chance to redeem myself
now after being after being not playing
chess.com events I went to over the
world tournaments and I decided to
myself that the only way to make up for
my mistake was to prove to myself and to
prove to others that I could win myself
now that has been my mission and that is
why I've lived in a suitcase for two
years that is why I've played 260 games
in one year that is why I've trained 12
hours a day because I have something to
prove and now that just.com has
certainly decided to hop on magnus's uh
insinuations hikaru's very direct
accusations now they see the opportunity
okay we're just gonna get rid of this I
believe that this is completely unfair
this is a target attack and if you look
at my games this is not it has nothing
to do with my games so why do you
specifically why do you why does the CEO
trust come to me and say we're looking
forward to having the global Chess
Championship we're looking forward
to you playing on our events and then
right when I beat Magnus they decide to
remove my account and not let me play in
the tournaments this is absolutely
ridiculous and they've only done this
because what Magnus said with picardo
says and that the entire social media
and Chess World is completely attacking
me and undermining me but and they maybe
would think that I would be afraid to
tell the entire world that I cheated in
some random games and I cheated in a
tournament when I was 12 years but I'm
not afraid because I know who I am and I
know the chess player that I'm and I
know what what I give to chess so I'm
not going to be scared to be manipulated
and to be conspired against to try to
ruin my chess career when I know what
has happened so you know this
as far as Magnus this is absolutely the
fact that he did it without saying it he
knew the insinuations that would follow
if you look at social media every single
platform I'm getting thousands of
messages not thouser there are thousands
of tweets everyone is attacking me
and and uh some people are defending me
and I really appreciate those but when I
see people attack me with absolutely
zero evidence I you know people have
zero I'm the only person who knows what
happened and I'm telling you guys that
this is this is the truth now I I you
know I really do not think that I would
have the courage to to say this but some
people I'm very thankful to people who
who helped me make decision and you know
what um
this is this is the truth and uh I would
really and now Magnus can uh and Hikaru
uh uh Hikaru I've never ever cheated
against you in an online game and it
never happened
and uh and and and the most ridiculous
part uh and uh this uh is is that um you
know the same players that in this
tournament are in scenery that I'm
cheating
have also made insinuations about people
who are making in situations by me so
let's just say the people who are saying
these things about me
they're not that innocent themselves so
it's it's very ridiculous
um so so you know I'm sorry if I'm I'm
rambling but the main thing that I want
to say is that I am not going to let uh
chess.com I'm not going to let Magnus
Carlson I'm not going to let
hikaranakamura the three arguably
biggest entities in chess simply slander
my reputation
um because the question is why are you
going to remove me from chess.com right
after I beat Magnus just uh what's
what's with the timing so
um I I would first of all you know again
I'm deeply deeply sorry for what it's
happened is the biggest single rig out
of my life I could and even now to look
back on it I cannot recognize myself to
give context I was 16 years old I don't
want to make excuses but I was living
alone in New York City it was peak of
the pandemic and at that I have been
financially independent since I was 16
years old I left my family and I was
living alone at 16 I had rent to pay and
I wanted to you know and I was willing
to do anything to grow my stream so of
course I made a childish mistake and I
will have to live with that but I'd
rather live with that with everyone
knowing the truth instead of people
making simple uh you know
speculation about about me because this
is the full truth and I'd like to see if
everyone else can can actually tell
their truth when chass.com sends you
this email did they give a reason no
reason they're just informed they're
just no reason they said I I try to log
into my trust.com account I wanted to
check the games and uh they said we have
I could log in sending me email
a few hours later they've rescinded we
have privately so they didn't want to
ban me publicly because I didn't have to
give a reason and they think that they
can scare me and because they think that
I'm not going that I'm not going to talk
about it because I'm afraid to admit
this but this is an online I did this
when I was 12 years old
and then when I and then the SEC other
times I did it was not even in a uh over
the world tournament it's not even in a
prize money online it was an absolute
random games and I understand that some
people might lose respect for me for
this but it is my greatest mistake and
I've done everything I've done in the
past few years has been to to make up
for that mistake and that is my entire
purpose as a chess player is to prove to
myself and for others that I'm trying to
to do better and I hope that my results
uh and my commitment and my hard work
has shown that I have I've I've learned
from this and that I'm uh I I learned my
lesson Hans how does it feel to play the
rest of the tournament knowing that
everything here is surrounding uh the
Singapore cup Magnus left and clearly uh
something is happening how are you able
to focus because you know when obviously
before after the game I opened social
media and I can't get my eyes off it
because uh every single person in their
in their whole family has an opinion and
of course you sort of get dragged into
it and I'm reading it and I'm uh it
obviously was really disheartening
seeing so many people you know
I would like to say this is when you
know when I was eight years old
um I went Magnus Carlson came to an
exhibition in California and my mom took
me there I just started or maybe I was
nine I just started playing chess and he
was doing a blindfold symbol and there
was an auction to bid on it
and uh when when they were bidding on it
uh it got up to a thousand dollars and
it became too much and my mom was like
no no if you really really want it we'll
do it you know she was gonna really to
make a financial sacrifice so I could
play and I said no no Mom one day I'm
gonna play him for free
okay and instead I got assigned big
chess piece and you know that happened
but to me to see my hero
um to see my absolute hero um
try to to to
Target
um try to ruin our reputation ruin my
chest career and to do it in such a a
frivolous way is really really
disappointing
um because you know you spend your
entire life looking up for someone and
then you meet them and then you know my
dream came true I lived my dream for a
day beating Magnus and then all of this
happened so
um
I'm sorry I forgot what your initial
question was how do you focus on the
sink fill cup well you know when I sit
on the board it's pure it's all chess so
even even today maybe there are moments
during the game where my mind wandered
but when I'm playing chess that's all
that's that's all there was on my mind
uh and hopefully it'll stay that way
does this bothering you fuel you does it
make you absolutely it absolutely fuels
me you know my my fuel
um has always been maybe not anger but
spite has been has been a strong fuel
for me when I was uh started to play
chess and the Netherlands my school
teacher told me I wasn't good enough
and that certainly fueled me I've always
been been one to prove people wrong and
uh this this absolutely fuels me and
this makes me want to win the tournament
even more and uh you know I can I can
come to the game I can completely strip
you want to do any fair play check to me
you want I don't care because I I know
that I'm clean and uh they could
literally tell me those ridiculous
things they want me to strip fully naked
I'll do it I don't care because I know I
know that I'm clean and uh I'm willing
to subject myself you want you want me
to play in a in a in a closed box with
zero electronic transmission I don't
care you know name whatever you guys
want
um I'm here to win and that's going to
be my goal regardless
Hans very candid words guys any
questions on the contrary a very
heartfelt interview
uh your motion spoke for itself uh Hans
all we can say is enjoy your free day
stay away from social media and keep
your head in the game you know I think
much of this needed to be said and I
think it's very good that it has been
said uh and uh yeah thanks thanks for
coming in and doing this yeah and uh I
just uh before I go I just thank you
guys for for giving me the chance to
speak and I'm sure many many people are
are going to be seeing this and I just
would like to to hope that everyone
keeps an open mind and uh and
understands that uh chess is my entire
life and uh I've sacrificed everything
for this game and I'm willing to do
anything to to to prove and to improve
myself and to improve at chess so so
this is I'm sorry but the chess is
everything to me so uh I think that's
all that's all I need to say absolutely
you've had plenty hands thanks for
joining us here guys we're coming up on
a rest day hostel on plus one trying to
win this tournament yes he is and again
uh Peter very heartfelt words yeah it
feels like we really should not be
talking right now this this needs to be
how this broadcast ends because like we
we are not adding any value to what Hans
said here yeah fair enough and of course
tomorrow is our free day we have shown
you the pairings for round six but shall
we just show the pairings for round six
coming up wait a minute today is Tuesday
Thursday Thursday here we go here it is
uh Peter please do the honorso plays
white again
plays White against Wesley so uh Battle
of the leaders there uh levonian is
White against Mexico and Jan will be
playing what the white pieces against
Fabiano Caron wonderful and to close the
show we're gonna go over to Anastasia
yeah and she's going to share her final
thoughts of uh yet again an amazing day
here at the Sig Bill Gap Anastasia
thank you yes sir I don't know actually
what we had after this interview I mean
I'm completely shocked because I was
watching it just nearby you said to stay
away from social media but yeah social
media comes after you and we still you
know we're checking those those comments
and of course amid we're following the
news and the development of the story of
course the development of the sinful cup
and I can tell you that yes I'm in still
social media is booming and we are
posting all the time without stop I mean
all the players give their comments and
I managed to also get interviews with
linear Dominguez and also Fabiano Carana
gave his comments after the game so all
this you can find in our Twitter and
Instagram accounts as well as later
probably will be published in the
YouTube channels so keep following the
sync World Cup stay with us and I mean
all the best time it was really a crazy
day
I think we're all in agreement on that
one uh Peter
rest day tomorrow we'll be back on air
same time on Thursday thank you everyone
good night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited